All right. All right. Like I say y'all, it is a Monday. Uh the Monday before Q4. So, everybody I know in business moving and grooving, but definitely uh want to get some of the folks in here that will be speaking at Q4 and teaching at Q4 and then go ahead and get you guys some assets right now that you can take and use. That's what it's all about. But this room will be open until 4, but it's not like the summit where I'm
going to keep teaching and and showing. Few of the brothers have booked a time to where they're going to pull up. Chad Erington's going to be here at 1. SBS will be here at 3. It's early for keys. letting him know. Y'all can put in your chat. Put in the chat what are your direct need. What do you what were you able to take from the summit and which part of the summit spoke to you the most? What skill? What plugins you
feel we should make for you to be better off?
um especially for Q4 but also the future. Are we starting our business today? Are we starting? Do we need what skills do we need to create? And I'll go in here create skills. I have the skills. The other ones I'll send to your email. So, let me show you how to apply skills so that when the skills come to your email, you can apply them directly, quickly, swiftly, and how to move them. All right. All right. So, y'all, I
mean, what's the word? I'm not see I'm not seeing no chat. What we building? It's only seven of us in here right now. Come on. Let's let's less less. That's why keep saying less.
Hey Spinn, how are you this morning?
I'm healthy. Shane, what's the word? What we looking like over
I am great.
there?
So you guys shared a lot of great knowledge this weekend. I'm just trying to um order my steps to actually implement it because I had the pleasure and the blessing of you all setting me up pretty strong.
what I've, you know, it's been a couple of months since you guys created the app for me and I've made additions, But before I learned about this um AI summit, I was prepared to launch like doing outbound calls to my corporate clients to secure the wellness app. Well, the uh actually it's a personal effectiveness app. Um but from what I learned this week, and I need to kind of back up, I need to start with the interview
to make sure that I'm positioning the product properly. Um, and then from there really just update all of my scripts and my outbound calls. Um, I was wondering also if you suggested that or if Hitsuyo Aku, I don't know if he's here, but suggest that I go into GitHub to find like the latest, you know, uh, code or automation that might help me to either secure clients or to build upon the app that we already have.
That's definitely not a GitHub thing. We just want to make sure that it's connected. And since he did make that connection, um, no more building.
There's no there's definitely no more building. No more additional features. Um, no more pretty to it. It is starting to go ahead and move with these sales, creating these scripts that align.
Right.
So, that's where we're going to go next with
is what's the best way like how would you direct me to get started being so
that.
I've taken like weeks to do this but now would your suggestion be for me to confirm the scripts I even built a prospecting tool in the app to organize like who I'm reaching out to to gather emails and numbers like that but now I see goji berry so I'm kind of like h should I use what I have or should advance. What What would you
Okay. So,
suggest?
you said that you built an outreach tool within the app.
It's a
This is this is when I hear a app has a function for a user has a function for a user or function for a corporation but also has a function to feed itself.
Is that what you're
Um,
saying?
so basically what I did is I created a database where I can upload CSV files
Right.
with contacts that I have asked Claude to scrub the internet for. CL Claude has a little bit of limitation with LinkedIn, but I do have um like I said about 300 contacts, which is nothing, but um I have about 300 contacts mostly well in Georgia that I can start calling. So it basically well actually I could show you what I have but it has my scripts my my phone scripts my email scripts my objections and also the client
or prospect database. built into the tool.
So, but it's built into the Brick House Mindset app though.
It's not available for clients. This is just for me.
I know,
It's kind of just based
but it is it inside of the same app.
um when I go to lovable. Yes, I do update within the
Yeah. Well, that needs to be separate.
app.
That's what I'm saying. It's 111. Um, new and menty is an app for users and corporation just like the Brick House Mindset app. It has no outreach tool. It has no additional tool inside of it. Here go. Here go you right here. So to build an outreach tool like your very own goji berry if you will, it's a mistake to have it inside of the brain and the uh in the body of the same application that you're serving the users. Even
if you say hey well this is not for users to use. If you have a lovable account, every internal app should be separate. The Brick House Mindset app needs to stay the app. The Breakhouse Mindset app landing page needs to be different on lovable.
All
Your outreach CMO CRM tool needs to be separate on
right.
lovable. And you're saying,
Thanks.
and then you're saying,"Oh, well, Claude has this, this." You're making one app think of everything. Serve the users, serve you with outreach, outbound, CRM. You went to one, you went into the inside of one tool and made it do everything.
Yeah, I did cuz I I So, you're saying they all need to be separate projects with so I can prompt
Yes. Yes.
Claude to separate them now.
Um, you're going to go like this. Um, chill here. Saw you what you did real quick while I do
I hit. So,
this.
basically what I did is you all built me the app and then I went in lovable and I built a prospecting tool which um basically I asked Claude to scrub prospects from the internet and LinkedIn to give me a list of prospects that I can reach out to. So, I have a prospecting database where I can move forward like my email sequence like I I emailed this person on day one and then this is the email I'm sending on day three.
So, it has my call scripts, my email scripts, the progression of each opportunity, and um it feeds into a CRM for brick house clients. It's
She built her CRM outreach and what the users are going to use with the affirmation.
Everything's inside of one
Oh, no.
app.
Separation of concerns. A separation of concerns. That's a bit much. That's a bit much.
That's a
Um, yeah, it is a lot. Um, cuz now you're moving out of web app territory into like full-blown desktop OS
lot.
territory. Like I I ain't going to lie to you. Not not to say that that's exactly what you're doing, but it's like having every single thing under one house like that is a little tough cuz brick house mindset is client facing. You see what I'm saying? That's for users. Whereas your CRM and everything, the the lead genen stuff is for you. Your users are never going to see any of that. So, you might as well just take it
completely out of the flow of your website. Now, here's the thing.
Mhm.
You done already built it in there. So, it's going to take a little work now to isolate and and refactor and kind of build up those walls to make sure that when you do extract those aspects of the software out of the main app that you don't break everything else.
But yeah, try to yeah, just like Spin saying, definitely do your best. Everybody, please listen everybody. When you're building in these new features, really think about what is client-f facing and is helping me run my daily operations to serve my audience and what is an internal tool that only I need to use. You see what I'm saying? If it's an internal tool, separate it from your commercial layer. You see what I'm saying?
That's that's the one thing I have to say. Separate your internal tools from your external commercial layer.
So when I'm pro Thank you. when I'm prompting Claude to do so, what should I feed it or what should I be mindful of?
What do you mean?
I would definitely I would definitely say be mindful of
Yeah, go ahead, bro.
database things like how all the data is being stored because again I'm pretty sure these I'm pretty sure when you built it in it kind of isolated it to a certain degree where it's like it only has to touch
Mhm.
but so many files if you want want to make that migration possible, but you've already built it into your back end. And that's where s* gets dangerous cuz I don't want you to lose all that data and then have to rescrape and yeah,
Yeah.
it's going to get dangerous on that side, the back end, less so the front end.
So question, you all showed us the re the remix option in lovable.
You're not going to remix what you just did.
Okay. All
That needs to come loose. That needs to come loose.
right.
Brick House Mindset. See, now just think of the app as one brain.
Mhm.
And so now it has to think about the affirmations and the scheduling and the the person like you said client facing. We got brick house mindset at we're there for one thing and the machine wants to do its one thing but on the back end it has to think about all the all the customers and the CRM. It's like a it's like a tumor on the back of your app's head saying well we still got to look out for CRM.
We still need to be scraping internet the compute the usage the stink for the computer a little bit. That's what you're having it do. That's what you're having it do.
Mhm.
you're having it think of multiple things when it's it's just trying to deliver one. So, snatch that off.
So
Whatever that CRM is, it's going to be a separate tool. It's not remixable. It's going in. It's going in. And here, I'm I'm going to I'm going to bring this up because you gonna have to do this. So, do you remember how long ago you attached the CRM and and crawl ability and outreach ability of uh of the
So,
application?
I added a CRM for clients probably around May, June,
Okay. So,
and I just No,
is that what the clients are going to use or is that for them?
this is so I clients.
And that's okay.
So I was so this is what I need to understand. So if I am managing clients from the app and then I pull them into a separate project, can they still talk together or does this have to be like totally separate?
You see what I'm saying? Like I put I said,"All right, so I have people coming on the app. I need to manage them. I need to, you know, maybe move them up to the goddess tier or another product or, you know, cut them off or what have you, you know. So that's why I thought everything should be on one one platform. But so now like I have created
Okay. Okay. The CRM is to watch the users how they use
business,
it, when they need to be cut off, when they need to be turned up, etc.
right? So like I have an affiliate program in there too.
Cool. Cool. Dining stadium.
Okay. So,
The out this outreach thing just has to come off.
the that that I just created like within the last month if
Okay, cool. So, this is exactly what we going to do about it.
not
Here is the lovable for a landing page, but imagine it's the app.
And all you're going to do is go up to this timer right here. Go up to this timer. It's going to say history. See, I set the owner email login brand summon link previews with the metadata. installed my Vimeo VSSL whenever I was doing this. Wherever you put that thing in, cut it back out. Document installed landing page BSL escape preview for the Shopify checkout. Everything that I fixed on the VIP purchase, go back to
that, click it, and make it rerun to that
Now,
version.
what if I made additions to the app since then? because I like the the voice to speak I believe has been since I added the um prospecting platform. Here it is. Pl prospecting tool that was added June
Okay. So,
16th.
when the prospecting tool went on there, then when when did the voice go on there?
Let me see because I tried to do the voice I could. All right. So that is August 6th.
Okay.
So, I started the voice probably in May.
Oh.
Couldn't I don't think it was whatever I had wasn't working at that time or I didn't finish it. So, it was just like a placeholder. And then August 6th is when I activated
Okay.
it.
Well, let's do this now. That's fine. Let's see because that prospecting tool has to be separate. They like to use cla uh your
Okay.
git's definitely in there. So go to connectors for your call connectors. Make sure your GitHub integration going on. Then you're going to go in on the mic to dictate. They cla the let's separate the Brick House Mindset app from the prospecting app. And then let's actually make the prospecting app better because now because now you're going to do the custom route the goji berry cuz
now you're going to go to co the goji berry custom connection route and you want that to be a separate app. You want that to be brick house outreach. You want that to be brick house outreach and that you know and then you'll follow up landing page.
Okay. So that means coming over here as well settings integrations say you see it is growing as No, it couldn't have been. Let me see something else.
I'm not finding berry in the in the claw connectors.
You see what it's not a claw
I'm not finding goji berry in the claw connectors.
connector. We had to We had to do it custom.
Okay,
had to be cut on it.
that's where we go to goji berry and then you said add the API and do that.
Yeah. Where did I get it from? Did I get it from the agent?
Okay.
I don't know. I thought I got an integrate. What did I just get that damn feel like I went straight to it yesterday. Like I was so hyp. I did it faster than I even realized. So yeah, once I get up exactly where this is at, we're going to place it there. We're going to go back to CL up in here to setting the connectors to add add custom connector.
And I need to go get that MCP URL again.
Is that one that I can use or every client has a different one?
It's going to be separate. It's going to be great for you.
Do you know how long this goji berry trial is?
I think they give you seven days.
Okay.
All right. So I ask the agent for the exact play and the exact play will be using gob MTV server access a bridge between your local environment and the go platform. So now, as I'm saying, separate that outreach app because it probably has good functions, but separate it from the Brick House mindset for sure. And then go ahead and create on lovable, that very tool. Connect it. Open the claw skill like I just did. Connectors
customize it. Then go ahead and add to where it looks like mcp.goji.ai. Copy and paste this URL exactly. So I'm showing it on my page, but go to goji berry and ask the agent to bring this up for you.
Mhm.
ask the go agent to bring this up for you and it walks it through just like this.
See,
Mhm.
ask the agent. Okay, it said it was in web hooks. Go ahead and ask the agent. everybody that wants to make this play for your outreach, especially when you're going corporate. For all my folks that's going to go CTO, go corporate and make it an internal app that services um your outreach and stuff like that. Go ahead and tie that stuff in. And then you'll just work from there. Shay, when it comes to inbound, outbound,
and how you handle those leads, it had to be separate. That's all it really was is separate
It was just too much in there.
that.
And then the goji berry is going to work. I can still manage everything. Well, goji berry through claude, right?
Yeah. So go in here,
Once
make sure you're studying Goji Buri and and what it can do. Check out the agents, contacts, insight. See what the dashboard is bringing you. LinkedIn uh put your LinkedIn accounts.
Mhm.
Put your active signals.
I've gotten even more leads from yesterday.
Mhm.
have applaud, you know, uh, see I put start a outreach campaign folks in the building. Make sure you study your own outreach campaign. See how it comes back. You'll see your leads up in here. Activate your inbox. I haven't yet. I'm build. I'm waiting for a little bit for tomorrow Q4. Like I really I really I'm going all in on Q4. So while you're doing the same, go ahead and separate those. Piece those together through
Claude. And then if you want to, you don't have to, but let's take it there. take it there. Go to Google and go to claude platform sign in. Just a minute cuz I want to make sure it's a real thing. So you can get the No, let's go to home anthropic. We really have to go to the company when we want API keys. And what that's going to do, Shay, is you'll put the API key from real claude into your app if you're going to take
it that far.
into the prospecting platform.
Yep. You have to customize the whole thing. It's not like it's just coming from the connectors. The connectors is enough, I think, for where you are in business. for where you are in business and what you're planning to do,
Mhm.
I would leave it in as a connector. But I'm saying for your application, you would go to real anthropic and get the API key to have quads working inside of the app.
I had to do that to add the voice touler. I had to go to anthropic and get an API key.
Okay. So,
Is that okay for
we'll use the same one then. Cool.
the prospecting tool?
Yeah. Per prospecting tool.
So now okay so every
So it can just do its one job.
project should have a claw API key in
Yeah. If that's what you're going to use and you like you know what you got on Claude,
it.
all your connectors with all the abilities from your your Claude will go into your piece.
It'll go into your application.
Okay. So just so I understand the API key is giving the project the abilities of that platform.
Yep. Of of claw match with the goji beer.
Okay. All right. Great. Thank you.
Yeah, that's just going to be if it's just hyper specific, hyper lasered in on doing that job, then do it that way. war right now is what I'm saying where you are in your career. Let's kind of use the connector. Let's study Goji Berry. Let's get clients. Let's close, you know, one to three people. Let's study that process and then continue. And then um with all of that and what you're getting back, start to set up the
outreach. Even if you're going to do the hijen slide, start setting up the outreach of what you're saying back to corporate to corporate um clients.
Right. So, that's where I'm going into ask the public, finding out what are the main pains for my prospecting demo and then updating the scripts that I I probably need to start from fresh and just create the seven sequence emails based off of what the needs are and what my tool can do.
And um also first I need to interview myself because that is one step I skipped that I think is going to help streamline the messaging cuz I'm you know I've been building for
Yeah.
what five months now and my me everything has continued to improve and tighten but Claude is still pulling in old information. So, I'm going to use the interview process to update all of my speaking points, my benefits, etc. across the claude and then start clean with the prospecting uh outreach tools.
Yeah,
Okay, thank you.
just align that messaging and align with your ideal client profile exactly who you want to reach. Like, hey, what's going on family? Um, I know that you work in HR. Hey family, I know that you work in team morale. Hey, I know that you're the team lead down there at such and such company.
Mhm.
Um but my proposal is this application this application will help with doo do you guys see any place that this would fit or do questioning first figure out what they need first and say well I have an app for that we're going to have to figure out that approach getting this into a corporation have to figure out that that front-end approach so think about that in your interview even have Claude have you know go back and
forth with Claude about Okay, if I'm sitting down with a CEO,
if I'm sitting down with a lead, if I'm sitting down with a person from HR, what am I saying about the app? What am I saying about the connection? What am I saying? What am I doing? What am I preventing?
Yeah, I've done all of that continuously, but the ask the public piece is going to be instrumental in just sharpening it. And um luckily I was able to go to some, you know, uh sales leads, etc., and get their direction from the notebook LM tool that you said go scrub the videos and get an outline. So I have that, but the two things that I need to do still are the ask the public to get the exact
Mhm.
keywords and do my interview, my full interview, because the the the app and the corporate app have grown so much since you guys gave it to me. So, I I need to backtrack and restart from that position and then update my scripts.
Yeah, but start with Google. That's why I say use Gemini more. Like, you know, I know you got this thing about AI, but use Gemini more.
Before you go to Notebook LM, before you go to Answer the Public, it's going to give you the key terms and the best search things for apps of your of your stash. Can't find those. Use a Google AI search. All right. What's up with the rest of the family? Y'all going in on where we are on business. Getting a little bit of a a GPS here put together. Excuse me on my nose. Y'all y'all put it put your hands up or uh type in
into the chat real quick while I handle these allergies. She's killing me. Jesse, what's good, family? I see that hand up. What's going on?
Hey, happy Monday to everybody. Well,
Good
for starters, I am three hours behind y'all and every time I think I got the time right,
Monday.
I'm wrong.
No,
So,
it's all good for
so I apologize for being late. Long story short, um these sessions I'm very new um signed up over the weekend. So I just wanted to get some clarity on what I may have missed and how does this session work?
Like what am I allowed to ask, not ask, things like that.
Okay. Yeah, this is definitely um so this is going to come with skills and abilities here when everything launches tomorrow afternoon around Newton. So what what skills, what abilities, what connections, what software that you learned from the summit can we directly put you in the path of today? Now where's your business now? What spoke to you during the summit? So everybody that just came in, what spoke to you during
the summit to where you say, well, I heard this part about marketing. H I'm not really at the marketing point. I I've seen all this about building these apps, these connections, these skills, these plugins. Okay, maybe maybe I could build a plugin. Maybe I can do that interview. Baby goo. So that's what it's all about y'all really tying in, tapping in. And then I'll have some of the family come through that's speaking
in Q4 come give a good word about Q4 AI future uh business and entrepreneurship.
nice. Thank you. Well, everything that I learned over the weekend, I for sure need in my business, in my everything.
Especially um in my world, I'm in construction. and I built things out of shipping containers. And then I launched division where we offer land, home, and car packages because I'm also a car dealer. Long story short, I hadn't really been on social media like that. And back in June, I just had a prayer to God and asked him to help me understand that because I felt like my audience was there, but I didn't know how to reach
to them. And so I stumbled upon opus clips and I like to talk. So I was able to put things in the opus clips and let it, you know, chop down my thoughts and we got way better results than I could have ever expected. My analytics is off the chain. Followers increased tremendously. Tik Tok reached out to us to ask if we would, you know, join their creator service plus program. And again, not expecting any of this. So, lots
of influx. Probably have about 50 new clients plus in the last 45 days.
And honestly, prior to that, didn't have a lot of automation built into it. So, while I have SOPs for the construction company, and that's great that, you know, people want to join right now, just even tweaking my schedule has been a little bit of a task. learning Kalently and connecting Kalently to Claude to help me keep all this stuff organized. And frankly speaking, I'm just one person. Um I did a reorganization last
year.
right?
I don't have a business partner anymore. Had to fire my assistants and all kind of things. And so this weekend was just so amazing to me because it was what I really had needed to be able to scale the business up. And then I think my biggest takeaway was when Aku was talking about viability and you know autonomy that whole presentation and I'm like I don't have any of that in place. So I need every tool that you all talked
about. Um even down to the marketing piece where you broke down the analytics down to the
Okay.
seconds how to revamp what you're presenting to those ones that are only looking at the three seconds. Like that was even valuable because when I was looking at my analytics, I'm a a dana add analyst and I was looking I said I'm not sure why people only watching this for 3 seconds and it's a 60-second clip. So,
Yeah.
even how you all broke that down over the weekend gave me a lot of value just in how I'm looking at my analytics. And so I need everything. I'm excited. I just wanted to just kind of catch everybody up on what I have going on. And then we added an additional um division which includes taxes. So,
All
um, a part of the reason why we created the program was because my customers couldn't get approved for loans. And that was frustrating to do a whole design consultation,
right,
hype them up, get them all ready to go to build their house or their commercial space,
come
and they couldn't get loans. So,
on.
my background is helping people do regulation raises. Um, I was a financial broker of sorts helping people with loans. I just got reertified for that, too. But um that trust and tax piece was really important because I didn't want to build for people and they didn't have their assets protected. And then the tax pieces so that they could qualify financially. And then I'm helping them too with uh personal and business credit.
And so I say all that to say I added extra things in that's making my business model more complex. And this automation and getting it on autopilot will help me out tremendously. just being able to stay organized as we had these influx of new customers. So, thank you for opportunity and I'm going to just wait and see what can be done.
Okay, cool. I mean, so yeah, while you say everything, I mean, you were the first person to go ahead and get into Q4 for the accelerator.
So, we're definitely going to be working together for 4 months um on building up cuz yours, you know, if you do need everything, then we're going to have to take that time and go uh day by day, week by week, make sure this is in place, this is in place. But for right now, you remember the um the AI schedule and lining up that schedule for everything that you have to do.
I don't remember but if we some parts I missed because I late both days or the time zone
Yeah.
change. So thank you.
Okay. So, let's go let's talk about this real
Thank
quick. Start off. So, everybody that is um you know cluttered days a lot of business influx of folks um Dr. Tony's also in that space I'm talking about did get her own assets in there. So for you Jess to go ahead and clean up the organization for today. You use claw chat or Gemini.
I use all three, but right now for scheduling is mainly clawed.
Okay.
All right. And as long as that go into settings and as long as the connector is connected to Google Calendar, right? Connected to Google Calendar. And then I'm going to go I'm going to say,"All right, Claude, I'm getting ready for Q4 2026. Uh, everything that we've been doing inside of Spin City HQ, new a mentee, and etc., I need that realigned and organized at a CEO's pace. I need to see all the um what what needs to
be done with our leads, our emails, our social media, our posts, everybody I need to be able to hire in Q4. All the AI agents I'm going to need to bring in, you know, timing the budget, structuring the budget for Q4, structuring out the taxes, da da da. I'll keep elaborating. I'm talking back to you now. It's like I'll keep elaborating on everything that has to be done. Everything that will be done, where we're going,
where we're not going, who we're looking for, who we're not looking for. All right. So, align that and get it ready to go on my calendar timed timestamp for what needs to be done each hour.
Again, give me the absolute schedule. Don't worry about if things overlap. So everything that does over overlap, make sure that my team knows. So we'll structure that out for things that need to get sent to monday.com. And um let me see that first and then we're going to create it. Create the calendar, create the schedule, and then push it over to my schedule in real time. So I'm going to let it do the work. I'm going
to let it think. I'm going to let it align, soak up the business, and then see what we're going to do next. And also in there, I would I would I should have said what plugins, what connectors, because I like that. I like that about um Anthropics Claw, the abilities to, you know, connect everything, see what's going to be connected, what's not going to be connected, what's important, what's not important. So, while that's
doing that, I'll go ahead and go back to like uh August's calendar. What's
I do like that. Claude, do you find that the other app types,
going
if we were using the same prompt, would yield something significantly different? I use Claw because I feel like it's a little bit more analytical than some of the other AIs. So, I'm just curious to hear your thoughts about if we use that same prompt in other AI models, would it have a significantly different result?
Yeah. Nah, because my calendar like I just I just showed you it on happening on claw, but I do my calendars on GPZ. All
Okay, thank you.
right. See, I haven't even set up. I haven't even set up. See, like uh days like this where everything's over overlapped, everything's jumbled. That's because GPT um put everything here. And I pretty much said the same thing. If all these overlap, how how's one human going to get this done at once? You don't. So, in there, you want it to come out just like this. just like this with timed outcomes and places to put what
the founder does. So now this starts to free you up because it's it's telling you exactly what you should be doing at that time and it's not all of this mundane work.
And it says the founder does message teaching, demonstration, recording. Team does editing, captions, thumbnail resizing, scheduling, polishing. No inbox calls, editing, posting or page polishing and it goes to the team board over on Monday and AI is pushing all of it because I know again on Claude Claude has uh NGPG you know all of the large language models are are are pretty much the same thing. Yes, they think different
and they have different data but large language models run like large language models. So boom and then like look look at the days be absolutely full with who hits the schedule when you have your own mentorship time even planning out for your time what you do at Q4 boom boom so all is to be ran look you got a CEO review and then have the calendar only ping you for what you do yes it's in here sometimes See, it says bring
spin only in for final assets, broken revenue paths, ev evidence B uh back spin changes, public claims, or relationship decisions. Do not do Mailchimp setup, pixel installation, editing, analytics, cleanup, or tax chasing.
Push that over to the team board. We got one thing to do. And then here, I don't know if you made it to that part of class. Everything that's timed, everything that's timed, Jess, I'll grab it. I'll go back to claw everything that's timed. I'll go back to claw. I'll go to schedule tasks. I'll go back to claude. The same claude that built the calendar. The same claude that pushed the calendar. The reasons for the calendar,
the timing for the calendar, the stack of the calendar. I'll come back to schedule tasks. I'll do new tasks. set up manually. The instructions are that rundown from on top of the schedule so that the AI can get as much done without human interaction. So now again, you've done a CEO interview with yourself or that level right there cuz you want this calendar. You want stack that count, beat that calendar senseless. AI,
don't worry about if five things overlap at 8:00 in the morning because what's going to happen is your actual intelligence is going to come through and you're going to go ahead and instruct this thing what to do on time.
frequency. Look, hourly, daily, weekday, weekly. When when does the content play need to be done? The permissions, y'all be careful with what you're doing. But a lot of the things how I'm showing you how to structure that calendar, right? Yes. The same thing that I'm saying to make sure everybody is hearing and seeing. Skip all approvals could be dumbass dangerous when it has something to do with money, tokens, APIs, etc.
All right, so skip all approvals. That's when you know, hey, write a script, write a blog, hey, read the news, give me the break it down to a TLDDR, give me the emails, ship the emails. Like, I'm not asking for any approval. um automatically approve certain things through Claude down there. Y'all, this is going to make Claude think a little bit. And that's why it says Claude runs its own run on its own and pauses to act
if anything looks safe. Now, right there, AI is going to think and say,"Well, I'm not spending any money. I'm not stepping on any toes. I'm going to go ahead and knock this out." And of course,
manly approved. That means you have to be there every time. Now to work in a project, you can also set the model, you know. Um I know Akun can agree. I wouldn't want all of my schedule tasks to be on Fable 5 and Opus 5. I'm not going to use that much compute. I'm not going to use that much AI to do the reading of the news, the reading of the analytics and brought it back TLDDR. No. So, when you look at the task as well,
and we'll be definitely going over it in in Q in Q4 because again, we want to save y'all bread while we make y'all bread. So, just, you know, uh taking the email, sending it over, breaking it down to the analytics by the number, recommending the next piece of content, recommending the next sales outreach. A lot of y'all can do signit five if you wanted if you wanted to be sharp and smart when it comes to emails, outreach,
slides, designs, content, maybe office 5 when you're building Fable 5. Fable five when you're making the internal apps apps like um Jay's going to hit him up the outreach app, build that on Fable 5, but have, you know, uh, automation could be pretty much Sonet five, content, opus five,
And let me add this in real quick,
right?
Spin. Um, y'all think of y'all agents as a meta tool.
Yeah.
It's a tool that can teach you how to use the tool itself better. So, as you're creating these workflows and you're like,"All right, I'm ready to automate this, put this on a schedule. I don't know how much compute or how much intelligence I need to carry out this task to the standard that I like ask the agent to run an analysis against the thing and be like all right based on opus 5 sonnet 5 fable 5 which tasks require
which model and can we make sure that every time I call this task it runs that model. You can do all these things. I literally just set up some of these things in the config file of the agent. You can build these things out and have it automatically know, all right, for this task I'm gonna switch to Sonnet, and then for the next task at 9:30, I'm gonna switch to Opus. You know what I'm saying?
Like, it can do all that. So, just have that strategy in your mind as well.
So, yeah. Yes, that's a good kickstart for you and everybody else that wanted to declutter the schedule and really see how to get those agents to work on time, on task, on schedule to where you can again, you'll get the ping from your calendar. You'll say,"Okay, well, here goes a new piece for content or here's your here's today's script for a live because here's the latest news you can use in your lane." Then you'll go
live how you do and then you'll have those key points to hit on. You'll bring those analytics back from the live and you'll tell you'll tell uh Claude this many people came through. You know that little after that after Tik Tok little thing that comes up how many people watched how much change you made. Da da da. Take that and bring that back to Claude. So now every time you get off of a live or every time you launch a
piece of content, let me see y'all.
See, you see some there there's some already down here. Monitor a topic like watch the news for mentions of a topic, competitor or keyword. There's the content ideas, the daily breed, inbox triage, read your emails, you know, see see where the hot prospects are because again, maybe you've done the goji berry and now your goji berry's working. It's doing cold outreach. You know, people are hitting you back. Say, I would
like to be book one of those meetings. Your schedule's all scrambled. Hey, I didn't I didn't see that you had one in the meeting the other day. Inbox triage to bring that straight to you. and then it'll prep for the meeting. So, also grabbing those, putting them in the calendar, and like um Haku just said, when running that tab. Just use sonet five to to knock it out. It's nothing major. I even use haiku 4.5. Just get
me over the text. All right. So, yeah, for for today, yes, go ahead and line that schedule up like that. Just get comfortable and then, you know, these tasks will start to come out with the daily with the daily challenges and the daily plays of Q4 that you're already in. And then I do need to give you my phone number because every month um we're actually going to sit down on a private session and work.
That's the part of the CTO um upgrade where we'll sit down oneonone or I'll bring in any other team that you need to sit down with and know like trust and piece together. That's a part of the CTO packet. So we'll be with you.
Thank you. That was
We go. We go. I see y'all chopping it up. You got any good word for us right here leading us into Q4? Dr. Tony, you want to give a a good word? Not too much a demonstration. Um, just good words. to make sure everybody's hyped while they're thinking. Let's, you know, I'm steady trying to prompt in you guys a mindset. Yes, it's AI automation, the tools we can use. What part of the mindset could we use going into Q4?
Well, good day everyone.
Wealthy day for sure. Wealthy and healthier than last time.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. I I personally believe that we all have our destiny. And when you're able to fully align with your destiny, you speak to your purpose in a completely different way and everything that you need.
You know, they talk about the law of attraction, but you can attract anything that may not be for your highest destiny. So being in alignment with your overall destiny is what matters and assists to facilitate the full on alignment for where you're going. I've done a lot of different businesses, experimented in different industries, and I'm quick to say, you know what, I tried it. I don't like that s*. I don't want to
do it no more. Never mind. Let me do something else. to other people. It's like she's not committed. She's not stable. She's not, well, f* what you talking about. Like, this is my destiny. I get to pick and choose and fill out what I want to do and, you know, learn if it's for me or not. And thankfully, I've been able to do enough of that throughout my career to not only understand me, but have the experience with understanding
who I am. Because you can say you are who you are all you want until you go through some s* and experience being that way.
You can't you ain't been tested. You ain't been tried and tested. So just speak into alignment with your destiny. You know, we all want to be great and efficient in business. Like that's what you all are here and learning to to do and accomplish and implement and execute. I always want you to seek you first and know that what you are doing is of great value for you and your own life and your destiny. creating for others,
operating a business, perfect, fine, dandy. But just know that it's okay to reinvent yourself, switch lanes, grow, evolve, and elevate throughout your process. Allow yourself to learn. Learn new things. Learn new ways about yourself and everything else that come to you. promise you I've never submitted an application. I ain't never submitted no resume for anything that I do at all whatsoever. So, I'm a prime example of
alignment with your destiny. All things will come to you that's meant for you.
Definitely. Definitely. Brother Miles, what we looking like, man?
What we looking like? What we What we doing? What's the real plays, man? What we looking at? How we get paid? You got to pick on you man. What we doing miles man?
s uh
I'm saying what we doing, man? What's the real work?
right
Where we going? Where we going with with with the miles movement Q4,
now
man? What we got to build up?
uh right now for me I just started over so I'm doing like uh uh digital products and drop shipping right now. So I'm in the in the list of trying to figure that out.
Uh what uh what
Um, uh,
platform
Shopify and, uh, Printify.
action and then how you get how you getting those leads in and then what's the uh the structure on you like I'm saying. Yeah.
No,
How are you getting the leads and then how are you converting the
we're not. when I'm say I'm at the beginning.
I'm at the very beginning like I set up the Shopify and I set up the Printify.
sales?
Um just figured out what kind of actual products I wanted to do and I'm going from there. Like I'm literally at the
Okay, cool.
beginning
All right. beginning of ecom and drop shipping. I say the very beginning uh does every does everything have the proper description and proper image.
Um, no. Cuz I'm, like I said, I'm I'm I'm I'm on a right now.
Okay.
So, as far as like I'm just creating the actual images before I get ready to do everything else. So, I figured I might throw a tap in while I'm just starting.
So, I get it right the first
Yeah, bet.
time.
So, what's going to be the biggest play? So, it's all going to be uh print on demand pretty much. Like when you say when you say printify, that's because you're putting the image on a t-shirt or in a hoodie or on on a piece and that's what's going to be selling or is there like real drop shipping to where I have a manufacturer that sells phones and I just make up a page about the phone and I middleman the deal.
That's drop shipping.
I know I want to get there. I'm not there yet. So, I'm just going with the printer first before I start doing anything like
Okay. All right. Cool.
that.
that that give me one second slow cuz it's going to be monumental on there. Wherever you're getting it from, you want to add a piece of their description and then your description. So, it's going to be closed. Oh, 100% cotton or however it goes. I want to make sure we get the descriptions in there.
Mhm.
as long as the descriptions are proper uh metadata on there so that this can be you know items can be found and then the images that support it those are pretty much foundational that'll be the foundation of what it is and then you'll say look I got the site set you can even go on here on Shopify and then ask the AI night. What's the best description on Shopify?
that
Yeah,
Shopify.
they got a little a little superhero um up there and you can open up open that up and get best descriptions for your pieces.
Got you.
Boom. And then even when you go down close on my Shopify actually a little bit messed up.
Yeah, it look crazy
Um,
today.
let me see. Hey, creating the collections. If you're doing TE's, if you're doing backpacks, if you're doing hats, each collection and the whole time row, ask AI to do it or what uh language model you've been using been on that claw joint.
Um, I think I use everything except
Okay, so we'll do it the chat GPT way.
that
We'll do it the GPT way. So on GPT on GPT, bro. So now everything moves. So how how come this happens at random times during the day? And we just did it so smooth on GPT bro nowadays. You see how when you go up to the top it says chat or it says work.
Yeah.
So you're gonna go into a work chat because when work work uses codecs and what they originally had remember when operator was out for chat so where it would go on it would it would bring up its own desktop and go to work
Mhm.
that's now work it's codeex and and operator in one. So go up in here.
Okay.
You're able to go up in here.
All
So everything that you're imagining, every point A to point B that you want to get to, again, one of those all y'all have hit hit the hit the AI with the explainer. I go up in work right here, bro. And then as I'm in work, I'll say,"Can you log into my Shopify
right.
and audit it?" Let's see what can and can't be done to um maximize maximize my drop shipping business. I want to like and you're typing this or you're speaking this to the mic and just dictation. It's like, okay. Well, can you log into my Shopify and audit it? Let's see what can and can't be done to maximize my drop shipping business. I want um image recommendations for each piece. I want um even if I can get a 3D image
or an AI model to wear one of these TE's to wear one of these backpacks, wear one of these hats.
I want those. I want the best description. That makes sense. I want the description to go into the meta metadata for AI citability. I really want my, you know, I want to uh have blogs about this or that. I want to feature artists. I want to whatever you really want to do, go ahead and walk that down and it'll know to log into Shopify and do its thing. So, when it comes up on the screen, it'll come up on the left. Um, it'll
come up, sorry, on the right. And then the screen will come up and then you'll just click that screen signify and then you'll be able to watch it work. It's going to bring back that audit and it's going to say pretty much kind of these same things that oh well there is no images here so we recommend the image of this. If you wanted to do this, you wanted to get the 3D model, we suggest Higsfield or it's going to create
the image right here in chat because you know it's AI. Who did Chat GPT buy?
GPT bought somebody for their images and videos. I think it's I don't know. But down in plugins, plugins on GPT, y'all. Plugins on GPT. You see there's the Hfield. There's the Google Drive. There's the Vid IQ. So, go ahead and do your plugins on maybe use Higsfield, bro, or use Canva so that when it comes back and creates the image, it'll easily go over to Canva. You'll pull it from Canva and put it right there on the
on the thing. Now, you see you see how that's working? That does that make sense, bro?
No, that makes
So, that cycle run that cycle with AI in work mode and just have it navigate
sense.
the image. Navigate the description, navigate the metadata. Okay. Boom. And then also then I would say when I when I did um when I did drop shipping, I mean I mean way back, but boom. Now to go to my meta ads, my meta ads that start to get everything warm. See now in uh what exactly are you moving on the on the printer?
Right now we just I'm doing shirts and with the other stuff is like uh gang sheets and designs for, you know, playing the middleman. So for everybody that wanted to actually put their products out, give them the the the designs so they can move forward and do what they need to
Okay.
do.
Bet, bet, bet, bet. Okay. Okay. So, if I had a design, I'd bring it to you. You'd make it, put it on a shirt, and then help me move it.
Yeah. Or I provide the already the the the designs they already have. So say like Halloween coming up. Everybody getting ready for their shirts, their tumblers, whatever it is they're using it for.
Yeah.
I put together what I put together. You pick and choose what you need, but I make sure I give you enough options where you know what I mean.
Yeah. explain that to the AI so it'll so it'll make that alignment and then go ahead and put that and then you'll say when
Okay.
everything's done you like okay well this site this is done here's the product here's the digital real estate here's the digital asset this we're working with and then we want to go ahead and walk over to something like meta ads something that's
All
going to go get attention and then and then like you just said hey Halloween coming up we didn't did this this this and Let's have folks. Where are we going to go get folks that want to do this? Now, you find other people interested in drop shipping or in Halloween,
right.
in design, online, da da da. So, walk all that through, talk all that through and watch AI work for you when you get that time.
All
But yeah, chat GPT work, sign it in where you want to sign in, especially on Shopify and Meta Ads, and then get in for like maybe like5 $10 a day. Find out that budget to start to get the messaging out and warm that platform up.
right.
You'll be able to watch the analytics and again, the AI that is inside of Shopify will help you read those analytics and then monetize on those analytics.
Um over on the left where it has online store and this s* moving raggedy man crazy. It seem like it's only Shopify a little bit. Think Shopify is not a little low and it just crashed on me. So down there where it says sales channels online store point of sale and agentic. Agentic will do help you. It'll connect directly to your meta ads. Anybody else that's using Shopify too. agentic mode to tie right into your ads and
um and do aentic outreach and marketing for you based on the budget. Yeah, to kick that off miles, bro. I would say that lineup right there of walking GPT through Shopify and meta ads and making it move and making the messaging move. Yeah, it work. You did it on make not I was on the operator right now. Yes. Justin Burns said he'll pull up in a minute. Y'all give y'all a good word. Justin Burns from After Build with AI.
Been rocking with the team for a long time. Good brothers with Red Pillar. Tapped in after bill with AI.
Come and give a good word. Don't improve the importance of you know Q4 and business. What is this? Chad Arrington said he can pull up around one. And Chief SBS said he'll be here at 3 for the last hour. So yeah, folks are pulling up. Keep your questions warm. Get your thoughts. You know, today today is really on the thoughts and where we can help people directly like we've done. You know what I'm saying? Chopping it up
with Shay, chopping it up with Miles, chopping up with Jessica. Anything y'all thinking of? You know what you what do you need direct help with? Andy G, Dalilah, what's going on y'all? What can we work on? Uh Jessica, you got we going got a
I do. I wanted to understand when do companies
question
transition from having a website to considering having their own app?
pretty much what the world is going on through and then AU talked about it a lot. your web page now your website your website is too much of a where do I look when now web apps have AI infused to bring the customer exactly where to look and guide them through the buying process quicker or the research process quicker a lot of people that's are stuck on websites that's a site to land oh I see this page and you're giving
a person a lot to And we know 2026, 2027 and beyond the attention economy,
I mean, they don't got it. So just going to spin cityhq.com will leave you lost. But if I direct you straight to where we have the the tickets for the AI autopilot summit, you need to get there and they'll apply AI agent on there to go ahead and give some direction and know. So now that's working as a web app. Somebody can use it. And then with web app capabilities like we go through on lovable or even Justin has his own
apps built with AI. It's that a person that frequently uses your products, your services or is connected with you, they can now just put it on their phone. The web app goes into a phone app. Now when you want users to use a process on repeat and on subscription then yeah you can launch it as a web app you know like Hickfield web app but you can download on your phone to use as a regular app right like you look at look
let's look at chatgptt y'all let's look at claude we all know we're on here using a web app there's not a website you don't go to chatgpbt.com and you're looking around looking for words and you know what I'm saying or doing this and oh it's AI that's a site the web app is what you actually use and then you can also go to the Apple store go to Google play store download it into your phone now you got chat GPT in the app
so we're saying that whatever your company does
and needs to deliver on autopilot that's when you know you'll need an application for
And I'll add this little piece because Spin just said it perfectly fine,
Thank you.
but I'll add this little piece so that way I'll kind of remember it a little bit better. A site is citation. It's just reading. It's just documentation of what the business is. So I could go to the McDonald's website and I might be able to see their menu, but I can't order nothing off there, right? The application allows me to do just that. Take whatever knowledge the company is giving me and apply it in real time to my
needs and desires. So again, McDonald's selling burgers, I'm hungry. But if I go to the website, I can't order off that. If I go to the app, I can now apply my money to the software and get them to deliver me
Yep.
food. You see what I'm saying? So, it's more about the the functionality of the site read versus actual execution.
Thank you. That makes sense.
Yeah, that's dirty.
Yeah, that makes sense. Do we still need the static website or can we replace our websites with like the landing page for the app or whatever services we are offering?
That's
That's why we told you for sure you want a landing page.
Yeah.
You don't want people looking around getting confused now. Hey, what is it? What is this? The Shay Love. They just going like this. Some of it's pink, some of it's black, some is yellow. Like he said, it's a citation. What what do I have to read about this thing compared to where I can see something, click something and land exactly where the offer
Yeah,
is.
cuz I basically uh replaced my website with the app landing page.
Got you. It's way better. People don't want to really want to leave uh read a lot. And that's why I tell y'all and if y'all seen who all who all seen all the videos on ai autopilotsummit.com everything has a video on it.
I actually don't leave anything to reading there's a video for everything because nowadays everything should be conversational. Even when you want to close digitally treat it like you treat it like somebody just walked through the front door of your physical business. Somebody want to walk through the front door of your physical business and you'll just stand there, you know, when you greet them. Hey, what's going on,
man? Welcome to Spin City HQ, man. Oh, yeah. Sp I I seen I seen I seen the uh uh the outside of it. What do you got going on here? Okay. Well, we do uh we have the AI autopilot summit. That's what's going on. So, August 29th, treat the internet, treat the digital world as if somebody just stepped foot into your physical business. They don't, you know, unless they do want to browse, that's when you leave the reading. That's
why I put reading. But at the top of every page, whether you guys looked at where to register or or reserve a seat down to the point to where, well, I want to reserve a bigger seat.
And it came with a video. It didn't say,"I want to reserve a bigger, better seat." And then you have to read,"Yeah, this is a bigger better seat than the first video." No. Here I am again, family. Uh, well, I'm thankful that you reserve a VIP seat. All right. So, what that entails is this, this, this, and this. All right. We definitely have that for you. And there is one more. If you definitely wanted to upgrade one more
time, family, go ahead and reserve a uh, emerald ticket holder seat. And, um, click that button and I'll see you on the next page. See me on the reserve. Hey family, it's crazy. You just reserved an emerald uh uh vault key holder receipt. This is what this means, y'all. Boom. Boom. Boom. Boom. Every I I left nothing up for y'all to read. I put everything in video. So, that works more on an app than a website where y'all
would have read everything. I gave y'all the information up close uh and personal and then I gave you the exact buttons to hit to go ahead and send payment through.
Make it easy in the digital world. exactly like they just walked into your to your real world um brick and mortar business. Greet them, meet them, answer their questions, and go from there. And then close close them at the register. Uh I think I think I missed it, man. I had a I had a thank you video set up for every everybody. All right. I'm working on applying the audit. Cool. Yeah, I seen folks doing their audits. Seen
folks doing their audits. So, that was a good piece. That was a
I hope everybody's having an easy time with the audits. Again, use your agent to your advantage. Thank you.
good I need to take my site from sale and make it into an interactive app. It could be interactive or for sale unless you just want to redeliver the code on something like lovable. Level has really smooth code and connectors right now. I think lovable on top of uh delivering app. The connector coming through and the ease ability to put some of these APIs into your apps is really fun.
It's really cool, really smooth. Good design, really good UI UX. Pull it. So, I would say pull it if you want to just to have fun. Bring it to lovable and then add a interactive agent. Again, you can just And here here we go, y'all. Let me explain something. I think they asked the other day. So, everything I could told y'all about the GitHub, definitely get your GitHub, go to work, definitely get your GitHub connected.
That's why I told I forgot who I was telling to. I think it is CC. Um, going up in here. Going to work mode. My GitHub is plugged in.
Are you showing your screen?
Yeah, it's supposed to be coming up. I'm going have to reset the computer again like I had to do yesterday. Oh,
Do you have enough?
the computer just starts acting hella crazy.
Okay, now it's
So, born into a work mode or even if you're using Claude now, if if you're using Claude, you're going to be using Claude uh co-work.
You're going to be using Claude Co-work. If you're using Claude, you're going to be using uh Gemini. It's going to be Gemini Spark. Y'all large language model. Most of them are the same. You're going to go in codework GPT work or Gemini Spark plugged in with your GitHub. And what you're going to say is um work on my lovable project three. But do not use any lovable credit. Only work through GitHub. Look what's going to
happen y'all. Again, any coder, any developer, any engineer can work up code and then do a pull request. And that's what's going to directly impact the Lovable app without spending any lovable credits. So that's how you keep a free Lovable and get a lot of work done. Smarter work done at that. Lovable works on a slightly it's not dumb. It's not dumb at all, but it works on slightly different parameters, if you will, when
it comes to coding and building because again, lovable kind of wants you to sap and use up all the credits. Like they want the money and this is why we say we'll say I say that's why I said vibe coding is a scam cuz you're vibing.
Yeah. Lovable. Try that out, you know. Yeah. Put a make it blue. Uhhuh. Yeah. make it this and lovable say,"Yeah, well, we gonna shoot them credits up to do that." And that's fine because you're in here vibing. You feeling good. I remember was me and hit and uh Lovable launched a free day. Hey women, come and build an app for absolutely free. Yeah, right. Like it was for only women. That was a marketing that was a marketing
ploy. Yeah. All the ladies come through and build an app for free all day. The moment we got on the app, it was crap. It was crap. And I bet
Literally by noon that same day,
nobody
noon that same day, that s* was bricked out. Completely brick.
done. I bet no one was able to build an app at all that day. But you know what they got that day? 1.1 million signups. So lovable, right? So going to chat, going to Claude, going to going to Spark and saying uh work through GitHub only because a pull request is free to lovable because Lovable the platform did none of the work.
So to test it again, claw code. So now that's going to be a clawed code thing. when you want to test it, it's called code codeex or anti-gravity at that point. And of course, that has to work through git. It's not going to work any other way. Has to work directly through GitHub. So now the coding platforms I'll go down here go to my projects that are connected with git go to the new amenity joint mean what time is that?
I can't really count. Um, I go to new ainty main and then I'll go here and I'll work all the pushes boop boop. We'll just push the lovable will be like boom. Okay, you just did a a pull request, this request, that request. All time I never use any lovable credits. I'll be on free lovable. I'll be on a free lovable um pushing and pulling and creating on the app. So connect your GitHub, connect your GitHubs, connect your
GitHubs. All right. What was that?
So I have I have Claude writing the back end directly to GitHub and then lovable I'm publishing the front end.
Yeah.
Okay. So that's proper
And and the internal system. That's what I'm saying. Claude, give me something cuz here's another thing that you can do. Definitely. Uh Shay, everybody ask Claude on the front end to work it up. What does it look like and how? Ask Claude to prompt Claude code on separating this from this while holding together this because again I asked you to now you have code and you actually need to pull out a finger without destroying
the rest of the code. That's the thing. It's like when we seen and heard that everything's in one place. It's like wow now you got to do like a little bit of code surgery. We have to get that other code up out of there without destroying everything. And lovable has Yeah. has the the the um the problem. I'll call it a problem. It'll destroy a lot to get to one piece of code. It'll it'll it'll it'll tear apart a lot just
getting one piece of code
So pull it directly to GitHub is going to avoid that.
out.
But I should do like you said um what is it? Uh no that's in lovable where they can just do the prep versus the build, right?
Wait, say that one more
I was just confused for a second.
time.
So basically I have Claude speaking directly to GitHub to do the backend coding.
It's not really speaking. It's Claude doing it work and speaking to itself and making it and making the lovable making the app move through GitHub.
Mhm.
Claws is doing the work. Paul speaking to himself and then Claude is doing the push,
Okay.
doing the pull into in and out of the repository.
Right.
The repository shows up in physical form on lovable.
And then I publish.
Yep. You publish. your publish what's done for the
So, one question I have is that I don't even see Claude co-work anymore.
world.
I just have it says Claude chat and coowork because coowork when
Yeah.
it first came out it
Co-work right there. Yeah. It's no longer separate on the side.
was
It's right there. Like I'm saying, it's either chat GPT chat or GPT work. There's either claw chat or claw co-work. That's how language models are
no it says this what I have it says chat I'm using claude it says
progressing.
claude chat and co-work work and then claude code is a separate tab cuz it used to have a co-work tab but that's gone. I don't even see
Because because that's like I'll bring up on screen because chat and co-work
that
is not the same thing. You can click chat or you can click co-work. Those are two clickables. not the same thing.
see where I used to see co-work as a selector but I don't see
Yeah, but you can still select it next to chat.
that.
That's not That's not a That's not the same
Oh, okay. So,
thing.
it's down in the actual chat. It's not in the index anymore.
Okay. All right. So, I see that now.
I see my screen come up.
And so, what is the use of co-work? Because I mostly use chat for like general info and then I use code to actually create. So, what are we using co-work for?
Co-work usually gives desktop control to the agent.
Oh.
So the agent can do the stuff like on your computer for you.
Yeah.
Like it can go around and click files and open like you'll literally see it take over your computer and record everything that it does.
So if
This right here, this is a button.
I'm
Give Claw attach to run autonomously. It's a button.
Yeah, it used to have it. I missed that. It was It used to be in the index at the top.
And that's what I'm saying.
It was three of them.
Okay. The language models are progressing.
Yeah.
Companies are saying that you can either try some design out, you can try some coding out, but we're either going to chat with you or we're going to do something autonomously.
The same way chat is next to co-work is the same way that Gemini is next to Spark in the way that chat GPT says chat and work. It's either talk to the machine or have the machine do something. That's the realm. That's what all language models have become. So you either click co-work and again top prospect email list summit leads da da da. It'll go to work. Just how co just said it's going to go to work. It's not going
to talk to you. It's there's two things you can do with AI employee right now. It's either back directly with it and get info back and talk to it and say what you're going to build, what you're not going to build, and then you put it to work. Just like any other human, you can talk to the human. You can have a conversation with me right now. Or you can say,"Well, Spin, can you can you do this, this, this, and this?" Now,
you just put me into cowork mode.
and co-work is for the automation whatever I want to happen
Yeah. What you want done in real life,
automatic
what you want done on the computer, not what you want to talk about, what you want done. That is conversational. Codework is get to work.
and code is I thought where the
Code is for coding. Homework can code.
bill
Homework can code while code is strictly for code. You can't even chat to code. You cannot have code go and do things on the computer. It's strictly for code and it must have a GitHub to code on work can do anything like look in your emails. Code cannot. It's meant to deliver code. But work can work on your Shopify. code to not
And that's why they started leaning so hard on that that line in the sand. You see what I'm saying? Between the two because they saw the two different groups of power users that were spawning as these technologies got better. They realize all right a lot of the early AI LLM development was based around how can we make this better for coding the chat part is already pretty decent how can we make this better for the coding
for the developer that wants to adopt these tools to speed up their work right boom then as these models started to become more marketable more publicly known chat GPT kind of just became the default word for any AI that anybody would use they started to realize that everyday people in different industries wanted
to use this, but they're non-technical. They don't understand all the code, language, and all that extra s*. They need something a little more plain English to do their everyday day-to-day task. You see what I'm saying? So, that's co-work. You see what I'm saying? Whereas me as a coder, I ain't always looking for no co-working situation. I already know the work I got to go do type s*. I just need the work executed. So,
I go in,
Yep.
I get the work executed. Now, when I want to elaborate on an idea and really flesh out, all right, does this make sense? Here's where I want to go. Just like been saying, I'm going to go into more of a chat mode, especially with chat GPT when you're paying for the subscription. The chat is unlimited. There is no limits on chat. Codeex still got limits on it. You see what I'm saying? So, that's the real difference.
They'll let you talk forever, right? And they'll even let you build up some files, some markdowns, you know what I'm saying? Get your little PDF, whatever. But when it comes to actual like hardcore execution of either day-to-day workflow task or hardcore development, you're either looking at co-work as a non-technical person or codeex or code as a technical person. You see what I'm saying? That's the real boundary line.
But again, that comes from them observing the market, looking at their users and saying,"How can we best serve them with this technology that we're developing?" And then how can we make it easier for them to understand the difference between the two? So when it's three damn uh tabs, that's kind of confusing. When do I use chat? When do I use co-work? When do I use code? Now that it's just two tabs and we consolidated the
chat and the co-work options, it's a lot easier for you as the end user to understand, okay, well, I'm not really a coder.
I ain't really trying to build a website right now. I just want to audit my CRM.
Hey,
You know what I'm saying? All right. Boom.
that's
Yeah, cuz I've been just using code and so the challenge that I've had is that sometimes I'm building I'm talking through things in chat and then I have to ask for the prompt to put in code, but code is way more advanced in knowledge of the app on the back end.
I'm actually not even against that strategy. That's something Spin taught me too. The pick and pull method. You see what I'm saying? like you bump into an issue in the code part,
Okay.
take that copy that whole section out, bring it to the chat, have a different AI LLM model, audit that work as you're um as you're doing it. You see what I'm saying? And then it helps you move faster. That was one of the main things he taught me.
So, I'm not against that methods. You see what I'm saying? Because again, if I just want to talk, then why am I burning up all my coding limits for that?
facts fact and folks always say well I ran out of my usage I ran out of my usage because
Right.
you probably didn't pick and pull because all you like you said you it could chat forever bring it a line of code where what it's not happening something happened in in in code I mean call told it I it is going to do it. It will make recommendations, but why not take it back to Sonic 5 right quick and have a conversation on it before I put it back uh you know and have it reprompt code to say oh kind of s* like slow that
down and you won't you you won't hit usage as
great. So just one more question.
That's
So as I'm going back and I am interviewing myself so that I have a a effective today what the understanding of the app is and my outreach.
So, I'm talking to um being interviewed in Claude chat
bad.
and it's going to give me basically a new skill.
Yeah.
It's going to update my skill for the project and then I'm still only putting that in my brick house mindset project or how would I have code read this updated language? That's where I'm getting I'm doing a lot of back and forth because code has one set of language and chat has another set of language. So, I'm going to restart and start with the interview, but I want everything to match so I'm not updating language in
the build and then in the website and then going back and
One word, handoff. Tell chat GBT in your work in your regular chat area.
forth.
This is Harold Whe just so you know who's on the phone. But one word, tell it to give you a handoff in your chat. Take that over to your work and it'll have everything so you don't miss
Bars.
anything.
Okay.
Barers.
And then is that going to be locked into cloud code moving
Yeah. And you got another choice again. You can go into your settings area of your uh clawed work.
forward.
Well, I mean, I'm sorry. Well, I've got work space and the personal. So, when you have both, you can combine them all together to work as one. But in that space, um, yeah, I think it is. You can bring it over there and, uh, and have it read in the back end in the settings area. Uh, it can read your personal stuff, too.
in the memory. Okay, I'm looking in the memory I think. Let me see. All right, so I'll look through the memory because I believe I can update this. Okay, thank you.
Hey,
You're whoops.
what's up? Let me I'm answer uh I'm going just say something real quick in the chat and then have Harold introduce himself for what's really going on and who y'all really hearing from is that Dan you said um you've been having problems with Madness because um Meta lost Madness kind of said that uh Meta couldn't have it couldn't keep it so it was on Meta and then now it's it's all tweaked out because all you know who want
who data who got whose data to um re-implement data information da da da. So yeah, manis kind of fell off lately. But um yeah, Big Brother Hero, man, go ahead, introduce yourself. Talk your talk your good s*. Let us know what you've been up to. Well, you know, based on what you can tell us of what you've been up to.
Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
Good introduction so we know what's going on right here. Real boss s*.
All right, everybody. Pleasure to meet everybody. My name is Harold Wheel like the fish in the ocean.
Whale and throw a Y on the end. So, Harold Wavy, you can find me at my.com, but uh my company name is Suede, S W A D Soul, S O U L. So, suedesoul.com is that I have a AI agency. Um just to give you a quick little synopsis, I'm originally from Florida. I grew up in the country raising cows, pigs, and chickens. But I got um was I sung in the church and all that stuff. Got in the military, went in the Navy and did 11 years
and uh worked on uh I was a radar operator. So, I worked on ARPANET. So that was the first stage of the internet. So when I got out, I jumped in the music industry and I was a producer at Death Row Records during the murder was the case time and an artist at Solar Records back then with Baby Face, The Whisper, Shalom, blah blah blah blah blah.
Uh, and I was the digital guy also that could sing that made everybody put AOL, Comperve, and all those things that were coming out back in those days in their computers. And I made them give me their email address. They didn't even know what it was, but I knew. So by the time they came up with the word spam, I had harvested 14 million email addresses already. In uh 1999, BET put me on the front page of their website as
uh with along with six other people had picked the artist of the millennium and I thought it was unfair because I was number six on the list and that means that the rules nobody was voting for me. So I pulled out a million email addresses and wanted 97% to the rest of them. BET immediately sent some people to meet with me and like how you did that and I broke down the technology of how this was going to work in the world.
I got involved in virtual worlds in 2004 in a platform called Second Life. I built the first ever virtual world movie theater with Stars Home Entertainment, a movie called the Jimmy and Judy Movie. That's how I made Wikipedia actually. So, and beyond that, um I uh got into crypto in 2009 when Bitcoin came out. So that put me in a stage and I did that because I was on the dark web buying Photoshop and all that but I needed
to have Bitcoin. So I got involved doing that stage of it where I wasn't even understanding how serious it was till around about 2011 2012 is when I got serious about keeping it and knowing what you know I lost wallets and all those kind of things back in the day. So but fast forward I learned I'm a person that builds systems and I don't like to do stuff twice. So I um I after I left the music site I went to working with
a company called Urban Network.
They launched the care they were the black version of South by Southwest. We launched the careers of Destiny Child, Luda, Mike Jones, Mary Mary, Boys of Men, blah blah blah blah blah. And I was the program director there. And I um my first morning jock was John Amos from Good Times, you know, James. So me and him toured the country with this online radio station that nobody had even had online before. And that's what we
were doing during that time. After I got done with that, I moved to the ABA, the American Basketball Association, and I became vice president of strategic development for 18 years. I just left that two years ago. So during all those times, I put these programs in place. I built the cryptocurrencies for the ABA. I built 18 coins for them. I built Riddic Bosecoin. I built uh Anthony Hamilton's first NFT.
I built uh um Tom Brady's first NFT through his fame photographer Mark Serotto. That was probably the hardest one we did because it was so legality working. But in my stage of going through all these, one of the things I've learned is right now, especially in the place we're in right now, economy going what it is, AI taking over jobs, we need to have a plan. So the plan has to be one having systems in place that you can
use to be able to create finances. So what you're teaching right now, uh, Bas is on point, man. I give you, you know, I'm taking my hat off to you because this is so needed,
Well, too,
so needed in this point. But in the essence of what we're doing,
man.
we want to be able to know that this stuff costs a lot of money to keep doing. So in other ways to get out of that, you're going to start moving into the open open source side.
So codeex is your proper piece to build in that way, but you want to make sure it's building in a way where you're not taking on as much of the the debt as possible. So if you can pay for a year's verse of hostinger, get you a hostinger account. That hosting your account will give you uh your your server side with a VPS and then um pay for something like run pod ru n p o d. It's very cheap, okay, for what it does for the
hours that it'll run and they put that on your hostinger and have codeex build on your hostinger. So everything you're building now is open source. So you're using open source video, you're using open source AI program. So you're not paying the back end you would normally have to pay when you're building these other things. You still need codec to analyze it and put it together for you. But once it's in place even build
in your platform in the back end because the first thing I do of anything I build is a admin area before I even build to think about the site.
My admin area has to be uh a strong CMS so I can see everything any user signs in with. I make sure that I got god mode power. I can invite any new admins that I want to invite. I can delete any and I can put them with certain roles so I can control them. I can gift credits. I can gift plans. I can um uh and I and I want to also be ability to be able to uh have users be able to sign in and leave any kind of other information
that I could have in the back end so that I build a uh internal uh AI health fixer. So it fixes anything while it's on. So if they put a code in say,"Hey, I got a problem with this." It's going to check that. It's going to fix it. Tell me what it did in the morning.
So all those first. Then I start building the site. So that now and I make it to where I can go in that in the back end and everything I need to do I can control there. So that's the first stage I do so that no matter what I'm doing, I can control after that component. If I want to control stuff on the site like images and things of that nature, I build that, make the homepage so I can change images. So I don't need to
go back into coding it again to do none of that. I could do it all internal on the main things that I feel need to be changed, added to and all those pieces. But the key piece I want to say today that everybody need to be thinking about is having your own second brain. Second brain. That is the key piece right now. That is your operating facility.
bars.
So you can tie everything else you're doing. All of you got 50 like I do over 50 sites. I only talk to my second brain in the morning and it talks back to me. I wake up with the wake up word and it says this is how many sites we have online. We had a problem with this. We had this many people visit today. We made this much money over here on this one. We got this many visitors. What do you want me to do now? And because
of all my sites, I tell it what I needed to do or it gives me uh advice on what we do. And then I keep going about my day. So those are the next stages of where you're going to make this stuff easier for you in the long run. So my second brain is ssbrain.live live so you can see what it looks like.
Uh it's very unique looking because it has what's known as a obsidian table in it. So these little dots that are connected to everybody I talk to everybody and I go in the back and I just talk to it. When I wake up in the morning, tell it who I met, what we talked about, I'll talk about this conversation here and all of that will be logged. So if I ask it a question next month, it'll say,"Hey, remember you had that conversation
with these guys. Let's go ahead and make that work." But da da da da da da. So that's the new game and I want to help you guys get there faster. So look at mine and if you see it, I've got two ways to do it. And because of everybody on here with you, I'll send the code out to everybody get it for free. But if you see on my site, I'm charging for it. So I'll send it because everybody that's on here gets it for
Damn little key holders,
free.
man. How you loving that,
Spin.
Thank Yeah.
man?
Thank you.
Hey.
Yo,
Great day.
what?
Spin. This ain't fair, bro.
This is okay for
Yeah, that's that's that's man.
Right.
I told y'all, man. Shout out to Dr.
free.
Tony. Shout out to Uncle. Look y'all, I told you this summer was going to be different, right? I got one more ball player real quick that I want to chop up with y'all. I know he heard I know you heard I heard Uncle here, but can I introduce to y'all? Y'all know him from the Ascended Masters. D Hood, can you give us a good word, brother, on on how you are how you're navigating this AI and robotic space from your perspective,
G, please? heard. You got it. I'm talking to you. Don't make me call you now.
What up though?
Let's
What up, bro? What up? What up? What up, brother? You saying? Give us some more medicine, man. I hear burn this mug down.
go.
I did too. But you saying when I when I say when I say this something going to be different when it come to AI because y'all got real bosses to talk to. did this ain't look I'm not again I'm not hating y'all don't ever take this as hate but these ain't no AI gurus these are systems architects at the deepest level you hear where Uncle Herod is from D Hud man give us some more medicine on that man
Yes, sir. Definitely. Yeah,
please
I appreciate you always having the space, man. Uh, if you can give me a good two seconds, I can get it together here. Um,
Yep your background and what and what you really know as a as a boss in
but I definitely listen to uh Yeah, definitely.
space.
And then my brother that just uh was just on there, man, that's I appreciate the the value he just dropped, man. That's they don't they don't teach that stuff every day.
Crazy.
But uh give me a quick second as far as being able to
You ain't no good.
um give me a second. I'mma turn this thing on real fast so I can actually see. Okay. True. Um, but as far as that that second brain, that's a that's a whole thing that uh let me see where's I'm trying to find
You only get that from from Kto. That's what I was saying, man. Me and H be going around and teaching.
um
Hey, and they try to leave us in the background. Yeah, them some them some spiritual knuckleheads, man. Come on, man. We really build the world around you. You just don't understand yet.
exactly testing. Testing one, two, three.
Testing, testing.
Yep.
Yeah,
You on there,
unlock.
bro.
All right, cool. I'm back. I'm back. But uh welcome,
With the robotic with the robotic arm,
welcome.
robotic camera. Y'all don't understand yet.
Oh, yeah.
Cook up,
Oh,
bro. Let me go on mute.
yeah. As as as far as being able to have um you know, AI have actually wear a lot of my AIS. Uh and then I appreciate my brother because I actually use my second brain within my mask as well.
Yeah.
Uh but if y'all were to see uh if we if we were to be able to
Y'all don't get it. Y'all don't get
utilize um you know AI you know for those that don't know my name is D.
it.
It's an entree, motivator, speaker, author, um, super stack developer here in ATL, Georgia.
Love chicken wings, right? But besides that, as far as being able to, um, utilize AI at a at a highest level, um, you know, I love the the run pod and all the ownership talk. My man just I think Shamar Shamar, he just just spoke over ownership, you know, but being able to take that ownership, you know, is is is the perspective you don't get into. you actually out there understanding how to optimize at different levels.
Um, but when it comes to being able to own your AI, you know, for those that don't know things like Olama or ways to to really download a model, right, when we can we can download it and put it inside of a device like this, right? Uh, when we think about first question, people are like, well, what does it do, right? But when we when we understand the future of you know technology um you know to be able to do computer vision
matter of fact the police use it on you now inside some of these flock cameras or some of these little uh solar powered devices that it's it's called computer vision you know people they're they're making these short names like flock because when you have multiple cameras working in unison to to cap to you throughout the city right it's it's like flocks so you you know you building your
own flock or fleets of of of or swarms of of AIS. Um, when you do it on the camera side, you know, to give one camera to actually have the ability to see is called computer vision, right? So, when you when you can when you can do things related to computer vision, you know, object detection or obstacle um avoidance, right? Obstacle avoidance is how the Tesla car moves around, you know, the way. But when we think about
the camera being able to understand the depth of something, I can't avoid you if I don't understand how far you are away. Right. So, so if so, if I'm wearing this and I automatically get a red alert is because somebody's running coming too fast, right? Right. So, computer vision in many ways is how I do droning for dollars. If instead of me going to do wholesaling deals and walking through driving through the neighborhood,
I can stand in one neighborhood and drone it out. Right.
As as far as drone for dollars instead of driving for dollars, right? A lot less gas, right? Right. But when we think about being able to how does a drone detect an abandoned property, right? you know, back before back before chat GPT days, you know, it's a long process you had to do to actually teach a drone what a property is, what a what a mailbox is because, you know, if you can't correlate the property to the mailbox,
th those are those are associations relationships that when the drone does find the bando, it looks to the mailbox to associate the address to send to the API. to get the analyzation of what the property's real time evaluation may be. Right. But
So what D Hud is talking about is machine learning.
if
That's the real knowledge of what he's doing right now. It's how you shape a LLM.
Mhm.
So please sir,
continue. Amazing.
But but but this is the other side of it. Like my son, he's 19 right now, right? But when when he's when he's 10 and he doesn't know what a bando is, what do you do? You say,"Hey son, this is a bando." He's not going to get it one time. This is an abandoned property that we're looking for for wholesale creative financing son. This is the after after 50 10 depending on maybe how how smart your you know your seed is. You
know you're at at a certain point it's he's going to be able to point out a bando to me. Right? See that training that he's talking about machine the human learning right before the machine got it. Human had it right.
Yep.
But but in the instance of being able to in a before AI, you know, you would have to literally upload 50 or so plus pictures of a mailbox for that AI for that drone to identify and then 50 pictures of the housing a beat up property so that so that the drone can even identifies from the bandos.
If most if most properties down the street are random properties and it's one out of one out of a 100 bandos, the Bando is considered an anomaly, right? So So my drone should be going down the street detecting anomalies. That's called anomaly detection, right? When anomaly detection has been used since probably since you've been alive to what's an anomaly? the felons that shouldn't be in the country that that is being
detected by the computers vision through the airport, right? Computer vision keeps your country safe from invaders, right? So to keep your house safe from invaders and you download a language model that has computer vision capabilities right now you can download it on a Raspberry Pi. Don't know if any do with chips and Raspberry Pi. This can be my doorbell ringer. This can be my smartome. This can be this can be the thing
that keeps my house safe from intruders, right? But chat GBT 3.4 didn't have full vision capabilities.
In your business, you need cap computer vision capabilities to what? Look at contracts,
Yep.
look at web pages after they done so that they can edit better,
right? all these things the AI needs the ability to see, right? So, so to be able to detect um through a camera lens, right? All these types of things allows us to be able to create more products, monetizable products, and monetize AI because after 4 was released, they released 4V, GPT4. But if y'all didn't know, Open AI had a product called Clip. Clip was their first computer vision model. It was out actually before Chad
GBT, right? But a a good resource for those that's trying to get more into this. Rooflow is one of one of the great sites that I use. Roboof Flow. So now in So now, let's go back to getting our drone to understand Bandos up and down the street by default.
Instead of us going to take a hundred pictures of what a property bando looks like, we go to Rooflow and we go download a uh go find a free a thousand pictures of mailboxes. Go find a 3,000 pictures of videos I mean property houses. It's video and image data sets. So now instantly my my AI my drone through training and now I can enhance it with the language model right so you learn that being able to have these types of
computer vision techniques you know when it when it comes to pattern recognition now flocking flock camera that's a little different now you have more than one drum right right to be able to have a swarm ARM because the biggest thing we're doing with this swarm, of course, a swarm is the future of uh war as well. So, when y'all understand that even in some of this war in the Ukraine going on, they're they're they're using
drones that that can have a mission on board. Listen to that. If you own the model on board, meaning if your smartome didn't have a language model downloaded, then it can't be smart because there's no smart thing on board.
Maybe it had access to something smart, but soon as your internet is down and you say,"Hey, Siri, call the police." Internet down. Can't be that smart, right? But but as far as when we think about sometimes smart is a signal thing. If somebody cut your Wi-Fi, you know, we can have our own thing, but if we don't have Laura devices or radio, long range radio devices to be able to signal an outside party, then we're still
virtually stranded, right? So learning when it comes to some of these chips and things like that, you know, the the smaller the robotics, you know, I mean, um, all these smaller robotics that are going to run the city and wearable AIs, you know, for me, I just last month I added um body language data set stuff. So we I want to be able to been test and stand in front of people and and they tell me the truth and they tell
me a lie and then inside my mask, you know, I can be like,"He's looking to the left. He's lying." You know,
look, this is But to but to but to be able to be able to tell habits of people and patterns of people without actually speaking.
Hey, D Hood,
Uh yes,
bro. Another cut in, but I got to get in on that.
sir.
How many people you think been doing that that really knew how to update, upgrade, and put real AI inside their Metagasses?
uh only only a certain certain few like like out the gate I think a lot of it's a huge percent that did but they didn't know where to send it. You see what I'm saying? So so Metaglasses out the gate it came with a WhatsApp connection, right? So if people weren't if they wasn't building and they didn't have like a the circumvention thing at first, right? So if you wasn't building a WhatsApp agent for me, I already had Nad
in and kati to WhatsApp. So WhatsApp can say create me a movie, create me an avatar, check my email, analyze anything that can be connected to mini workflows inside N8, you know, when it when it comes to sending, hey, from my glasses, send such and such an email, you know, but as as as far as being able to learn multi-modular systems, when it comes to being able to hack any device, I'm not going to say hack, uh, I'm I'm
going to say modify, you know,
Not a buy.
modify any any outputs.
Yeah.
Um because a web hook, you know, like I have AIs that call me in the morning where I say,"Hey, AI, call me real fast." Um and then when I when I think about being able to use AI to be able to monetize, I mean, call me at that moment, you know, it's a lot of things that's that's routing routing on the back end. Um, but when it comes to being able to, you know, you utilize AI inside of different systems, you know, being
able to, um, utilize your own workflows, like I recreated N8, so I know a lot of people may be familiar with that tool. U,
Yep.
but when it comes to workflows,
Take it
web hooks, and and um, time triggers,
home.
you know, I teach teach people a lot of different about time triggers when it comes to being able to automate the AI. Um then uh give me one sec.
Yeah. So when it so when it comes to automate people on a on a on a on on the side of time time triggers, I recreated my tool called a GPT calculator. I mean GPT alarm clock. I own calculator too but GPT alarm clock. Um because I was focused on the time trigger. Most people may not understand you know some of the new systems open claw open hermes and you know uh um deepseek harness you know some of these some of the newer
frameworks you know they they they focus a lot of times within their own their their actual cron jobs to actually maximize uh maximize more of the potential. Um, but when it comes to being able to create more modular systems, then you're able to actually build um more more modular systems um inside of your inside of your main ecosystem. second. Um but when it when it comes to your having having ownership of your actual
AI um you know being able to build actual monetizable tools you know a lot of times the personalfacing um agentic tools that you that you build and especially your command line tools if you don't really understand more of the advanced side of it you know the real goal in in AI sometimes is to to start something now and then and then evolve it um versus versus wait um versus versus not versus wait and not
create. Um because we can we can wait all day and long try to learn the most advanced when sometimes we just need to to get started, get going, get moving. Um but as far as as far as showing y'all some examples of AI, I can definitely do any of those if you want. Um but if y'all have any comments, questions, concerns, um you know, or specific ask or specific industries. Matter of fact, let me check the chat. Uh, I could
definitely go more specific on something versus um out of out of
Yeah,
all
that was just the the beginning the beginning touch points. I mean, we can check the chat right here.
things.
We got Justin. Justin should be in here about seven about seven more minutes. Yeah, I just so real quick from the from the emerald key holders, where whereever in life have you learned that at this level? Spin, Aku, Uncle Hero, uh, D Hud, where have y'all heard it like this?
You can tell the truth.
No.
Which AI guru? I told y'all this something was going to be different.
Can I Can I share this real fast?
I I told y'all that it would unlock something and having that key was going to unlock something in
Oh, my bad.
your mind because of who's sitting down at the round table, right? And then I know a lot of folks they like,"Hey, you know, I don't I don't I don't know why I was spending 300." And I think it I think it was today in his video, especially y'all ML key holders, y'all been making them damn videos because look what you're hearing now. Look what Aku, look what Harold and look what D Hud brought within the last hour, right?
What they brought in the last hour and then again, you know, um, apps built with with AI, Justin Burns, they come in here in the next few minutes and give a good drop. So yeah babe about about two three more minutes the hood if you wanted to cook but then we definitely going to um you know increase the round table of who's speaking bro that's what you know a good round table when it comes to lessons and demonstrations
y'all could hold them and there other speakers coming through um so yeah bro I mean fire in the chat y'all and you know I told y'all it would be different I told y'all it would be important I told y'all
Um, you know, uh, when I say it's your brother from the inside of AI, do you know that I hang with other people and other brothers and other sisters from the inside of AI? And now all y'all are in inside too because now see see how I say you know too much because not only do you know how to navigate AI in business, AI in marketing, AI here, AI there, da da da. You've now heard absolute code control, AI in robotics, AI
and wearables, the way machine learning pretty much works, human learning, machine learning, and that's when I told y'all when we talk about autonomous vehicles, how did you learn to drive when you were 15, 16, or whatever age you got behind the wheel? Somebody was there in the passenger seat and was like,"Okay, well, this is the accelerator. This is the brake. Use this mirror. Look at that mirror. Look at this one back
up. Especially whatever era you learn how to drive in. So the things that you're able to see and able to hear from champions at this level in AI and I'm grateful.
Again, when I say it's your brother from the inside of the game is cuz I hang with other people on the inside of the game. You dig what I'm saying? It's like, and then again, look, I'm inviting my my my folks in here. I don't even think Aku even knew D Hood and Hero. Herold and and D Hood didn't know Aku. See, are we able to make the connections here? again. Um they stepped away. Hero Hero and um and Tonee cuz they work
on really big projects. You know, they to they told me they told me y'all they told me they they going to bring back um one of the top uh VCs in robotics and rocket spin. Oh, I robotics and rockets. I don't I don't want to I want y'all to know how far AI can truly go. We're not no f gurus. We are people on the inside of the game. We are people just like you on the inside of the game that know about flot camera systems,
that know about autonomous vehicle engineering, that know about rocket engineering, chip development, absolute code.
code bases, code ownership, open- source AI. You dig what I'm saying? That's what type of team you're around, right? And and you know, through the through the summit, Dr. Tony has been there and she just stepped back in her ability to even work with and work alongside these individuals. And this what I'm saying about, you know what I'm saying? The best family you can have. That's that's a good that's a good conversation
because again, Aku didn't know Dr. Tonee. Dr. Tonee didn't know a coup. He, you know, she trust and believe who I bring myself around in the huddles that I get in. Okay. Well, I can bring I can bring the Uncle Harold on this m* and cook up on this, this, this, and this. That extends the family's knowledge. And then we'll all listen to D Hud and physical AI and robotics. Then we'll listen, you know, spin and and it's in
and it's um AI architecture within marketing and within autonomous vehicles, machine learning, human learning back and forth. You'll listen to the code basis open-source AI of Aku.
What are we talking about? This is your family from the inside of the game. And again, where people I don't know if you can give them the the the good whispers of the good word. Uh yes, see we got another heavy hitter for y'all. You dig what I'm saying? Um, so let's go ahead and tap in. We getting in. We getting in. We getting in. Uh, Dr. Tony, go ahead and make that intro, please. I just hope you're all grateful. You
know,
We'll have uh Lady Rocket joining us in a moment, but we did just have um another one of our partners, Harold and I, uh Brian, the owner and founder of Traction Coin,
heat
the first barter token ever minted on the blockchain over 23 years in business. Who do y'all know has been on the blockchain for over 23 years in
Come on,
business? Brian, you want to come off your mic?
man.
Introduce yourself.
Yeah. Hi everybody. I'm Brian Stone with Troptions. Uh we started in 2003 as a barter token, 2004 registered with the SEC.
And the story goes on and on and on. So we've been around for a long time. We're a proof of use coin, which means you can actually use it to purchase goods and services. One of our coins, Traoptions Pay, um is accepted at over 580,000 merchant locations. Home Depot, Lowe's, Delta Airlines, Southwest Airlines, Uber, Amazon, Five Guys, Ruth Chris, Burger King, McDonald's, and the list goes on. Then trap options gold is a
token that actually has been used for um leverage, collateral, uh balance sheet enhancements, all kinds of different financial uh tools that businesses need to um boost their balance sheet um up to where it needs to be for them to go out and get loans or you know do whatever they need to do. So, we have a plethora of things that that the tokens have done and doing. All factual, everything's on the blockchain, been audited,
AML, um, all kinds of really good stuff, working with Tony and, um, Harold, which are two of the greatest people that I've met because they really know what they're talking about and that's exciting.
So, that's just a little bit about Troptions.
man. Good to meet you, brother B. I'm glad I'm glad you brought the blessing to being headquarters, man. And a probably something, man. B, I've been telling is going to be different. You know, I'm I'm pretty strong. I've been a um a developer on the Google side, Nvidia side, and I work on autonomous vehicle engineer business. I built out a lot of these systems um that guide marketing alongside like Chad Arrington when
it came to the original Clickfunnels and and all that good stuff. So, yeah, I'm glad that you are bringing this wisdom of the blockchain at the highest level um for the family by the family ever, bro. I'm grateful for you, bro. Good to meet you.
Good to meet you. Thank you so much.
But I told y'all told y'all going to be different because who you're around B. I would have a question brother. What does it look like when I build up a autonomous business? The business is running itself. You know, getting some money here.
What can I connect? What can I do on the blockchain that'll make this business? Is there a way that'll run smoother? What would I do with autonomous business at the highest level? I'm getting cash in, man. I'm breaking down deals, man. I want 150,000 per deal. You know, what can that look like from me from your from your standpoint in doing that level of business?
Wow. I mean, um, that's that's that's a that's a Dr. T question. She's more into into that.
Okay.
I'm just learn I'm learning from her on taking what we're already doing to a whole another level.
But I love what you're talking about because that is the next level. That's that's where everything's going is is what you're doing. You know,
I'm There we
that utility that utility where people can actually use the coin. See,
go.
everybody's getting a lot smarter about cryptocurrency. It's not it's it's no longer um buy low, sell high. You know, the question that people are asking now is what can I do with it?
What can I use it for? What can I buy with it? You know, because it really doesn't make sense to take a crypto asset that appreciates and turn it back to fiat. What we did is when I got involved with TR options as the president in 2015, the first thing that I did was take us off all the speculative exchanges. I wasn't interested in a buy low, sell high, dealing with brokers and traders. I wanted something that the mass
could use because I I I bet on that's where it's all going to go. Now, everybody at the time said I was crazy, didn't know what I was doing, going to bankrupt the company, and you know, nobody nobody cares about that. If you're not on an exchange where people can exchange it and buy low, sell high, nobody's going to use it. Well, I I beg to differ because if you look at the second paragraph to Bitcoin, it says what Bitcoin
was set up to do. Bitcoin was never set up to be in the financial industry and in in fiat.
Bitcoin was always set up to be anonymous and from peer-to-peer. And that means that if we wanted to buy a car on Saturday and every all the banks were closed, I could meet you at Starbucks. You could bring your wallet. I could bring my wallet, you bring the title, and we do a transaction right there without having to go through any banks. So that's what my whole thing was. I mean, we bought houses, cars, boats, trucks,
gold mine. I mean, everything you can imagine that you buy with regular fiat. We did it 100% with our token. Um, and we didn't do it once. We did it hundreds of times. In fact, we got sued by the SEC three times and we won three times because it's factual. It's all on the internet. It's all on the blockchain. All the transactions are there. So, that's kind of the direction that we've been. And now I see a full circle because
more and more people are starting to want to do stuff with their tokens versus just buy low, sell high, and can't do anything else with it other than cash out.
And you know, we all know what the dollar is and we all know what uh where the digital currency um play is that everybody's talking about. So that's
real quick. Thank you for a good word. Your hand is up. What's going
Yeah. So, two questions.
on?
So, this is very timely because for two reasons. So, if I'm understanding correctly, we can use your Bitcoin to buy pretty much everything in the ecosphere. And a lot of us are trying to figure out what where we need to put our money. because the dollar is is uh very uh what is it? Susceptible right now to changes. And they're also saying, well, I'm hearing that gold and silver might not be it either. So maybe can you
talk about the um viability or the security of putting your money into Bitcoin and how that would help sustain
Well,
us?
we're not we're not Bitcoin. We're Trapions. So, different two different tokens.
In fact, Troptions, we are on the Bitcoin blockchain, which was one of the oldest blockchains. So, we're not when you look at um Bitcoin, Bitcoin is what's called a proof of work. Tropions is what's called a proof of use. So, the Trapions pay is on the cash rail and that's the one that you actually can go into Home Depot, Lowe's, and many of the other ones, pull out your wallet, pull out your phone, and tap the app and
then go up to the cash register, and she'll ring up $7543. You would then hit $7543, hit a hit pay, and a barcode would come over and they'd scan it and a receipt would come out and you would leave. Now, one of the differences between that and people go,"Well, you can do that with with Bitcoin." No, you can't do that with Bitcoin. Bit Home Depot won't accept Bitcoin. Delta Airlines isn't accepting Bitcoin. The way that
they do it with Bitcoin is is you'd have to go to a Binance or a Coinbase.
They would give you a debit card. When you went to buy something, all they would do is pull that out of your wallet, cash it out for you with fees, and then put the cash into your on your debit card, and then you would go buy it. But you're really just buying it with cash. With Arcoin, when you go into those places, Home Depot, Lowe's, Delta Airlines, you're not switching anything. You are actually buying it with that
token. Okay, so that's one token, the Tropions.go and Tropions Aus.
Wow.
And I always tell people, you really have to have a strategy in what you're going to do because these are used just like Bitcoin is used, you know, 80% of Bitcoin is held by merchants. I mean, by the big the big businesses, the, you know, Black Rockck and all of that. And all they're doing, they'll never sell it. They're just using it for a balance sheet enhancement or to keep it on their books as as a store of value.
Well, Tropions go gold and trapions a US does exactly the same thing everything that Bitcoin does only we take it to another level with the different uses that you can uh use it for.
So, it continues to go up in value. Now, I can't and it goes down. I got to say both because otherwise I get trouble by just saying it just goes up.
What?
But it goes up, it goes down. The difference is is because we're decentralized on the Bitcoin blockchain, we don't have those swings like Bitcoin. It will never drop from $120,000 to six $60,000 in 15 seconds. Now, we're not the same price as Bitcoin. And people always say, well, if that's your coin, you guys you guys create the you create the value. Well, first of all, anybody that says that doesn't know what they're
talking about as far as cryptocurrency. And second of all, if that was true, I would have a coin the same price as Bitcoin, but it's not. So there's definitely differences on what you can do. But again, ours is set up for an ecosystem and we have a lot of different businesses and and you know, we've like I said, we've buy we've bought houses, we've done all the stuff using the to token as a peer-to-peer token versus a
buy low, sell high type of token that you just turn up back into fiat.
the average cryptocurrencyy's in business for 15 months and normally what happens is is after everybody um buys into it, you know, and they do a rug pull, then everybody loses their money, so they go out of business or the next question is is people say,"Where can I go use this?" And when you can't use it, you just got to store it and then you got to go right back to fiat. You got out of fiat like you were talking about
as an investment. Why do you want to go back to fiat? Why not use use something that continues to grow for your business, for your family, for whatever? It's a store of value. It's an asset, and you use an asset just like you would use stock or anything else. So, we've even written Troptions off as as on with the IRS. So, there's so many different things that you can do with it. Um, it's just really finding what your strategy
is and how you want to move forward.
Wow.
So this is truly another form of currency because
Absolutely.
um recently I was approached by this startup.
Um basically what they're doing is they are taking uh student records from like high schools and colleges and putting them on the blockchain for security and transferring the information. And they're stating that being that it's on the blockchain that it's impenetrable, it can't, you know, be hacked, etc. And that um from from what I understood is that the blockchain is like the train track the secure train track that
that carries information or currency etc. And then I guess in this example the crypto or the Troptions or this uh student record is like the train cart on the tracks that is okay.
Right. Yeah. So, Bitcoin the the Bitcoin blockchain is the highway and then that's why,
So
you know, people don't realize that we're on the Bitcoin highway. So, that means we can do whatever they can do with Bitcoin. whatever you can do with Bitcoin Troptions can do and then some because we've taken it to a whole another level.
So yeah, the Bitcoin blockchain or the Ethereum, you know, Ethereum has its own rail and or blockchain and um a lot of them are Salana has their own, Tron has their own, but yeah, those are their highways and then the people that come in and sign up or mint their own tokens on those highways are basically using those for uh to move on a worldwide basis. Now, the the beautiful thing about all of them is they have ledgers.
And that's why when people go,"Well, I don't know. I can't I don't know if I believe what you you guys sponsored NASCAR teams and all of that." It's real easy to see. It's all on the blockchain. Everything is timestamped and numbered on the blockchain so that you can go back to every transaction and you can see it. Not just me, but anybody on our Zoom can go look up all the transactions of any cryptocurrency if you know
how to do it. It's not hard, but it's all there for everybody to see. That's one of the reasons why we did an audit also from a third party to validate that those transactions were all real and and they all, you know, they're they're not made up.
Once you do a transaction on the blockchain, you can't ever change that. It's never going to be you. I can't go back and go,"Oh, I said this. Let me quick go back and and change it on the blockchain." It doesn't work that way. So, on the blockchain is a very safe place to have it. Um, you know, the Bitcoin blockchain is one of the oldest and hasn't been ever hacked.
So, Bitcoin is just one lane on the highway on the blockchain. It's not the whole thing. Cuz I was thinking that um wait a minute. So for the information, is it true that all of the banking systems like the the um all of our stock exchange, has that already been moved to crypto or on the blockchain? Is that's what's happening with our financial system at this moment?
That's what's going on now. They all haven't moved yet. A lot of people, a lot of businesses right now are waiting what's called the Clarity Act, which hasn't been passed yet.
Um, one of the reasons why we were sued um, back in 2017, 18 and 19 was because none of the administrations or even countries wanted uh, crypto, you know, they were all trying to get rid of crypto. I mean, China had it banned. U, all the other countries had it banned until finally they figured out either get with the program because it's not going anywhere. Now, this new administration wants to make America one of the
crypto hubs of the world. So, they're pro- crypto. They're doing everything making a lot of the tough regulations that the SEC had on crypto. They've they've lightened up on everything basically just about on crypto. So, becoming easier for companies such as ourselves and other people that are out there um to do stuff with with the crypto. But yes, everything is is headed towards the blockchain. Everything's getting ready
to go digital. Um and it's just a matter of time. They're phasing it in now, but it's it's that's where everything's going. Yes.
Great.
We got Lady Rocket on the car. Well, the day
Yes, it's hello. Hello everybody. How How are you? Can you see me? All
Yeah, we see we see you, Ela.
right.
I'm I'm grateful for you real quick, but at the same time, my brother in there, he he's in between dev calls and engineer calls.
Okay, that's fine.
But people, I appreciate you though cuz they don't they don't know what's coming. I I'm spin city a developer engineer.
Hello is coming. Yes.
Uhhuh.
Uh we have a very special uh presentation and a show for you because of doctor's fantastic meeting.
Tony. Yeah. Oh yeah, man.
So welcome.
Yeah, we grateful.
So I understand you have to you need a little bit more time.
Yeah. Yes, indeed. I gotta get my brother to tap in with y'all real quick.
Okay.
Real champion. Um challenge. We we we talked a lot about lovable over the weekend in the summit, y'all. But here's a brother that's directly taking them hands on head on and going above and beyond with apps build with AI.
Grand champion, my brother, let them know your story. Let them know your movement and the reasons why we should take AI apps more important, bro. Because again, we're going to the corporate level. We're putting apps inside of corporations. Da da da. The spin city thing. my brother from uh ANT1, Justin Burns, man. Can you give us the good word, man? Can you can you can you can you let us in on the big business and the importance
of AI apps in Q4? I seen you get up in there, but hey, I know the goat ain't shot.
Hold up, hold up, hold up, hold up. Mic check. Can y'all hear me?
Yes, sir.
Yes,
sir.
There you go.
Come on, man. We come.
The audio is just tripping.
They don't get it.
What's up,
They don't get it,
family?
man. Go ahead, Justin. What's
What's up? What you want me to Oh, you want me to talk about Man, we could we could talk about a lot of stuff,
up?
but man, apps, man, is something for y'all that don't know. I'm Justin Burns, CEO of Apps Build with AI. And uh I've been I buil been building software for the past, man, it's been a minute. 13 years I've been building software. Built my first app called Maestro. Let me just show y'all, man. I'm a visual learner. I like to visualize things. Um, but this is this is the the first um this is the company.
Okay,
Let me see real quick though. Let me see if I can share. We on Google Meets. I don't really use this.
bro. Come home,
Hold on.
bro. You already know how I was going to do it.
Hold on. I'm trying to see what we working with. But while while this while I'm sharing this, so I'm the CEO of Maestro and also apps built with AI. I got I pretty much saw where technology was going, which is I knew it was going to be bigger than what it is even now.
Back in the day, that was about a decade ago, um I started developing. I hired my first developer, burned through about a million dollars. And then about a year ago, I was about a year and a half ago. Wait, a year ago, Claw Code came out for the first time. And uh man, we've been tapped in since then. Built about 10 plus apps. Um, Maestro has 3,000 customers on it. There's a lot of people talking about vibe coding and
coding, yet they really haven't built anything sustainable, right? I know that's not my brother spin. Um, so some of the things I'm going to share with y'all, man, is and I like to repeat this saying this is the greatest time in history. Um, if you don't get wealthy in the next 5 to 10 years from what's happening right now, it's your own fault. I know that sounds very direct, but I'mma just be honest with you. If you don't
get wealthy in the AI age with technology and what I like to refer to as what's happening is the democratization of technology is happening, y'all.
Now, let's go a little deeper though because it ain't just about build apps. It's about three core things, right? One is it's about solving a actual problem that people pay for. And this is the challenge, right? There's so many people just building stuff and they don't really know if people going to pay for it. Now, if you just building a build, that's cool, right? But I'm going tell y'all, man, if if you want to build
something that actually has legacy and where people will vote with their dollars because that's all we do, right? We vote with our dollars. We say if something is valuable, we sign up for it. What I'll tell y'all is most people don't really The first step in all of this is you got to have a worthy idea. Usually what I find is like don't try to reinvent the wheel. Most people they built stuff that people are not going to
buy. You know what I'm saying? So our community as built with AI, you know, we about 90,000 deep.
We got 14y old uh she's a 14-y old girl named Melody. I'm about to feature her spending. I'm about to come out with a documentary. We about to come hard. I'm doing a uh documentary right now on people that's actually building
Yeah.
the future. We got a 14-y old. She built an affirmation app. She's 14. She built it with Lovable.
Heat.
Um she got a thousand customers on that joint. Thousand customers. You know, I talked to her father two days ago to confirm her coming down to do this documentary with us and he was just like,"Man, bro, you changed our life." Like I got a 14 year old who's making, you know, four to five figures a month and don't have to work. So if you built something, you know, I tell people this all the time. If you built something,
built something so people will pay for it. How do you know if people will pay for it? Well, they spending money on it right now.
Don't try to build something. Now sometimes you could build a new platform, but if you really want to make wealth, man, spend money on stuff that's already building. um stuff that people already spending money on and then you make that product better, right? So, there's three ways to make products better. One is pricing. Sometimes you you deal with a company, they might have tra crazy crazy pricing, right? You can have
a lower ticket product um to do that as well. Um or you might have something like, you know, um uncomplicating complicated tools. So, one of the things right now that people think, and maybe some of y'all think this, how many of y'all think like in order to compete with these hundred million, $200 million technology and app companies that you got to got, you you might have to have more features than them? Any of y'all
think that? Let me know in the chat. How many of y'all think that?
Yeah.
Oh man, I gotta have more features.
I gotta have How many of y'all honestly think that? Hey,
Yeah.
Jessica
One in one in the chat if y'all thought that about about them apps.
say put
One in the chat. Y'all know how to do it. Flame it up for the
a one in the chat if you think that. Let me just tell y'all cap.
one.
All cap. All cap. So, that's what these like these beliefs. This what will stop us from actually building stuff. Case in point, I'mma show y'all a few. Let me give y'all some sauce, man. That's my boy. That's my boy. This my boy uh speed.
Come on, man. Let her get that now.
Let me show you. I'm gonna show y'all a couple examples of companies that's that's actually um if you were to recreate these um just so because I I tell people, man, everybody online got opinions, but many people don't come with the data and the facts, right?
Everybody got opinions, but opinions opinions change over time, right? Especially when you discover truth. Let me show y'all this real quick. Um let me see. Share my window. Share entire screen. Okay, there we go. Y'all should see this, right? Y'all see my screen, right?
Yeah, here we
So,
go.
so um this is a platform I use as an example. It's called Eupform, right? I mean, Type Form. So, Type Form is a $100 million company,
Right.
right? It's a basically all it is, y'all, it's a it's a form builder. All it is is a form builder. They do a $100 million, right? How many of y'all being honest, you will see this and you be like,"Man, we can't really compete against something like this." How many of y'all be honest? Be honest in the chat. You be like,"Man, they got money. They got a team." How many of y'all think that?
Be honest. If you looked at something like this and you saw they got $100 million in funding, you might say to yourself,"Man, we can't compete against them." Jessica said,"Yeah, I would think so." Well, this brother right here decided to go up against the juggernaut and he created a platform called Eupform, right? Which basically does the same thing, but what he did was he made a lower price. He basically um made this
lower price, lower tier price. So, look at this. And you know how he found it out online? All the customers was complaining about the fact that this was way too much. They like,"Man, this this product is expensive." Y'all do y'all know how many cut y'all know how many products out here they trying to like they got so much money they have to raise. We was just talking about this with Claude being like even Claude like I'm
doing a workshop on Thursday about Claude and I mean pretty soon I'm not going to be talking about Claude because Claude is getting to that point they're going to be they just became mainstream so they becoming too expensive.
So now the Chinese starting to create these cheaper models that do the same thing and will knock their block off. So they got to watch. That's why you got to watch this. But anyway,
Right.
this dude, he basically created a $29 a month product. Everybody say he was silly, but he built this product. Guess how much this product doing now? This product is doing about $200,000 a month in recurring revenue, right? $200,000 a month. Technology is the biggest way to get wealthy. Technology is the biggest way to get wealthy for like it doesn't like this is the greatest time in history. Let me give y'all another one.
How many of y'all heard of school.com? Y'all heard of school?
Oh, there we
Everybody Everybody heard of school because everybody jumping. Y'all in school,
go.
right? Everybody got school. Everybody in school, right? School jumping, right? Y'all heard of school.
Yeah.
Well, let me give y'all some education on school, right? I know the owners of school, right? I was in a most people don't know this and they don't know. I was in I was in a mastermind with uh Sam Ovenans, who's the founder of school. Most people know like Alex Hermoszi,
but Alex Heroszi came in later. Uh Sam Obans is the creator of this. Now, let me give y'all some facts. Sam started this company about three months ago. And do y'all know y'all can start a school and all these platforms claw code. Now, it takes a little time, but here's what he did. Instead of him listening to everybody, he created a simpler version of this platform, right? A simpler version of school. Everybody was making
fun of him like,"Oh man, it's too basic." D. He ain't listening to people, right? So, he built this and now this pro this platform is worth about $2 billion. if he wanted to sell this platform right now, he could pretty much get about two billion for it.
About two billion dollars. So y'all So let me just tell y'all, man. Um I'mma just tell y'all this. Y'all can keep playing around with this technology stuff if you want to. I'm not playing around with it no more. Like I've been able to, you know, this is we always throw around stats. I mean, just so y'all know, man, like we have a multi-7figure um technology business, you know, multi-se figures. Um, you know, I don't have
a technology degree. I'm not a developer. I'm not a coder. I'm not none of that, right? I just decided to break the chains of poverty that was over my family and I committed to the process of learning this stuff. So, the last couple things I'll show y'all real quick, Ben was talking about this. So this is the first so y'all know because I know it's a lot of people online capping, right? Spin, we know it's a lot of cappers,
right? Um there's a lot of people capping in they raps, right?
They capping. They be they just they see the money and they like,"Oh, I'm AI. I'm Mr. I'm I'm I'm Mrs. and Mr. AI specialist, right?" So I say people capping they raps. So let me let me just show y'all this real quick.
Are you
Um let me show y'all this. So this is my platform, Maestro. I built this in 2016.
Crazy.
We still we still we still alive till this day, right? So this is a Netflix platform, membership platform. Look at this. We built all of this. Spent a lot of money on this. But then Spin was talking about lovable, right? So y'all was talking about lovable this weekend.
Yeah.
So this what this what happened.
Hey,
This how we came to the C.
you know I was waiting on you. Go ahead. and do your
I'm I'mma show y'all. Right. So,
thing.
this what I mean about innovation, right?
Many of y'all you can innovate. But here's the challenge I'mma give y'all that you need to understand. You have So, I was talking about this on a class last night with my students. I said, you know what's going to stop all of y'all from taking advantage of the largest wealth transfer in human history is y'all overthinking? I said this in a class for 200 of my students last night. I said y'all overthinking like your fear.
Like if you were just for a season just to take action as fast. I don't care if you got an idea. I don't care if you know how to build. Just build it imperfectly. Like that's the challenge is what's going to stop most people. They overthink everything and then they built so slow. AI make man AI is so fast. It's going to change in a year. Right? So this is what we did. we built. So, man, some of y'all know the backstory,
but since I built the Maestro platform about I was out the country, I was in I'm from the US.
I was in the country. I was out the country for two years straight, right? Um, two years I was gone. Went to go find myself was traveling to like South Africa, Bswana, Tanzania. Um, I was in uh Thailand, Dubai. Um, and then I finally rested on Bali. So I was in Bali getting my zen on, getting my spirituality on, okay? Cuz man, y'all been to Bali, you you ain't got to deal with all of this. I was in Bali for about six months.
And then one day, my homeboy called me. He was like,"Man, you see this claw code lovable stuff?" I was like,"What? What is that?" I had never heard of these platforms. He was like,"Yo, AI can actually code your platform." I was like,"Let me see." I saw it start coding. That's all I needed to see. That's all I needed to see. And I spent about a month trying to master these platforms. And at the time, it wasn't as easy as
it is now, Spike, y'all got the golden ticket.
It's much easier to build now.
Yeah.
Back in the day, about a year ago, man, you had to just figure it out or know somebody who knew somebody. So, fast forward, we start hosting these summits. We started getting the demand.
Heat.
We was putting about our first summit we got 5,000 people to register. The second summit was 12,000 people that wanted to learn about how to do AI coding. So far total we have we've had about 90,000 people who have attended our summits, right? Which is crazy to even think about, right? 90,000 people. We spend over We spend over $100,000 a month on advertising. That's how aggressive I am, right? You might say, Justin, yo,
that is that true? Well, I told you I don't need to I don't need to lie to you. I can show you that's how much we spend on ads every month because it's this simple. And I tell y'all this and I wrap it up. It's this simple, right?
You need a great offer. Some of y'all need to be writing this down. You need to have a validated idea that somebody is spending money. Number one. Number two, you need to have a great product that you're building. Whether it's a course, my two favorite things to sell is courses, but apps are just next level. If you put to if you put those two together, let me tell let me give y'all a hat, right? If you have I call it a
tech ecosystem. I can't go deep into it for the sake of time today, but it's a tech ecosystem. If you combine a app with a course with a community together, you'll win. You'll win. You'll win. A course,
I'm doing
I'm talking about packaging. I'm not talking about separate.
it.
I'm talking about together. Course, community, app, you package it up together. You can sell the me. If you good, you can sell it.
like I'm I'm I'm good at what I And then let's add even on another one. You add in a little bit of coaching, right? You add coaching. That's the four I call the four the the the the the four elements of you could you can I'm here to tell you, man. You ain't got to listen to me, but I'mma tell you. You can make seven figures by yourself without a team. All the stuff that they used to have us do, they all You got to throw
all those beliefs out the door though. You got to throw all those beliefs out the door about I need to hire 20 people. No, you don't. You're in the AIH. Like, like you need four elements. You need an app, need a course to go along with that, like video so people can watch it, community to go aside with it, and you need to be able to coach people, right? So, this was me in the beginning. Now, I got four coaches in the program
because the program got 2,000 people in it now.
Got four coaches. I don't even do the calls no more. Y'all do one call a month and all my people show up. All right. And then I got an app that led to me thinking and I'm going tell y'all I had the same feeling that some of y'all have. Right. You may say Justin, you got experience. So about let me tell y'all how how greatness is is created. So I was I was one of uh y everybody know lovable here. Right. Right.
Yeah.
Uh everybody lovable here.
Yeah. Yeah. We went over it.
Thank you.
Okay. So, Lovable, just so y'all know,
Yeah.
Lovable is worth $13.3 billion. They just got a check cut to them for $500 million, right? So crazy when you think about the size of these companies. I'm like, I'm I I was one of I was Lovable's top affiliate,
Yep.
one of their top affiliates about maybe about five months ago.
I was cuz I that was the number one platform I recommended. They was cutting your boy real short, Spin. They was cutting your boy's low checks. And I was like,"Wait,
Okay.
I done put about a thousand people on this platform and I'm getting a $1,000 check. What's up, Spin?" You know, like that's that's the cuz the commission rate and that's another way y'all make money, too. You make money. There's so many ways to make money online. You can make money from recommending other people's product. Like, I'mma tell you, spin everybody here. If you get value from this, you should be promoting this
so that you can make money on this program, right? You have an affiliate program. So, here's what happened, right? Here's what happened. I was trying to reach out to their people and they people was ignoring me. I was like, why can I put a thousand people on your platform and I ain't even got a response from a rep.
That's why you got to always treat your people really good, right? So, here's what happened. I met with my team and I said, you know, we done built this community of like 90,000 people. Like, we really have made a thing in this space. We've changed a lot of people's lives. People, man, if I tell y'all the stories of people 50 plus years young, they building app technology companies because you're not just building an app,
you're building a tech company, right? I think y'all need to understand the value of what you building. That's what I program my people. I'm like,"Look, we say app building to each other, but really you're building a technology company." So, watch this. We was on a call one day and I was making a joke and I was like,"Man, y'all want to go headtohead with uh Lovable?" And my team was like,"What?" I like,"What you mean?"
So, I was like,"No, for real. What if we built a competitor to lovable?
Would you think we could do it?" And that's not kind of something you could vive code. There's some complex projects that you have to really work it out. But probably I want to say we talked about it for a week and we decided to build that joint. So for the last three months we've been building a competitor to Lovable that actually launches next month, y'all. So well technically October um it launches. Let me give y'all
Can I give him a little preview spin? And watch this.
and we need that.
Let me tell Let me give y'all Y'all want a preview?
And you better bring me in on that,
Y'all want to see?
man. It's not a
Um, let me tell y'all something real quick,
game.
Sign us up,
too.
Justin. Sign is up.
Listen, it's up. Um, here here's what I also tell y'all. The same thing I kind of I talk I'm not teaching y'all going deep, but I'mma tell y'all.
Once you find something that's working and already making money, this how you separate yourself from everybody else. You find out what the holes um what their holes are, what their like what what are the customers complaining about that they're not doing. That's how you win. Don't copy somebody, right? It's easy to copy people. It's much harder. It's better to basically build on what's already working in their program
and then after you build on what's already working in their program, you then make the product better, right? So, let me show y'all how we did that. We So, here's here's how we did that. Let me give y'all a example so y'all could do this in your own products. So one we noticed this stat 90% of people who code and lovable replet whatever claw code all the tools 90% of people never launch. Now this is a stat I believe that's
across every board every every platform every this could be this could be catered to because when it comes to success most people quit.
I'm not telling y'all something to discourage you. I'm just being real with you. Most people quit, right? When it comes to things, they quit. Okay, so here's the stats. 90% of people who code on these platforms, they never launch. They It's like a dream. They just build something and then they never launch it. Right? That's one. Out of the 90% of people who I mean the 10 that leaves 10%. out of the 10% of people who launch
who actually get to the finish line and launch their product,
All
only about maybe about um 8% of them ever make over $10,000 in a single calendar year, right? Over $10,000 in a year.
right.
That leaves one to 2%. That's why we call them That's why I call my people the 1enters because I'm like, look, this how we get out of the game. Step one, you find an idea that's working and you make it better. I'm gonna give y'all the summary that I'm going to show y'all the platform.
Step one, you find an idea and that's already making money and you make it better. You find out what the holes in that armor is and you and you basically don't copy them. Model what they're doing and make the product better. Number one. Number two, you built the product fast. Stop trying to make a perfect product. Build something. Get it to market. Most of the time, being real with y'all, I sell stuff before it's even
done. And I tell my customers like,"Look, this is in beta. Some of y'all think that you got to have a perfect product before people give you money." Uh-uh. That ain't true. That's why I win a lot of times because a lot of times I might even say,"Hey, listen. My product is in beta and I'm selling it before it's done." Andy say founders launch. Andy, you done been on my training before? Andy, you'd have been on my training.
Andy must have been I see. I already know.
where somebody using my language. I'm like, Andy, I already know what's I said.
founders launches.
Oh,
Hey,
founders launch.
real quick,
I said,
Justin. Justin, before not to cut it right there, but the founders launch,
"Yeah,
nobody was realizing what I was doing, bro. Remember December a Minty one founders launch. A Minty 2 in spring was a founders launch.
right." Yep.
New3 was a founders launch and how you always said keep on launching.
Yep.
Every launch is a founders
Keep on launching. That's the secret, right Andy? No.
launch.
Like that's the biggest thing that and why my people actually make money instead of just buying stuff because I tell them the same advice. You always do. You should be always launching family. Nobody. Let's say your first launch you get zero customers. Who knew that you got zero customers except you? Hello. Only you.
again.
Only you know that you had zero customers. Only you. You know what most people do? They be like,"Oh, I got zero customers." Okay, so launch it again.
Bravo.
All you I tell people just keep keep launching.
Great advice. Keep
Like people be like people be waiting to get to the bag.
louning.
It's like you keep like every I'mma tell y'all how some of y'all like one launch away from being successful. I'mma tell y'all the first product I launched was called Script Engage. It was my first app in 2016. The first time we launched we had zero customers. Same product. Watch this. Same product, zero customers. I launched it again. Same product, zero customers. I launched it again. Same product, zero customers. I launched
it again. Three customers on the fourth one. Do you think I gave up? No. I'm like, every launch I'm like, what I do? Is the messaging is this off?
Fantastic.
Is this what's this? Like some of y'all don't be tapping into y'all energetic spirituality that y'all are like the like like spirit has endowsed you with the ability to become energy like shifters. That's what I am. Some of y'all like y'all give up after the first try. You be like like you're like I'm a that's what I realize. I'm a spiritual architect. It's not about it working the first time. It's about man, you have
the ability that other people in this universe don't have. That is shifting paradigms. So I'm like, what's the Okay, what I do? Okay, the messaging that's bad. Okay, boom. I'm not promoting it like this. Fifth time I meet this dude in in in Las Vegas. He's an affiliate manager. He's like, let me get you some affiliates on this launch. He was like, have you launched before? I was like, oh yeah, we done launched. I did about
five launches with like three customers, y'all.
The sixth launch, the sixth launch, 500 customers on the sixth launch. The seventh launch, 1,000 customers. The eighth launch, 1,500. The e, the ninth launch, 10,000 customers. That launch we did like half a million dollar. If I would have gave up on the first five that didn't work, I would have missed out on the go, family. Y'all see what I'm saying? If I would have been like,"Oh, the first one didn't work. The second
one didn't work.
Yeah.
The third one didn't work. The fourth one didn't work." No, I'm like, it's only this what this the mindset you got to have. And I'm gonna show you how apps do with AI. It's only a matter of time before it work. That's my mentality. That's it's only a matter of time before I figure it out, family, before I get a download from spirit, before I get any type of anything. It's like I might get an idea like what am I doing wrong?
D. It's like we try to control the process when it doesn't work. It doesn't work. I need to move on to something else. Maybe or maybe you ain't going hard enough. Maybe you're not launching enough. So every time something don't work, I'm relaunching. I'm relaunching. I'm relaunching. So, this is Let me show y'all this real quick and then I can tell y'all this. So, this is um this is what we uh this what we've been working
on. Let me see if this window works. I think it works. Yeah. All right. So, this is going to be this is the new apps built with AI platform. So, basically, um this will allow for you to build your entire app from A to Z. um similar to Lovable, but I'mma actually show y'all the back end of it. So,
I
this is this is this is the back end of Azville with AI.
can't
This kind of Hold on.
Let me I may not let me let me just show y'all. Right. This exclusive. Hold on. Let me stop. I may I ain't showed this yet. Spin. Only Only my inner circle showed it. Should I show y'all this?
man. Well, you better get Come on,
Let me not Should I show y'all the sauce,
man. You better give me that damn Come on, man.
man? This gonna make y'all a lot of money. Should I show y'all the sauce?
Y'all, you cold over there, man. Let us get that,
I don't know. I don't know. Ain't nobody really seen the chat like that,
man.
you know. All right, let me show y'all real quick. So, this was dropping in the next this was dropping in the next 30 days, right? Ain't no platform gonna be like this. So, this is the brand new asbuilt with AI platform. So, these are actual apps that the platform has built, right?
So we built this yesterday. This was a medical app for tracking medications, right? This was built in under 10 minutes using our platform. Um, so this actually manages your medication uh with AI bots and everything. This was built in under 10 minutes, family. Did y'all hear me? Under 10 minutes using our platform. You can also build live websites. So y'all know how all the sites be looking AIish. Well, this actual site
right here was built with apps built with AI in under seven minutes. All right, so this website, this entire website was built in under seven minutes. Uh this is a cargo website um that you can see um as built with AI though. Uh like let me just tell y'all the first platform that you can build is how many of y'all know what a uh anybody know what a PR is product? It's called uh product documents. All right. So some of
you one of the problems that we're solving with this platform is most people don't really have an app idea or sometimes they don't know if their app idea is good.
So now what you can do with our platform is you can actually plan out your entire app from A to Z and AI will actually build your entire app before you spend money on credits. Here's a news flash. You know how some of y'all complain about credits? The reason why most people complain about credits is because they don't plan their app and all the features and
Mhm.
all the journey and the users. They don't plan a scope first. So, this is going to save you a lot of money because you'll be able to plan out your whole app, give it right to AI, and boom, you gonna save money and credits, family. They The reason why they don't want you to have a planning system is because they want you to spend all the money on credits, right? It's how they make they want you to spend.
Y
So, they don't want you to have a planning tool. So,
earlier.
we gonna have one of the first planning tools.
We also gonna have different crazy uh we call them 5D websites. Y'all see all of this? So these are all the websites you're going to be able to build inside of apps built with AI. All custom this don't and these are only like 20 templates. We're going to have a library of like 20 different templates so you can build uh any type of website any type of custom joint. Oh y'all on lovable, don't worry about it. You can import
the project. Go ahead smackaroo right up in my project right up in the system.
It's
So you get to be able to uh port your whatever project you're building.
amazing.
Um also here's the last couple things. We also integrate with every mostly everyone, right? So you can connect Stripe, Superbase, everything to our platform and you can be able to take payments right away. You could do custom domains. This the biggest thing though, remember I was telling y'all about uh finding your customer. So we are the first platform app building platform that will basically allow for you to actually
market your app.
Nobody has this. All right.
Nope.
Nobody has this.
Wait
So apps with AI will scan your entire app as built with AI will scan your entire
for
platform, right? It will scan your entire platform and it will actually go in and it will find your customers. You can also run ads. You can also uh create AI videos and everything for your app. That's where we coming, family. So, you can build anything. And see my team, they up in here. Look at this. They building all type of stuff in here. Um this is what they building. This is like I'm giving y'all behind the scenes
exclusive. This ain't this ain't public yet, but we we actually building uh invoice systems, um everything, right? and we basically pushing the limits of what's possible. Like here's a app that as Build with AI built itself as well. Um and yeah, man, we we it's about to go down.
So that's why I told you man, some of y'all got to push, you know, this didn't exist 45 days ago, but I had the belief in myself. Just watch this y'all because I don't tell I don't teach I ain't like these influence. I don't teach nothing. I ain't preaching. That was that's like I would say uh number number um number 10. This is probably number 10 on the difficulty number 10 of how difficult this platform was to build.
Y'all think that stopped me or you think the challenges stopped me? No family. Like I've been working with developers. I'm like build it like this. Boom boom boom. Build it this way. Boom boom boom. Build it this way. Like you got to push the levels of ingenuity. Yeah. We going to go. Yeah. Keep this up in here, family. We going to go ahead and serve them notices out. Lawyers on deck. Lawyers on deck.
Hey,
Keep that.
I offer y'all a summit and I offer y'all an inner city uh inner circle meeting,
Keep.
but keep everything in this m* or we going to come get you. Hey, don't even worry about it.
Yeah. So, that's just showing y'all a little preview. Man, we we uh we coming we coming hard. Um we also working on some other technology that is uh a little bit
Yeah.
private. Uh but we are officially if you guys join the weight list at asbillwithaii.com um you can join the weight list you could drop I think somebody dropped the link in the chat. Um yeah so y'all can join the weight list man. And y'all gonna see October 13th through the 16th. That's in about a month and a half. We're gonna do this big event with like 20,000 people, right? Um, Sebastian, I'mma invite you to the studio
that we that we doing it at. We doing it in this big studio,
What's
man.
up?
We about to go big. We want to put about 10,000 people on this platform, man. So,
Let's
that's that's my advice, man, to y'all, man. Go big or go home.
go.
I don't want to hear about your experience. I don't want to hear about where you grew up. I don't want to hear about none of that. I grew up on the south side of Chicago with no no family support, no nothing. Um, and I was able I've been able to build what I built, man. So, I'm grateful to Spirit. I'm grateful to Source. Um, I'm just grateful that I get to be a conduit in other people's success, man.
Right.
And that's what some of y'all need to do. Stop thinking I'm going to give y'all this last piece of advice, encouragement. Stop thinking about your own personal ecosystem,
Start.
right? Like it's too many of us in the spiritual realm, we so worried about just paying bills.
Like we just so that's like if if if that's what you worried about like you got to think bigger. Like you got to think like you're if you come from if you really believe which I know if Sebastian teaching y'all y'all believe this, right? If you believe you come from source energy, why are you even thinking anything in lack? Why why does that even that shouldn't even be in your that shouldn't even be in your energy field.
And if it is, you need to rip it out cuz source ain't nothing about source in poverty consciousness. Nothing in source. So, but see, we think that we got to go trade time for money. And there's nothing wrong working at J O, man. But this is the time I feel like where source and all the ancestors are here where we need to show up for ourselves and build the future. Y'all, I don't think y'all realize what's coming. You want
to know why? You want to know why everybody talking about darkness so much spin?
Everybody talking about it's so dark. It's so dark. Yeah, it's dark. You want to know why dark is happening? Because it's light on the other side that they don't want you to see, family. They don't want you to see that you about to go through one of the greatest times in history. They don't want you to see that very soon there's technology coming where they gonna slap a band on your wrist and it's going to be able to tell
you everything wrong with your body. I'm not talking about 10 years out. I'm talking about five years. We about to go through like all the stuff that's happened. They don't want you to see it. They want to block you with higher prices. They want to say,"Oh, everything increasing." Yeah. You want to know why they increasing all the prices? Why you got to make bread? Why you gotta make money? You gotta make money because
they raising the price to get you to not be able to afford the promises.
So that's why I'm like, listen, no, no, no. Like when people see me, they like, Justin, you making this, you you at this level. I'm like, no, I'm just seeing what's happening. I don't want my family to go through that. I don't want my family to be on the other side of this and being like, man, we can't afford groceries. That's not abundance, family. Don't let them trick you out of your Don't let them trick you out of your
promises. So, I say this in wrapping up, man. Go build something. You should be spending the I don't care if you work a job. I don't care if you got a business. You should be spending the next 60 to 90 days locked in on some type of product that can set you free. All right? You should be locked in 60 to 90 days. No exceptions. You should be locked in no matter how hard it is. Whatever you struggling with, if it's important
to you, you should be locked in. And we all struggle with something, right?
Like me, I struggle with health sometimes. But you know what? Guess what I did? I made it. Watch this. This is going to be powerful, too. I like I like man, I need to focus on my health. I had been going to the gym. Source was like, make enough money and then pay somebody who's a coach who can help you with that. And I made enough money. Now I'm in the gym four, five times. I lost about 30 lbs in the last two months just
being challenged in the gym. Like we're going through a transformational period right now where I'm being challenged. Family, everything that you want is on the other side of you facing scarcity. Let me say that again for the people in the back. Everything that you want is on the other side of you facing your scarcity demons. This is stuff that's embedded in your nervous system. They've embedded this stuff strategically
into into your cells, into your DNA.
You want to know why? Because they know it's hard to change it. But you are the light. You know what I'm saying? You are the light. You are source energy.
All
You can transfer all those scarcity stuff. And you know how you get on the other side of it? You just use your energetic frequency to build family. That's what you got to do. You got to channel all of that stuff into building.
right.
Is it going to be hard? Yes. Are you gonna get a couple lumps on your head? Yes. You gonna be lumped up. If you go to build something great,
Thanks.
you gonna get some lumps. Take it with stride. You gonna get hit in the head. Saturday some stuff went down. I was like,"Oh, we got the solution." Monday the solution came up. Right. So, I just want to encourage all my spiritual family, man.
Go out and build something great. Take the lumps. Just keep building, man. As Bill with AI, let me give y'all another encouragement. As Build with AI ain't funded by nobody but me. It would cost half a million dollars to build something like Asville with AI. It's a lot. But guess what? I'm putting I'm because I'm so in focus mode and because I'm building so
Yeah.
hard, I'm funneling the money, I can fund my own projects. Y'all get what I'm saying?
I'm taking all the resources and I'm funneling it and as with AI is going basically be its own channel and marketing, man. So, listen, that's all I got today,
We grateful, bro.
y'all.
Trust me, bro. We grateful. Y'all burn this place up for my brother, man. Definitely tap in with Absil with AI and Justin. I am taking them over the next 120 days. Absolutely through Q4, the Q4 AI accelerator. So again y'all, we taught on lovable, but as soon as Justin dropped that, y'all already know how I get.
It's by the family, for the family, within the family. It's all in house. Everybody that's going into the Q4 AI accelerator will have access to apps built with AI. I will be there to help you. Uh I mean the app itself is going to help you build.
actually
You see all the steps, funnels. I'll be there to help you, guide, guide you. I'm there for your marketing. I'm there for your meta ads. Y'all know again the summit. Everything we did on the summit y'all is everything we going to with uh
employed. I'm
Q4 and and it's all with the family by the family in house.
sorry.
Y'all, we appreciate you, bro. We appreciate you, bro. We about to get into outer space next. I mean, we cooking, man. I told him this summer was going to be different, bro. So, I'm definitely definitely grateful that you tapped in, bro. Appreciate you, bro.
Yes. So, y'all y'all can follow me on Instagram, man.
without
Um, if y'all want to stay tapped in, join the weight list, man.
Appreciate my brother Sebastian.
Yeah.
Y'all tap in, man. This AI stuff is this stuff is this stuff is crazy and it's and it's about to it's about to be up, y'all. So, appreciate you, Sebastian. I tap in with y'all soon.
All right, bro.
I peace.
Man, one minute 60 seconds worth of What other summits you been to that have been like this? Well, what other summits you been through to be like this? And for 300 bucks, 297. I said, give me three days.
touch.
$100 a day for this, man. Peace to the family, man. Let's go ahead and go to outer space next. I know Justin had to get that in. You know what I'm saying? Let's go to outer space next. because he able. Let's get it. Did you hear me?
Hey, good morning. Is Is this the time to start?
Yep. Yep. Yep. It's all you now. You on the big screen.
Oh,
We see
fantastic. Well, thank you.
Thank you, Sebastian, Dr. Tonee.
it.
Thank you for being such a passionate advocate for incredible mission that you're introducing me to and your community. H I appreciate being here with you. I am Lady Rocket. And when Justin was talking lounge, lounge, lounge and founder, founder, founder, I felt like at home because I lounge and because I am founder. But I want to also tell you that your lounge can also be empowered beyond unreasonable dreams. And by the
way, just to introduce myself, I am investor. I learn how to build technology, how to make money on technology, how to help others make money on technology in the place that optimize this skill, which is Silicon Valley. But I am coming to you from Los Angeles because I decided that true empowerment comes when you are able to combine creativity, music, art, entertainment, space, rockets, and something that I want to tell
you about a secret of a venture capital funding as yet another way for you not to have to wait a year or two to accomplish position of being rich but sometimes making it possible with one meeting.
I also want to introduce myself as an art collector, an art sponsor and someone who has been working with black community for a long time. Uh I am sharing with you a word as you might recognize. It's a Mandela's face. It's a famous sculpture done by the most famous South African sculpture Marco Oliver. And this award was given to me by Damon at Artbasel Miami. But something also I want to introduce to you as an art collector.
You can see this beautiful painting behind me. It's going to be auction off for between $500,000 to $1 million. But what's unique about it is I am also involved with Formula 1 which is untapped source of financial energy. Maybe this is another discussion. But as you can see Louis Hamilton, Lady Rocket Rocket and I managed to pay enough the artist who the most famous Canadian artist to paint me into this painting. Well,
why is this art here? How is it connected to call to action called lounge? because I do own rockets and I do take art, billionaires, collectibles and cryptocurrency and AI in space.
If there is something that I want to leave you with is an understanding that like Justin and Dr. Tonee has been sharing with you. This is incredible timing for unprecedented creation of wealth especially in area of AI but also there is another area that through Dr. Tonee and her relationship with my company, Capernic Space could be a mutual consideration for you. And this place is where I would love to see more African-Americans
because so far I see very few, very few if at all is a space economy and AI and space economy are like that and the demonstration of wealth. I cannot give you all the detail. I will be sharing with you significant points is some of you might have noticed that Elon Musk by the way I am a client and partner of Elon Musk and I will mention couple of things about it but for your for jolting you and making you look at yourself
in a different new light and finding new ways to get funded in addition to what Justin proposed which is absolutely valuable path, but I want to talk to you about a path that made Elon Musk a trillionaire and also path that demonstrated that even Wall Street and I know that we are here to talk about black wall street and this is why I wanted to be here because I strongly believe in black wall street just a new version
in AI and space and I am working with representatives of Tulsa, city of Tulsa because this is where the biggest new wealth creation also needs to take place.
Going back to Elon Musk, going back to the world's creation, you might have noticed that Elon took Space X public about almost exactly a month and a half ago. It was on July 11th. Okay. Historical date also for for all of us because you know what happened? Wall Street and big money people took their head offs and bowed toward a new economy called AI and space and SpaceX gained valuation of almost $2 trillion unprecedented
recognizing that wealth is in AI and wealth is in space and wealth comes from being empowered to use new source of wealth that comes for free. New source of wealth that I utilized as a American and European entrepreneur. Source of wealth that can empower you instantaneously to be able to finance development of your technology, finance market entry, and most importantly give you financial value that you deserve. And this
new source of funding that is untapped, especially black by black African-American community is called venture capital. Venture capital and Dr. Tonee and I might have more absolutely incredible information about it. But let me tell you about venture capital.
Venture capital is the single source of major money that comes to you without necessity of worrying about credit, paying loans, making monthly payments. It comes to you for free based on something that so many of you already have. Everything that I learn about you from Dr. Tonee, I know that there is already a lot of you who have it. And what it is, something that Justin also referred to is number one, strong belief in
yourself and your vision to transform your talents, your imagination, your personal courage into something that is called startup. And there's a huge difference between being a startup versus small business. And difference is measured in billions of dollars. when you meet with the venture capital and I met on several occasion. My company copernic space is funded of course by family capital also my son and I but we have
a very major venture capital and angel investors angel investors is another incredible source that maybe we can discuss at some other time but I promised Dr. for Tony to talk to you about the venture capital. Do you know that every company that is worth forget billions trillions started with the struggling founders frequently a single person who had a compelling vision and had a perseverance and smartness and some help
of getting a meeting with venture capital.
The people who wouldn't be where they are include Zuckenberg, Jeff Bezos, Elon Musk, Lady Rocket, Grand Blaze and do you know magic magic of venture capital their business is to take horrendous risk and write you the check based on the PowerPoint or AI type of a presentation. This is why it's imperative and I know that Dr. Tonee is teaching it that you understand how to selfexpress through mini mini mini business plan
and not your you know uh 100 pages that bank is asking you three pages one page three powerpoint slides and walk in and have someone set up a meeting with me because I am also venture capitalist and as a matter of fact I am discussing possibility of launching fund with Dr. Tonee, that would be specifically optimized around incredible founders like you and you know the time has come because not that venture capital doesn't
want to finance you but there is this lack of bridge between you and VC. Do you know that only 0.5% of venture capital money goes to African-American startups because there are no people that bring us together? There is only the second group that compares in smallness of the founding that comes from VC that compares to African-Americans.
And you know who it is? People like me, white women, they get miserable 1.5% of venture capital funding. Not that they don't want to finance us, but we are not coming prepared to give them an opportunity to write you a big check. Facebook happened because Peter Seal, Peter Seal, he's still around, listened to Zuckenberg for about 7 minutes. Seven minutes. And he said,"Okay, here's my check, $500,000. Go and build your
prototype." Do you know that Jeff Bezos couldn't get funded? He got $20,000 from his mother, from his family members finally to get enough money to travel to Silicon Valley and pitch his company. Do you know that those who gave him $20,000 when he was at so-called seat funding level walked away with $200 million when he went public? That's the leverage of having startup versus small business. Acceleration of your value
is instantaneous and one of the most important skills that is frequently lacking not only about among Africanameans white entrepreneurs have the same problem. I had to overcome this problem which means how do I decide what is a value of my company when I work to walk into my first angel investor or venture capital meeting and it better be hovering somewhere around 1 million to 5 million because people don't have a man
time to write a smaller checks let me tell you I am part of the Silicon Valley and I am part of the investment community here in Los Angeles.
And let me tell you what's happening and why this is absolutely perfect crazy timing to take a chance after of course you get groomed and prepared and educated. Do you know I was just talking with one of the top venture capital guys in Silicon Valley and do you know what he told me? He said,"Lady Rocket, this is absolutely crazy time. I have 24 years olds walking into my office with nothing but a piece of paper or a one
slide presentation on a tablet and they are telling me that they are worth $1 billion. Those are the times that we live in. I increased valuation of my company four times during last six six months. I told you I own rackets. Why? Because I wanted to create business that addresses ultra wealthy and my rackets are positioned as something for ultra wealthy who already have Ferraris, Lamborghinis, Bugattis, private jets, uh
private yaks. What else can you have? Well, private rockets with a private rocket launch,
Thank you.
but also I make money and provide opportunity to make money in very unusual, very generous and very innovative way.
When we take something inside of the rocket number one, it starts registering among the elite of the space industry, one of the wealthiest people. two, instead of being just AI agent, it becomes real world space asset, connectivity of blockchain, connectivity to crypto. And then when you go in space and come back in about 30 minutes on average, the value of Omega watch that they send in space from $10,000 or $20,000 goes
to $1 million. Why? because it creates ultra rare collectible unprecedented. Thus, my rocket that is lifting off from the billionaires islands Azoros is taking in space some AI agents. Dr. Tonee was participating in my super in-person event at the Regan Foundation with veterans and billionaires because I'm sending in space XRP and a Bitcoin but XRP represents the image of horses dogs used by American veterans and military
and we are fundraising for US veterans and their dogs and horses because there is one wealth creation that venture capital and investors respond to. Show your generosity. If you have authentic, proven, not a traditional philanthropy that you write a check and nothing happens, you add value to your NFT, to your token, to your AI agent.
If you schedule part of it to function to benefit others, let it be veterans, let it be artists. I have one of the largest NFT art collection. If you go on X, by the way, I live on X because this is where big financial transactions happen. Instagram is good for being a celebrity, being influencer,
Yeah.
but if you want to belong to the category of founders, investors, get investors attention, be on X. Especially now that X launched YouTube type of capabilities. You can stream, you can have a media channel, video channel on X. Plus, this is where investors are. This is where big transactions are enough. This is where Bitcoin, XRP, Dodge communities live. And of course, someone that plays some part in my life, which is
Elon Musk, who owns X. So I wanted to just highlight I know you have a busy agenda and I very much appreciate the opportunity to um be your guest and support your important mission. Let me conclude my agent I was wearing something different. My agent made me change into this jacket because I suspect there's a lot of you who are also creators and to me fashion is the most important language art and fashion.
So this jacket is from my lady racket art collection is going in space. It will have AI agent attached to it and I want to leave you with the ideas of thinking about AI as a way to enrich financial value of something that you might be already doing. T-shirt fashion. Uh by the way this is the t-shirt with I believe there's a Bitcoin. This is from my rocket launch which went to the moon with Elon. We have art and AI agents
on the moon waiting for the auction. So I want to leave you with a song, Men on the Moon, because it's ultimately about going to the moon. Okay.
Thanks.
Thank you so
Thank you.
much.
We grateful. But burn the place up. What other stomach? What other summit, family? What other place? What other circle? Come on,
Thank you so much.
man.
It's a it's an honor to be here with all of you and thank you Dr. Tonee for introducing me and I want to welcome all your guests also to Lady Rocket events.
Let's mix. Let's come together. Togetherness is powerlessness. Togetherness is powerlessness.
Lady Rocker, I appreciate you tapping in, Dr. Tonee. Wonderful guest to bring to the table to the summit. Especially when we sit around and we say,"Man, this one gonna be different." All right, we going uh we gonna do a 10 minute I think from 11:00 a.m. You know, y'all know usually we go on lunch. I don't already have my wings. Usually we go on a break. Let's get some water. Let's stretch. Let's think about what we just
heard the last few hours, y'all. What have we been through already? We We've been through code. We've been through AI ownership, AI agents, business progress, automation, robotics, space, apps. Hey, let's go ahead and take 10. Take 10 and think about what we got to think about. We still got Chad Arrington coming through. One of the biggest AI systems creators out there, you know what I mean? Did did his thing. He will
tell his story. But let's take 10, y'all. Um, congregate is going to congregate.
I know y'all like to sit down and um and talk amongst each other on break. Give your boy uh 10 minutes y'all. 2:45 p.m. Eastern. 2:45, hour 45. Um, I'll be right back in here for a quick chat and uh we'll we will bring in brother um Chad Arrington and my brother Chief SBS before I go on break. I mean we going to come back from break. We come back break. How do y'all feel about this? I need you know I need that moment.
Y'all know I be needing them moments. my social media moments to tell the world what else we got going on here. From voice, from heart, from spirit, how are y'all enjoying this summit and this secret day?
inspiring. Okay.
And that's and I just want to say so, so Jessica, you've already put out you've already put out your testimonial about the two days. Now you experience day three.
Listen,
You feel like you was
can I keep this real with y'all? Can I tell y'all something?
I have spent a lot of money in my professional development on conferences with the hope that when I leave
early.
there, I am inspired, aspired, have information I can use and actually go apply it. This is absolutely the first conference and I'm 44. I've been to over 100 conferences between construction, uh, real estate, uh, personal development, motivational like just the fact that these leaders are coming here to bless us not only with their presence, with their knowledge, offering to give us other legs up that I don't even think
Spin was expecting them to say out their mouth like this here is absolutely Absolutely the most phenomenally put together conference that I have ever experienced in my lifetime. When I tell you that you're usually going to conferences and people are trying to sell, sell, sell instead of give, give, give. Y'all have given us so much in the last three days. I don't know how I'mma recover from this. Like when I get off of
this, I'm going to have to take a nap just to calm my brain down to be able to get back in the ring and get things started again because I have never experienced this highlevel applicable knowledge in the way that it has been presented here in the last three days.
That is what is up right there. That's strong. That's strong.
Yeah,
Any more good voice?
man.
I do want to go on break,
I actually Yeah,
but I got to I got to hear this. Dood, what's up?
actually I came in to give value. I was and I was busy doing some stuff about to do some other stuff. I was like,"Dang, let me sit back, man. I'm I'm getting it, too." You see what I'm saying?
Man, I'm getting it
getting the value. But the but but when I think about I strive to be the best and the crazy thing
too.
is like you brought people in that that is is ranking people I know like Justin I he was the first one to actually bring a robot to to invest fest you know what I'm saying a couple years back but all you just mentioned SBS I was just talking to uh Barbie her
Mhm.
his his wife to do my tax stuff her but to when I think about bringing greatness
What? Yeah.
in one place you know what I'm and the the the the amazing uh lady that just went on, you know, to think about the real world real assets and and and you know,
Yeah.
for people to understand tokenization and stuff like that and putting putting value and equity in the tech side, Justin say make it simple, man. But you know, when you put these pieces together, man, I appreciate you and I appreciate the value that I gave I mean that I that I gained, you know, not not just the opportunity, man. and and you know, shout I tell you, my brother, putting them putting them pieces together, you
know what I'm saying? Cuz that that's that's that's what um a real teacher is. You know what I'm saying? Putting putting the ecosystems in in one place cuz sometimes even as a builder, we can be narrow-minded, you know, um on on certain things.
You know what I'm saying? So, shout out to you, my brother. I appreciate the value myself.
Yeah, that's what's up right there,
Let's go.
brother. That's what it's what it's all about. Giving value to the family. Giving back. Giving back. Giving back for sure. All right, y'all. Let's do a break. Let's do Let's do Ken. Let's do 250. Let's do uh your hour and 50 on a minute. We'll come back through Chad Arrington to come through. Tell you his story, his past, his modern times, and his future and AI systems. I won't even do an intro without him. All right,
y'all. Let's take 10. Let's take 10. Let's take Let's breathe. Let's drink water. And let's go see the sun. I've been sitting down teaching. I don't know if y'all been able to move, but I've been sitting down teaching, watching, listening, getting my own value. Let's take 10, y'all. Peace. What up y'all? What up? What up?
What up? What up? What up? We back at it. How y'all feeling? How y'all feeling? How we feeling? One's in the chat. We feeling good. Two's in the chat like spin. This ain't it. Two mean this ain't it, man. I need a little bit more than this. All right, y'all. All right. All right. So, y'all, you know what I'm saying? I'm again, I know all y'all are saying,"Hey, you good to most seminars, webinars, uh, and stuff like that.
All they do is sell you." I do have something to tell you. And it is the Q4 accelerator. If you've enjoyed what you've experienced the last three days, please come enjoy four more months of it and let us carry you and walk with you into the new year. Okay? Okay? We'd love to have you talk that real quick. He said he good to go. He said he good to go. And yeah, I did put on the summit and I taught and Aku taught and um
etc. We we invited some good friends.
D Hood came through. Y'all have to give a uh another round of applause for your good sister Dr. Tonee for bringing Uncle Harold Brian from the uh Krypto and Lady Rocket. Y'all got to give her her y'all got to give her her flowers now while she on the on the kid up here. You understand? Did she take off yet? No, I see her. You know, I give y'all appreciations, wow, and claps. Um, and Dr. Tony, Dr. Tony, you want to make
that announcement to the to the group right quick that you text me? Y'all can let them know. You can let you can let them know, doc.
Lady Rocket actually announced it, but I've been waiting until now for us to uh be able to announce that we are officially launching a joint venture to offer our VC uh venture capitalist firm. as well as our incubator accelerator to you all. So, that's been my primary goal in helping you guys understand how to fully and thoroughly position yourself in business so that you can start raising capital. You don't we don't have
to do it the hard way.
We don't have to use credit. We don't have to use our our revenue. We don't have to use our earnings. We don't have to go into debt doing business. That's what venture capital raises are for. You don't pay that back. You learn how to structure your company properly. Increase your valuation so that you can offer equity. Do it the way it's supposed to be done. But these are all things that we are never taught and we we don't
get invited to the table. So this is our way of being able to bring us to the table for once and for all.
And do we see that y'all that we are we have our autonomous business or we have our app, we have brick and mortar business. We're smarter at it. We're faster at it. We're a collective with it. And look who we have around us to help us fund the damn thing. Right. I do have homies that that will come through and talk about the credit side of things.
Like you just heard Dr. Tonee say, it's like, okay, well, you ain't got that and you got a plan and you're ready to move on something and you're going to do this and you're going to have that and move forward like this. Why not have all angles, all aspects surrounding you? Why not have all this good family around you? And then and again, I know a lot of y'all told me, quite a few of y'all told me like,"Hey, Spin, look,
I'm gonna focus on Nick. I don't know about all this AI stuff and robots." Okay, De Hood got a robot. I don't I don't I don't got robots. I don't have rockets. I don't have But what did we hear in the connectivity of things? See, I I I never want to get on a stage or on a camera anywhere and force somebody off their own wishes. This was not to force you off your own business. And like I said the entire weekend, listen,
I'm giving you I'm giving you the look from an engineer, developer, and the CTO. I help companies do what they do but recognize what technology can be used to advance it.
Chief tech office I didn't say don't write your book. I didn't say don't throw your event. I didn't say this and that. I say okay well you have an app let's make it better. I'll introduce you to a person that has made millions in apps. I introduce you to people that has made made billions in robotics. Silicon Valley talks. um partnerships with some of the big wigs. And I know how some of y'all feel, okay, yeah, we we are
the melanated um community of North America. We the original people, blah blah blah. There's partnerships that we need in that Silicon Valley. I told you all my homies is Jewish. A lot of my homies is Korean. A lot of my homies is Chinese. A lot of my homies is Aritrian. A lot of my homies is European. Like, okay, well, fine. They're my homies. I'll bring them to y'all. Whether y'all like Elon, hate them. Doesn't matter.
Y'all heard what she said. We need to be on X more. You understand?
LinkedIn and X. We all love each other. Yeah. We She said we on there on Instagram. Be influential. Be nice. Be fun. Look cute. You want to get into this tech? You want to get into this money, you want to get into business, corporate business, we do LinkedIn and X, we do Nvidia developer newsrooms, we do Google engineer news rooms and we stay connected with that level. How long we going to stay connected at our own level
amongst our own friends and imagine to reach that level? We're not in the room with them. And I definitely wanted to make sure that even if we have made seven, eight figures in business, if we're if we're at the level we're making five, six figures in business, maybe we try to look for that first four figure spin, can I get a ban from this s*? I want you to see just like Shemar would know in the beginning of the seven
habits of highly successful people. I think it says begin with the end in mind. If I show y'all highend points, exit strategies, y'all saying,"Well, now that I'm kicking off, I could actually be this, this, this, and this, and approach the world like that." I hope we
understand. All right, I tapped in with Chad real quick. Let me see. I think I need a few more minutes. Okay, here we go. Here we go. Speaker of God said,"I'm at the gym about to start coaching, but I'm truly grateful to everyone on here who contributed and those who took the stand to change the world. Starting with yourself, peace, power, and prosperity, man. Appreciate that, bro. If you're in the gym, coaching, that's
what's up. Keeping people healthy." My brother, he in the building. All right, Chad. You don't even know what we've been through. All right.
I see y'all rocking today,
But I know you going to warm it up some more.
man. What's up, crew? Love.
What up? What up? What up? I know you going to warm it up some more. I mean, we've been through it. I've been putting them through putting them through it all weekend. All week I've been putting them through it. Coach Tony putting them through it.
Aku, you know what I'm saying? The whole HQ team. My brother Chad. Chad, give them your story. Chad, if they don't know you, Chad, act like we all been under a rock. Give us that storyline before you give us that game. Please, brother. Because it's really important. It's really important when it comes to the ownership of the AI, when it comes to us being leaders and everything that you had to experience. Your story, Brother
Chad, is is of monument within itself. So, give us five minutes to digest that story and let us get some game on these AI systems at the highest level, brother. Please.
Man, first and foremost, man. Much love, man. Hey, Spin, I just want to tell everybody what's going on. I'm plugging this thing up in the charger. Hope everybody is well today, man. Spven been working. He been grinding. Give me five seconds, Spin. I'm plugging this up in the charger, man.
come and tell you guys what's been going
Yeah, but it's good. Good dog. It's good. Okay. L up right quick. Definitely y'all. So, and I'll just and I'll just preface the question with everything that y'all have experienced again because this what I always y'all know me. I got to make this connection with everything that y'all heard. Do y'all truly believe and have the confidence that you too can make seven, eight, nine figures in technology with what you've experienced
this weekend? Just give me a one. Give me a flame. And I'm saying truly, are you confident to say, you know what, I can build the thing. I can run the thing. I can manage the thing. And I can connect the thing amongst my family and even take my five figures uh from my book deal, my five figures from my app deal with a little bit more elbow grease and a proper structuring to take to my VC family and I can take this thing
to and pass the moon. Do we have that confidence?
Do we have do we have a new backbone to say,"Y'all, you know what? I was kind of lost in business. I I was confused by the AI. I know I didn't know that this could go with this. I I kind of just been talking to chat and I kind of been just going I didn't know. Did the AI autopilot summit let you know? Did it make you confident? Did it give you confidence? Yes, indeed. Peace to the family. Peace to my brother Chad.
What's going on, man? So, everybody, man, much love to all of you folks here today. Y'all took a commitment to be out here on Monday, so I know y'all grinding. Um, blessed to be here, man. SP, I appreciate you guys, man. for the last decade, decade and a half. So you guys know I'm from Baltimore, Maryland, and we don't have access to anything, right? We don't got access to tech guys. We don't got access to resources, celebrities.
And so what we use AI to is to connect ourselves to the world and just to kind of build out our systems. Um, like I said, I'm from Baltimore, guys. I went to college, played basketball, and came into this world. And now we got, of course, the YouTube world. We got social media. But it's a real way to kind of use our influence. And what I like to build, guys, I like to build systems that allow us to kind of hack the algorithm.
You know, so many of us, man, got expertise. Uh so many of us got different talents. So many of us are the underdogs that nobody knows about that's really, really qualified. So the way that I leverage social media, guys, to get my point across, right? Everybody from where you're from is familiar with your skill set. They familiar with who you are. They familiar with the person that they grew up with.
So you going to have to use AI, social media, build the connections, guys, and expand one your network. So that's the biggest part about it, guys. Expanding your network and your mindset. Um, trying to navigate Baltimore guys, trying to stay out the streets led me to college. Then it let me out to Wall Street. That Wall Street game, guys, is way different than the streets, man. These guys is dressed up in suits, right?
So this right here, it was a doggy dog world. The space that we was in in the Wall Street world was tech world as well, guys. Right? Think about this. Everything that you doing from real estate to investing into Bitcoin, it's all tech based. And we are usually the last to the party. So coming here from Baltimore, guys, getting into the Wall Street world, getting into a competitive AI tech world, we actually the hustlers,
guys. We actually the minds, we actually the ideas, as Spin would call it, we the brains.
So I have been on a constant path, guys, to one, you know, empty out my brain, brain dump, and create ideas that we can execute. In the music world, guys, I help with the streaming, right? So for artists that need help with registration, that need to be able to qualify and get streams on these platforms, they need to be able to monetize first and foremost. So I build systems that help them monetize, guys, right? Tik Tok,
hit, YouTube, Instagram, verification is very important first and foremost. And then we build the systems, guys, as far as visibility. So you see a lot of people talking about clipping right now. The clipping infrastructure is about having qualified eyeballs. So I'm a guy that builds meme pages, guys, in whatever niche. Just imagine if you was in fitness and now you got 10 different fitness pages. One that discusses supplements,
one that discusses workouts, one that discusses motivation. You could leverage all these platforms to be a real fitness trainer to get your message across.
You guys are competing against people that are brands and influencers that got machines behind them, literally. So that's what this conversation is about, guys. just wherever you're from, whatever you got going on. Build your systems, build your machines, learn the tech, learn the stacks, learn the things that Spin is talking about, guys, and just go out here, man, and trial and error. I think that's going to be the biggest
part, man, is just stepping out here, man, and having some confidence in yourself. Ain't a lot of people sitting on a call like this on a Monday, and not a lot of people that look like us, guys. We are less than a 1%, man. So, salute to everybody, man. Um, spin, just the thing I want to bring you guys right now.
Thanks.
AI works in any type of industry. I don't look at AI guys as a shortcut. I like to build out processes manual. I think what if you look at what SP is talking about, he's talking about building out processes that's manual that you guys really good at and then turning it into a tech skill that kind of expedites the work for you.
So please be good at your craft and then we just use AI guys to simplify to be more efficient. So don't think this a shortcut more than anything. I just want y'all to be really qualified and really good at what y'all do. Um, Spin, anything that you got for me, Spin, um, let me know. You want to see some tech, you want to see some systems, you want us to talk about some of the stuff that we doing, man, you want to talk
about some growth hacks, whatever cool stuff we locked in on today, man, I'm here to be a
facts, bro. So, I did teach him in the summit.
servant.
I think yesterday we got into satellite pages and media pages like you said. I taught them I showed them how to master your personal page. So, what I did with Chad, I said,"Master your personal brand page." And then I showed them, of course, the Spin City HQ, the new Minty, black, gold, green, and how you can make pages, you know, based on that.
So, I got Spin City himself, Spin City HQ, and then Grace Bodics partnership.
Yes,
And then also I have my Athletics partnership.
sir.
So, I, you know, with the partnership, but I also own pages off to the side. Age of Acceleration, AI first, AI first entrepreneur being ran by avatars.
Yes.
You know, that's what So when when y'all hear me say that satellite pages, media pages,
Come
that's like a a chat focused thing to where yes, I'm spin, but y'all don't know that. Well, now y'all do. I own AI accelerated. I AI first entrepreneur. Those pages that teach the same message, but lead all back to the same links. Infrastructure.
on.
Y'all can do that with y'all books. Y'all can do that with y'all speaking engagements, your companies. Da da da. You can go be the person, right? But then also you can have a AI avatar even speaking a different language. I think I forgot to mention that on Hey Jam. You can have everything that you do in English.
You're doing Spin City HQ English and then I have Spin City HQ espanol because
Yep.
that's Sebastian in Spanish and we're hitting we're hitting the the uh Central American and South American markets with the same infrastructure.
I'd like to s
And when I make those when I make those uh courses and when I make those ebooks, I'm asking AI just to translate everything I've already done.
Hey, Spin. So, I'mma give him I'mma give him a little example real quick. Right. So, you guys y'all doing like content creation. Y'all hear people talk about like the AI clones and stuff like that. All right. All right. So,
Yeah.
I'll show you guys like my my codeex real quick so you kind of get like a idea. See, SP, I'll be able to turn this camera around. Boom. All right. So, look. I'm in my codeex right here, guys.
cuz I done built out a a AI clone version of myself. We call this UGC, right? So you guys got the user generated content.
Yeah.
The reason why I'm doing this is cuz in every single niche, guys, I can put together a prompt. This right here is doing a trending news skill. So anything in hip-hop that's happening, right? We got Kefi D, we got a Tupac story. Now I'm able to kind of research the content, use my AI clone, guys, from Hey Gen. All right. I got my voice clone from 11 Labs. So when we talking about a stack, I'm using hen, the combination
of 11 labs, and I'm using a prompt and codeex, right? So I'm picking three different technologies to create the content. Now that I got the content, guys, I can schedule it out during the day. All right. From this conversation that we having with spin, it's all about syndication.
So from a conversation like this, I'm going to go do my hip-hop news. I done a couple different stories. And then we can take a conversation like this, guys, and we can clip it up. So you guys say something engaging. SP says something engagement. Now I got content guys for the next part of the day, the next two, three days because of AI. I'll take a platform guys like something called Opus Clip. Opus Clip will take all
of the top moments from us having this conversation. Now me, Spin, Miss Shay, Miss Sincere, all of you guys now got content to create the conversation and then syndicating it, right? How do I get it to Tik Tok, Facebook, Instagram, YouTube, LinkedIn at a click of a button? That's your automation, guys. All right? I'm not spending time doing the tedious task. get the content, chop it up, put it on the platform. I can do
this while we on this call.
So, you just got to think about the time it would take other people that haven't mastered AI to do the same exercise.
Right.
That's that's all we trying to do is make you more efficient. All right, we got to pick the kids up at 3:30. My entire day as far as content, education is done.
Done. For sure, man. Hold on, man. My other my other brother just got in here, man. And y'all talk the same, man. Y'all from the same spot, man. My boy Chief SBS, man. Step in, give a quick intro. We politicking talking about moving the world forward with the AI,
What's good? What's good?
man. What's good, my brother Chief,
How you feeling,
What up?
bro?
man?
How's everybody feeling?
Always love, man. What up, baby?
You from Baltimore, bro?
Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
That's what he was saying there.
I'm around the way right now, man. What's up with you, big dog?
Yeah, I was uh I was born over east, bro. by by
Oh, you by my Hey,
Marbo.
look. I was 1508, man. Uh 33rd Avenue across from city. So,
Yeah,
you know your family.
I was born on East I was I lived on East 30th Street, but I left, bro. I got a
As you should. As you should,
B.
man. I'm in Owens Mills now, bro. Man, so we here with the people, man. Sincere. Always love,
Yeah,
bro.
for sure. That's that's happening.
Uhhuh.
What's going on? How y'all feeling?
What up? What up? What up, bro? You know what I'm saying? Y'all in here at the same time with the same uh style of voice. I'm like,"Look at these brothers, man, over here from Baltimore." You feel me? Y'all say Baltimore. I'm saying,"Man, I'm from California." I'm like,"Man, these are my brothers from Baltimore." Oh,
Yeah, for
for sure, man. For sure. So, uh, me and Chad,
sure.
me and Chad right now talking about these AI systems and how to cover social media. Um, how to cover social media,
Okay.
uh, the massive way, taking your personal brand. Um, s*, chief. I mean, we done been through everything. AI systems, robotics, rockets, venture capital, etc., etc. you know, I've been hit you because um you know there's levels to the game definitely and we do have venture capitalist that's around but the way you were able to structure my credit bro again I don't know what look I'm not going to talk about it I don't know
what button the n press all right but again hey I don't know what what the button press what have you been able to do with you know financial literacy uh the the you know everything that you do give intro.
Just give me an intro. Give them a spill who you are.
Yeah,
You know what I'm saying? We tapped in.
got
You've been able to help me monumentally in my career and I want to make sure my inner circle knows who you are and what's going on.
you.
That's all
Yeah. So um I I go by chief SPS um the SPS is the brand which is struggle before
right.
success. Um was born in Baltimore Maryland didn't really come from you know wealthy wealthy background. So when it comes to financial literacy the biggest thing is that most people don't really understand how to get access to capital. Um and one of the struggles that we have in the community, right, even when you have business ventures, when you understand systems, when you understand uh artificial intelligence, right?
A lot of times you still need access to capital to be able to throttle, you know, your understanding, right? Whether it's backing systems, whether it's marketing and getting in front of more people, whether it's understanding other people's audiences and understanding what it looks like to have your business and have your brain and have, you know, what you understand, but then getting in front of other audiences that don't
know what you know, but that can benefit, right?
Um, you know, me and Spinman tapped in and like even him I like we done had conversations like,"Bro, is you going to this event?" He like,"For what?" Like,"Bro, you you a you AI genius, right?" Like,"You got to get into the room, right?" And and a lot of times just sharpening each other's axes. So, that's really like what I'm about. But when it comes to, you know, I want to say literacy, right? Um, just to make it a short
conversation, right? Because I know that y'all been here. Um, my thing is like I like to teach people how to understand the bank system. you know, the things that they never taught us about the bank system. So, even something as simple as right now, most people go and set up business checking accounts, they'll start an LLC, get the EIN, but then when they go start the business checking account, they don't have a proper
strategy. So, like, um, I see we got some people in here.
Um, Sincere, I just see you, right? Where you where you located, sincere, my bad. Where you where you located at?
Costa Rica.
Are you born and raised there?
No.
Okay.
Uh I I live in Georgia and in Costa Rica right
Okay, got you. So, like Georgia,
now.
using Georgia for an example, they have different banks. Have you ever heard of a bank called Truis? Being from Georgia, have you ever heard of Truis?
I have a business account
Perfect. Right. So,
though.
most people don't know that even right now with Truist, uh, you can set up a business checking account with them, but they'll also pay you $400 just for opening up the business checking account. So, people don't, they'll go and set up business checking accounts to just get with Finax or just get with, you know, different banks, but they don't have a proper strategy.
sort of I like to teach people how to one get paid to open up your business checking accounts and start new relationships and then understand how to position your credit, how to position yourself so that not only do you get paid to open up the account, but then now Truis has a business credit card that goes up to 25,000 at 0% interest. So now they're going to pay me $400 to start the relationship, right? But then they're
also going to give me access to capital, grow and scale my business, and they're going to give it to me at 0% interest for the next 9 months depending on what card you get or the 12 months, right? Right. And then I also understand they they whenever you do applications, they pull only from Equifax. They're only going to pull from Equifax. So then I can run the same play with a bank like Bank of America. Right now, Bank
of America, who on the business side, they pull from TransUnion, but they're also paying to open up business checking accounts.
So now I'm going to set up new relationships with banks. I'm doing it every 91 days or every 3 to 6 months. And I'm setting new relationships, but I'm doing it strategically where I'm getting paid to set the relationship up. And then I'm going to get funded to grow and scale my actual business, right? And then I'm going to understand there's different products that I can qualify for if I position my credit correctly and
things like that. So those are the things that I like to teach. I like to help people understand not to just frivolously open up bank accounts, understand there's a strategy that you need to walk through as you're, you know, building these different relationships, understanding who they pull from, what products they have. And then you have like you know you see people talk about CDFIS you got you know uh community development
financial institutions as well that also will fund you brand new businesses and same thing right it's just understanding the proper strategy so what I do teach right and I hope Sebastian give me some time at some point for the inner circle I come in and give y'all just some of that um understanding and then you have something called somebody just said an internal bank ratings right so even most people don't know that the
more money that you put into a checking account they also build an
internal bank rating If you have direct deposit, if you have uh multiple different accounts, business checking, uh business savings, uh personal checking, personal savings, the more accounts you have now, you also build up what is called an internal bank rating score, which also helps with funding. So, there's uh some banks that do what I call verification on the front end. Hey, let me see your credit. Hey, let me see
your ID. Hey, let me see um you know what you look like on the front end. Some banks like American Express, they do verification on the back end. So you might get approved from a soft pull, soft inquiry, but then they they might do verification, you know, after you get the approval. So there's just different things that go into it, but I think that anybody that's sharp in learning AI, u one of the greatest things you can
understand is how not to have to use your own money, right? Most of everybody's in AI is paying for different type of subscriptions.
It could be opus, my guy said opus, right? depending on what level ops you get on there subscription if you're getting clawed if you're doing chat GBT um depending on what level of AI that you're playing with and the level that you're playing at it might be different subscriptions and stuff that you have to pay for my suggestion is getting access to other people's money allowing that to be the way you pay for the subscriptions
because the other part that we don't realize is that when you use the credit card to pay for the subscriptions you're going to get cash back you're going to get reward points you're going to be able to travel for free and get certain hotels and certain perks so now you don't want to just spend your money You want to understand how to maximize, right? Everybody drop in the chat, maximize. You want to be able to maximize
your spending. You know what I'm saying? So, even me, I just went to the BET Awards.
I got my first class flight right on Delta for $8. How? Because I understand how to use my reward points, how to get credit, how to use credit. So, we have to learn how to maximize, right? Don't think that, oh, you know, credit is one of those situations where it's it's for people that only have money. No, it's for everybody who's in business to understand how to maximize. So, that's that's why I don't, you know, anything
I pay for, I'm I'm using a credit card. I want to get cash back. I want to use my reward points. If your credit is not where it needs to be, that's okay. It's okay, right? It's okay. We got to do the work. That be the other part because we'll make all this money but then we won't sit down and do the work because understand that all billionaires, right? All billionaires, all millionaire, most millionaires and all billionaires,
they're leveraging banks money because the bank's money is always going to be longer.
No matter how you look at it, the bank's money is always going to be longer. Do you understand how many direct deposits the banks is getting daily?
Thank
Do you understand that people get paid direct deposit every single day from different
you.
jobs all around the world? Right. So, what they're doing is they they have to make money off something called interest. If you go look at Chase, they're doing, you know, I can pull it up right now. I don't even know if I can share my screen, but you know.
Yes. At the bottom, bro. Next. between the camera and that smiley
Yeah. Yep. Boom. Here we go. So, what happens is like you got, you know, even just something simple. Most people don't know that you can audit banks.
face.
The bank, we call it bank auditing. What does that mean?
I can go in and I can look at how much banks are lending. I can see how much money they made within the last 3 months. People don't even know that you can audit. So now when I go and set up business check accounts, I'm not just frivolously going to set it up. I'm looking at, okay, well, so I'm going use Chase for an example right now. Let's look at, you know, uh, loans to in loans to individuals on credit cards. Somebody
look at that number and tell me what the number is. Loans to individuals. Who what are we? Somebody say what are we?
Yeah.
individuals.
It's
How much money did they lend out?
Individual.
And it says quarterly.
over.
Quarterly was it was it how how much how many months is a quarter?
That's that four. That's four
Three month. Three, four months, right?
months.
Boom. So this last quarter they lended out over $29 million.
Three.
See, we do AI. Understand we do AI. But understand if you could get access to an extra million, extra 500,000, extra 250,000. and what you what you understand with AI and marketing and sales, right? Backend operations, things like that. Now, we can go and attack the world because we understand that most brick and mortar businesses, most people that even online don't even understand what y'all understand about AI and systems,
right? But just in credit card lending, over $200 million. So, don't think the banks have any shortage of money. The problem is is our shortage of understanding and our our uh uh um and us not really taking it seriously to put ourselves in position, right? Cuz I'm going tell you right now, Chief SB Best, I got they defin I'm part of that 200 million for sure. They lended me some money.
You know what I'm saying? I understand that I'm going to put myself in position to get access to the capital. So, you know, I I appreciate the short time, but I would definitely like to come back, man, and show you guys really like the way that we kind of dig into it, what we put on applications. I can give y'all a whole entire breakdown of how to get access to funding and just understand that the banks don't have a shortage
of money. And if you're someone you got to get your credit fixed, you know, we can help you get your credit fixed. But what I see a lot of people do is a lot of people neglect their credit, right? And we live in America, you you can't get a car, house, I don't care how much. There's people that you can have all the money in the world, you won't be able to get a house, you won't be able to get a car, you know, you won't
be able to get certain things if you neglect it, right?
So let's stop neglecting it and understand this is a part of the system that we it's a part of the system. It's the system that we live in. Every America's trillions of dollars in debt. If it didn't work, why would they be in debt? So a lot of time we run around and we think,"Oh, that's not getting into debt." A lot of times we're afraid of something that we don't understand. We listen to our grandmoms, our moms, our dads,
our aunts and uncles, but most of them weren't in business. Most business owners, if you go look at Apple right now, go look at Amazon right now, they got I'm talking about millions of dollars in debt. But if you go look at their bank accounts, they also have hundreds of millions of dollars, right? So we us as business owners, we got to understand how to go get access to capital. And then the biggest thing is not just
getting access is how do we deploy it properly?
what y'all learning right now with AI and systems and operations and marketing. That's the the mo the best way to deploy it is get in front of other people that don't know what you know about AI systems back what he just talked about with content. Most people don't know. So, if you can get in front of other people and you can use other people's money to get in front of other people, how much, you know, how much would how
long would it take you to, you know, make an extra uh uh $10,000 a month, right? Some of you might got to get to 10,000 a month, 15, 20,000. it don't it it just there's a system to it. So one is you know setting up the LLC you know I mean making sure you position yourself properly and having the skill set. The one thing I want to tell y'all that y'all are blessed is being a part of this is working with Sebastian. He's
giving you the skill set.
Most of us struggle because we don't have the skill set. We don't understand tech. One of the things I want you to understand what y'all doing right now everybody here you got to give yourself a round of applause because what you are learning is tech.
Right.
Do you understand how how much money has been made in tech that we we if you understand what I mean by we didn't get access to right they
Yeah.
have black tech conferences they have black tech week and this is in different cities this is not just an online thing tech is something that and that's why it's called black tech because usually we're not the ones making
Yep.
money on it so you're not just you know don't just think of yourself as someone who's just learning something. You're literally changing the entire trajectory of not only your family, but an entire culture of people by being black and learning tech. Y'all follow me? So,
Oh yeah,
some of y'all just coming in, y'all just think this, you know, don't think this s* sweet.
What y'all doing is is is is is legendary.
bro.
I don't care where you are right now. You are right now. If you're a part of this inner circle and you're learning this, you are a part of what's happening with being legendary. And that's just you got to have the right mindset though,
Backward.
right? It's legendary because most of us don't make money in tech. We don't make money on systems. Most of us always work for the system and work a part of the system. We've never been able to have ownership within the system. So, not only are you understanding how it works, now you're having to have ownership. There's no reason anybody should be playing around. It's legendary what what he got going on and y'all learning
it. But understand the biggest thing is ownership. Most of us, my guy come from Baltimore, we don't own, right?
All of our families didn't own anything, right? The best thing is go get a city job, go work for the city, go work at the hospital, go be a part of someone else's system. Nobody ever talked about ownership. So, you know what I mean? You know, we scheduled that I come back,
Yeah.
man. I know. Okay, man.
Hey hey hey real salute you big dog and just for all of you guys ownership is kind of like why I had to sit down real bro I had to go do
Yeah.
a fair bit so I was in Baltimore man I built I built the tech systems man that helped like Drake and Kendrick I built the streaming
Heat.
farms but I didn't have no IP guys I didn't have no NDAs I didn't have nobody protect me I didn't have trademarks all those things how
Yeah.
I learned it with a sentence that you know what I'm saying you can learn from somebody else's mistakes.
So the biggest thing that Ro said man was the ownership man and just even for me bro we always learned something from being around each other. I just learned a lot of stuff just from hearing from you today, bro. Just how you position yourself,
Okay.
what the 90 days look like, why y'all getting denials, the structure.
Yeah.
Like that's a big conversation that bro is giving y'all to take away from the headache. That's what this mentorship is. He can that one sentence right there change all of you guys headache,
right? Trying to qualify at the bank and not having your structure correct. That's why I didn't get no money, bro, for a long time. So, we just appreciate you,
No, for sure.
big dog.
But let's build. Yo, I'm here to build and let's work. Let's connect and you know, however we can collaborate and continue to collaborate and continue to build up our people, bro, that's really what it's about.
It's the impact. You know what I'm saying? But I know that AI is it's just legendary, bro. The fact that we get a chance to be a part of it. And I know that y'all doing big things with it. You know what I'm saying? Sebastian. No, I be tapped in to to an extent. I know what I know, but I'll be asking questions. I'm trying to learn more about it. But I'm telling you, bro, what's happening right now is legendary.
Yeah.
And I just want everybody not to sleep on it. Because sometimes we can be a part of something and not understand the role that you're actually playing within it. You know what I'm
Yeah. The role that you playing in. Yeah. That's that's a big sentence right there.
saying?
It's that it's that Yeah. the role that you playing because y'all you know what I'm saying?
before y'all came uh the Baltimore brothers. Um yeah, we have been through a lot of I mean the nitty and gritty of technology y'all y'all for what y'all know me for I definitely get this been the first time I ever put that put together a summit where I g I kind of gave away all my game. I'm like I put all my cards on the table and look I use chat like this call like this Gemini like this anti-gravity like this I connect
it to this and I go out there and I go close corporate clients I try this Dr. Tony tell me this structure that structure and then especially for the people that know me. Look who I became in in under a year. It's because of family like this. What I was able to learn, what I was able to learn and then apply. We always say,"Oh yeah, knowledge is power." No, it ain't. Cuz there's a lot of people that know a lot of s* that
aren't anywhere. It's unfortunate that they know so much, but they don't know how to get out of their own struggle.
They know so much about every book. They know so much about every website. They know so much about basketball, but they don't know how to get out of their own struggles financially. You dig what I'm saying? Cuz they didn't know credit. Because again, when I met Chief, Chief uh he seen me go uh go viral with with a with a play um AI systems from last year. He said,"Man, we'll come speak to the community." And then I know
we all we hang with other AI people. So I'm say I'll get in there and see if I can add any value. Him uh uh brother Mangler Uno um and a lot of folks a lot of folks from the from the 1% of him 500 even though we hang with other AI folks you know again the mind of a a mind of engineer is a little different. You know what I'm saying? So, I definitely laid it all out this uh this summit. And um I don't know. I know we had
like a schedule. It's heck it's heckle funny. It's like the Baltimore homies, they both, you know what I'm saying, need to hit on 3 p.m.
But Chad, well, I did ask you had to come in earlier. But I mean, if if if Chad if Chief, if y'all both have time, then Chief, give us some game. If Chad, you don't have time, you know, whoever got time and whoever want to chill with with with one another, you know, the family is more than more than grateful to receive uh tangible wisdom to move out of this summit. But y'all, what I'm doing is is the Q4 accelerator. And
that's why my dumb ass I'm talking about, yeah, a quarter is four months because what I'm doing is is Q4. And the reason why I'm taking four months to do it because September I'm going to help them build and then when real fiscal quarter 4 comes we should be able to run up a bag. I'm promising I'm promising all my people in the Q4 accelerator to get out of the year about five figures in technology.
Yeah.
I'm helping people make their first five figures in technology and I call it the Q4 accelerator, but I need to do it in four months because I need a whole I need a whole month so where they can learn and build and go through the nitty-gritty because everybody a lot everybody in here know when when we were doing Facebook ads and meta ads like Chad Focus know meta ads and all these satellite pages when you was doing it in
2017 n
you was looking at the meta like your eyes were burning overnight trying to figure out you know the highs the lows KPIs, the CAC, the return on ask me. You had to do it as a human. Now I can take all of my actual intelligence, put it in the claw and turn it into a system, and then I'll create a a meta ads watcher agent like we learned on uh Saturday. Now, the meta ads watcher agent is reporting to the content creation
agent saying that, okay, will we will um AI abundance my satellite page? And one of my two of my satellite pages in Spanish, they need to reverse engineer what what I said in English in America and then give it to my satellite pages and re-engineer it again with a hen clone. And that's all autopilot based on the the demographic, the interest, and the behaviors of the people that's hitting on my ads the most. Now I know
how to create organic content that's going to hit the same way that my paid because it's a paid algorithm. organic algorithm. Play them at the both times and that's what's going to make your ads cheaper.
I mean, when we get lead, oh, I get leads for $80. Some Well, if you would have made an organic piece, let the organic piece grow with maybe a $5 bump into your followers don't equal finances. I don't care if a n got a million a million followers. I know two people came to me in the last few months with a millions of followers and said,"Well, I only make I only make five figures a month." I said,"n, you're crazy. And you're
not monetizing your audience.
Mhm.
You're not knowing how to find the where they're hitting on the niche to where they're going to buy your thing, where they're going to get your thing." So,
They only got a sales funnels,
that's why I brought them all through, y'all. So, I mean, y'all can game them at the same time if if that's what's going on.
man.
But, yeah, y'all both just tapped in from uh Baltimore at the same
So let me let me let me let me ask a question. So with the Q4 accelerator,
time.
right? When um for is this the people that are already locked in or is this this is for people who are
uh three uh I think three or four people are locked in to Q4 accelerator,
Okay.
but this is day three.
okay.
This is that secret day three of the Emerald key holders in the summit. So, we're still in the summit for
Gotcha. Gotcha. So yeah,
now.
what I want to do, bro, is just like when for the people that actually lock in, you know,
Yeah.
for the people that actually lock in,
Come on.
uh, what we'll do,
I know how it is.
what we'll do is we'll put together a class during in the beginning of the accelerator and we literally go through and then also what I'll do, what I want to throw in is when they lock in, like essentially whatever they if if if it if it's funding they need,
Yeah.
if they need access to credit on the credit repair side, we'll just do it for free. We'll throw it in there for free for them. Um but and then for funding we can kind of walk through that. But for the people that actually lock in, I would like to actually like lock in with the people that locked in with you and and and and let's build with the people that build with you. You know, I gave a little bit of sauce.
I talked about the strategies. I understand that cuz the thing about um you know the the the funding or financial literacy sauce, it's not just sauce, right? It's a foundation. It's a whole entire foundation. And so what I would like to do is come in and actually teach the foundation of it so that people really understand and understand that even as they're getting the
Yeah.
AI knowledge, they can understand the foundational tools they need to get access to the funding to grow and scale their businesses.
Um cuz to make five figures a month, you're going to need um something called audiences.
Heat.
You're going to need marketing, right? You going to have to be able to go out and produce content, right? And so this is where a lot of people got to realize even to what he said when I did see Sebastian, it was an organic post. But now that you have an organic post, you could definitely put a DM ad. You could do a boost post. You could take that ad and run it on shadow pages, right? You got shadow page like Black Success
Today cost $75 for Black Success Today. They literally, you know, and he has over 200,000 followers. So, there's other marketing things that that we need to help them kind of understand and get to that five figure month in Q4. So, I would like to come back and and give them some sauce on the foundation of the funding and,
Yeah.
you know, just what I've been able to do with the marketing. So that even I throw another class freak, you know, I mean, another class that we do and I just go into chief Sebastian style, what I've been able to do with the marketing, um, some of the things that's helped me get the, you know, 800 and something thousand follows, but actually being able to monetize and make money. Um, as well, you know, understand the call
to actions, understanding how to set up these stripe accounts and things on the back end. uh understanding that whether it's webinar uh like you're doing a summit whether you're doing challenge book a book a sales call you know a lot of people are very knowledgeable when it comes to AI but it's getting the customer from
Yep.
the internet into the ecosystem and then from the ecosystem to make a payment you know I mean so that's what I just rev that that way because I know that you already gave them a million dollar worth
Yeah.
of game so if anybody ain't locked in already you know you know what I'm
Yeah, I can dig it, man.
saying.
We appreciate that for sure.
So we'll but just make
Y'all can tap in. And remember, y'all, it is an annual payment plan. You can get in for 361 a month.
sure
Or you can call me, text me right now. You can do it right now. Text me, get in on the in-house payment plan how you can. But yeah, I mean, my folks skipping out game. Y'all done heard from Dr. Tony. You know what I'm saying? Yard yada from
for the people that's on the payment plan too. For the people that's on the payment plan, one of the things that might be missing is just getting access to funding and getting your credit fixed,
peace.
Come.
you know. So even I I would just say lock in on the payment plan if you can right and make the investment not if you can it's making the investment in yourself because if you already had if you already were where you wanted to be then you would already be doing
Yeah.
it right the biggest thing we got to realize is that it's making the investment to thyself you know when you don't make the investment you know they say that uh procrastination one is the biggest nation but it's also the assassination of your destination and I want y'all to write that down your procrastinating right now you being procrastination it's going to basically to be the assassination of your destination cuz you
already know where you want to go and
Okay.
2027 is like right around the corner. So right now if you do procrastinate all you're doing is assassinating where you plan to go and we got to understand that we have to stop doing that because the the thing is oh you might have the thoughts of what if it don't work. Well if what what you're doing is already not working and you're still doing it then at the same time you got to do something different to get something
different. If what you're doing is not working right now and you don't make any changes, then what is going to change?
Right? My biggest fear when it comes to like investing in myself or just we have conversations, my biggest fear is staying the same. My biggest fear is staying right where I'm at right now because what happens if nothing changes? What happens if you don't lock in? Okay, if Sebastian gave y'all the game right now, what happens if you don't lock in for the rest of the year? Do you think AI is not going to continue to change?
And don't you want to be able to get access and be up on the new information so that it could change your situation? I know it's only day three, right? And it's probably two more days, but what you got to realize is that,
No,
you know,
we went through it.
people that Okay,
We went through it already, but it's the last day.
bet. So,
Yeah,
even today is the last day,
we've been through
right? If today is the last day, right, for the people who haven't locked in,
it.
what what what are you waiting for? Is it is it what what exactly would you be actually waiting for? Sometime people be say,"Hey, I'm looking for a sign." Right? The sign is that the sign is that you're already here. See, you've already been praying for your life to change. You've said the prayers. You talked to Jesus, right? You've gotten on your knees, right? You've already said all the prayers, but then you come to
the class and then it's the same story how when they said, you know, who's heard the story when they said that God sent the boat to come save the guy and the guy say he's waiting for God to save him.
All
Who's heard the story? Right. So, the boat is already here.
Yes.
The but the the boat is here right now throughout the summer. The boat is here. The question is are you going to get on the boat? The question is are you willing to get on the boat? Cuz what you know what else is funny? I mean Noah, everybody laughed at Noah until the flood came. Then it wasn't funny no more.
right.
So even right now in this situation that you're in right now, it might your your peoples might not understand, your family might understand, this person might understand. But understand the flood is coming and it's are you going to get on the boat, right? So I I know that he's gave y'all plenty of game. It's not I know that you know Chad came the other everybody that gave information is is great. It's going to change your
situation. But the most important thing is investing in yourself because it shows that you really believe in yourself.
It shows that you actually have the faith in yourself. It shows that you have faith in God as well. Because a lot of times God is looking at you waiting on you. He's waiting on you to move, right? What's the saying? We can lead a horse to the water, but we we can't do what can't we do? Once we lead the horse to the water, what we can't do? Somebody tell me, not Chad. Somebody tell me, once we lead the horse to the water,
what we can't do after that?
Make them drink it.
Can't make them drink. So, now that you've already been led to the water, like it's the thing is that's so crazy is that it's time to drink. You know why some people don't drink? because they because they're more committed to their past than they are their future. They're more committed to what they used to do, the friends they used to hang out with, right?
Then the future that they pretty much want to build moving forward. So, it's just, you know, for the people that haven't, which I don't know who you are, I just pray that you make the right decision for your future because sometime it's a tough
What happened?
decision. Sometimes it's doing something different to get what you need differently. Sometimes you can't just stay the same, right? We got friends and family we talk to every single day and it's like they but when we have conversations they not it's not a profitable conversation. We're not having conversations about getting to the millions. We're not having conversations about, you know, and it's funny like right now y'all
learn a lot. Hey y'all. How many times have y'all been able to get off the phone, call somebody that you know, and y'all tell it's like,"Wow. They not in the room. They not in the room." Right? The most important thing that you need to do is, matter of fact, and lock in with the people that's here that's in the room.
Get accountability with the partners that's here in the room. The people that's worried about AI, that's looking at starting AI businesses and softwares and systems and all that. Like that's what you need to be doing. So I know he gave you the game. I just wanted to let y'all know, man, everybody there's no reason why you don't invest. Not even just into him, but into yourself. Sometimes you got to realize you got to plant
seeds. Most of the time the reason why people struggle is because they don't plant no seeds. And if you ain't planting no seeds, that means you can't reap no harvest. And sometimes it's also sewing on good soil. I'm going to tell you right now, you know, Sebastian is good soil.
Thanks.
Like you got to be able to plant seeds and do it in good soil. I'm telling you, he gonna make sure that he's one, every call that's scheduled that y'all supposed to do in Q4, he not gonna miss none of the calls.
If you need him, he gonna be there every step of the way. He's going to answer the phone call. He's gonna answer the text. So, understand it's not just sewing the seed is understanding, are you dealing with good soil? Anytime that somebody come and do a summit give you all the game, that means the soil is there. You just got a plan that you still need some water. You still going to need a little sunlight. You still going
to need some Jesus.
rest.
I ain't going to lie. You going to need Christ for sure. But I'm telling you, Christ can't do his part if you don't do your part. You got to do your part. We all love the Lord. I love the Lord as well. But what happens if I don't do my part? What happens if I don't invest? What happens if I don't study?
Cuz it's not just getting in here right now. It's also like, are you going to go and study? When you get access and when you locked in, are you going to study? When everybody else is going outside drinking and smoking hookah, I like to drink smoking. No, no, no. Yeah, I do it, too. But when everybody doing that,
There we go.
is you locked in? Are you going to be in lockin season?
Easy.
You know what I'm saying? Making $10,000, 20,000, 30,000 a month is not hard, right? People, all of you guys can do it. But you got to have a coach. Do you know how good Michael Jordan was? Does anybody know how good Michael Jordan was,
Here we go.
right?
There you go.
He was great, right? But what happened? He didn't win no championships until he got Phil Jackson.
Most of y'all are Michael Jordans right now in your life, but you ain't got the Phil Jackson. So you so you winning, right? Like which means you might be getting to the playoffs and you and you and you dropping 63 at Boston in the Garden, but but you getting bumped. Next year you might be playing Detroit. You getting bumped. But when you get the right coaching and you get the right team around you with the right coach
and now it's nothing that can stop you. Some of y'all all y'all missing is the coach. SP, how much is the what's the investment to the to the accelerator?
Okay.
Uh 4,000 a,000 a,000 a
Okay, $4,000. Okay, cool. You $4,000 and you said you going to help to make five figures or at least 10,000,
month. Yeah. And and I got a guarantee on it.
right?
If they do the work and they follow the work and somehow we don't we don't make five figures by 2020. That's why I need four months.
I can get in with them, get down to the nitty-gritty and help them make their first five figures in tech in in tech business, being a founder, having apps, having websites, having workflows, having summits,
Okay,
having webinars.
cool.
However, if if they don't make it,
Got you.
I can give them their four bands
All right, cool. So, they got a guarantee. So, at the end of the day,
back.
who I'm just asking, if he gave you $10,000, who wouldn't put a who who wouldn't get $4,000 back? That's my question. He's giving you $10,000 minimum. Who wouldn't give $4,000? Raise your hand if you're the person and you're like,"Nah, I don't want the 10,000. I'll just keep my 4,000."
Yeah, I make sure that and then I'm helping them make it.
Yeah. Yeah.
So what you going to make that following year as a tech founder and
No, I understand. We know. We know that. But some people
and we know you me who else we know and been around the summit Dr. Tonee and we going to space and we got all this. Are you going to become somebody you never even recognize in the
facts. The biggest thing is just like some people don't look at it where it's like you're basically getting 10,000 to get
mirror?
4,000 10 and that's minimum he we like he said. So now you're going to have all the skill sets to make let's say you make let's just say you make 50,000 next year who wouldn't get so let me ask you a question. If he's going to give you 60,000, you wouldn't get 4,000. Somebody tell me, tell me. Is that Can somebody raise their hand? Be real and say, is that a bad investment? $4,000 and you make 60,000. Is that a bad investment?
Shay, I see you. Is that a bad investment, Shay? I'm calling on you. Yep. You. Is that a bad investment? 4,000 you make 60,000.
Absolutely not. No.
Okay. Okay. So understand that if you know it's not a bad investment, then at the end of the day, the best thing that you can do is invest in yourself. Cuz what happens when you keep your 4,000? Now you keep the $4,000, you don't make the 60, that's a $56,000 loss. Now, who's in the business of losing 56,000? Somebody raise their hand, tell me. I
Matter of fact,
mean,
matter of fact, and look what Dr. Tonee is saying. All y'all that's been here, all Q4 attendees will have opportunity to pitch to RBC's now. Now, all now chief, they damn they're putting 100 grand, 200 grand, quarter million on on loss.
Yeah, I mean it was already it was already that anyway without you even adding it.
But ideally, it's just do they want to? Cuz most people what happens is you keep the $4,000 or you keep the 361 or you keep the $1,000 a month. You keep that. But you don't gain the information, the resources, right? You don't gain the information and the resources. What people got to realize is we have to start valuing information and resources over the money that's in our bank account because the money in your bank account
is not necessarily going to make you more money unless you put into a high yield savings stocks or something like that. But how much is resources and information going to make you now this is for people to execute. If you're someone who now if you're lazy and you don't execute, I would tell you don't get in. I'm going just tell you that right now. Don't waste your time, his time, nobody's time. But if you're someone who's
going to execute, right, tell me that the relationships and the resources is not what's going to take people to the next level.
It's the relationships and resources. That's how life work. That's how life move. Everything is based on resources and relationships, you know. So, and I'm telling he plugged in, you know, spend look, you know, he's plugged in with a lot of people that have information that have resources. Sometime it's not just the AI it's hey Sebastian I'm trying to get this done okay who can I plug who can he plug you in
That's all good.
with but when you don't pay the money now you can't get plugged in now you got to take the long
Yep.
route which going to cost you even what more
Mhm.
Chief, one of the slides, bro, one of the slides on the Q4 accelerator says,"Look, I'm asking for four months,
Hey,
but I can give you two years back." You know, this whole AI stuff is about time saving and and collapsing that timeline. So, I'm like,"Look y'all, if I if you can if I can tax you a little, I can make you a lot because again, I can get you in a room with everybody y'all been in the room with this weekend." And a lot of people would tell you,
Chief, y'all give Chief Y'all y'all let Chief and Chad know, give him a one in the chat. Give them give him a word of encouragement of what you've learned this weekend, how and how valuable it was for 300 bucks.
Yeah, it's probably too cheap. I already know.
We already know, bro.
I already know it's too cheap. But yeah, for me, for those of you who have locked in, man, lock in. If you need to do make the money, shift around. You got to make something happen, man. Don't don't be the person that um that don't lock in and stay right where you are right now going into 2027. You know, the new year basically starts right now.
All
And it's the it's really what people don't know is the decisions that you make today that's going to determine your next year. Most people upgrade their, you know, new iPhone coming out. A lot of people going to upgrade their phones but haven't upgraded their mindsets,
right,
haven't upgraded their mentorships, haven't upgraded the coaching. And the biggest thing is how you make decisions and how you are where you are today is based upon how you think.
There it
The only way you can change that is if you upgrade your you have to upgrade the thinking.
goes.
How do you upgrade the thinking?
Back.
You got to get around people that think differently. You got to get into environments that are different, right? So, and maybe the maybe the money is an issue. If you know where I come from, if the money is the issue, that's the reason why you need to do it. Because that same thing, if if you don't change,
Hey.
then nothing changes. And if you know that right now you need something to change, you need something to happen in your life, then there's no way you can continue doing what you've already been doing and you know it's not working.
So, you know, that's my my my couple cents,
He is
man. But, you know, I I do love y'all. Uh,
spinning.
Sebastian, just let me please keep me once you start the Q4, bro. Let's let's let's let's get the class locked in, you know. Uh, y'all can follow me. Um,
Yeah.
you
Put that Put that IG up in there. I follow all the homies,
know,
all the teachers, everybody that that I I I brought to the table. Everybody that Dr. Tony brought to the table, Dr. Tony herself. And again, those Dr. Tonee and that side of my of my circle is a little bit more secret than me, Chad, SBS, Justin Burns. You know, we out there doing entrepreneur. Y'all see that. We all know what Dr. Tonee and them
Yeah. And just let me know if y'all was here.
do.
Just say,"Hey, I was I was, you know."
And then Yep. I'll send you all the names, everybody that's locked in and then I'll call you,
Yeah.
bro.
I'll call you cuz it's going to start tomorrow.
Let's let's let's let's log in,
The buildin section,
bro.
like I say, it's Q4, but it's four months.
Yeah.
Because if I can get them to build the system, build the app, look at the app, they got it, they got the infrastructure right, build their social media, build their automated emails, build their outreach with the Goji Berry Times, the the chat chat, GPT, autoclaw, and I can get them rolling. A lot of them gonna make money in the next couple weeks just off the bill. But then when real Q4 fiscal Q4 get here, we gonna really
be, you know, stepping it up. So it might be monumental to lock in with you and Dr. Tonee in September. So they know the the credit, the assets, the the systems u with Chad and the VC points and how to pitch and how to build and how to get your paperwork right, how to get your how to get your math right with the banks.
Yeah.
Dot dot dot. You dig what I'm saying? So that's how we gonna do it, bro. September. September to remember. Overdrive. October. We automate everything. No nonsense.
Heat.
November. We stand on our prices. We stand on our slides. We stand on our pitches. We go high uh high uh ticket sales, five figures, six figure closes with corporations, putting AI in their system, or we just run up our own companies. Again, that's why I say I can get a person five figures. I can get them 10,000 um by the top of the year. Give me four months. Give me four months. both I give you and I and I and I I should
be able to return. And then getting you a business, getting you a system, getting you a mindset, and then getting you a circle. You'll throw you'll throw a summit where it's me, Chad, Chi, Justin Burns, Dr. Tonee, and we join you. You know what I'm saying? We're saying it's like, yeah,
Yeah.
if I tax you a little bit, man, I can make you a lot for
Yeah. For sure. Yeah. Trust me,
sure.
that that'll be uh anybody that take that offer and we come in and and talk to your people.
Yeah.
Yeah. So yeah,
Okay.
man. I appreciate y'all. Nice meeting y'all. Whoever followed me, just send me a DM, man. Let me know y'all was on the call. Um, let me know who all locked in, bro. Let me know who locked in. And, um, and and for those of you who are locking in,
Yep.
I just want to congratulate you to the rest of your life. Like, congratulate you to making that that that decision um, for the rest of your life because
My will say pe bro right here.
now
Jessica Lewis. Look, I didn't even pitch the thing in. I just so happened to launch it on the on the list of things.
I'm still trying to sell people on the third day, the Emerald Key. And Jessica Lewis was the first person. I don't know. She just seen it like at the end of day two and bought it before I can even get to day three. So definitely got to shout her out.
Yeah,
You definitely want to We definitely want to shout out congratulate Syncere Newman for tapping in.
congratulations.
She's all the way in. And I believe, you know what I'm saying, our sister Shay and TSC ELITE going to get up in there. So far that's why I know that is that is uh show extreme
Yeah, that's why I was talking to Shay. She I was talking to Shay.
commitment.
You know what I'm saying? We pray we we pray we see Shay in there.
Okay.
You know,
Yeah. We pray.
she got Yeah.
We pray. Stay
She been praying already, but we pray. We pray as well.
I'm I'm literally I'm in a I'm in a strange situation right now.
love.
So, it's work.
Yeah.
is data wick.
Yeah. Trust me, we all been there. That's the the reason why you are in the situation because, you know, the Lord wouldn't put nothing on you that you couldn't handle.
Hey, hey, look This Lance about to get to work.
Take that.
First of all, Terrell Brown got one of the best sales funnels too. Your team, y'all rocking and rolling too guys. So yeah y whatever he's saying guys and rocking he already got the infrastructure implemented.
Yeah.
So spin salute to you man. Salute to having Mr. Brown on here bro. One of the guys from around the way.
I'm going just tell you this. Not knowing bro from Baltimore that's how big the world is guys. Extremely successful.
He done amazing things and Sebastian brought me on my awareness man. So Tyrell Brown you and your team keep rocking. I already been in the DMs a part of the funnel. So now something like this a call two three years Sebastian can bring homies together that we grew up on the same street guys
Yeah.
my family went to MVO his family went to the same high school we from the same block it took three years and a couple DMs and this the type
of synergy that you get because of what Sebastian city working on here bring two homies together that's from the same
Yeah.
street All
Yeah. I didn't even know it. That's crazy.
And y'all had to get on at the same time. I'm like, I hear Chief the other day. I hear Chad the other day. I'm like, Chad, bro, can you come in?
right.
Can you slide through at about 1, two?
Can what can we get, Chad? Chief said,"Okay, I'm going take the 3:00 spot." Chad like,"I'mma come in at three." I'm like,"Bro, these bomb like they on that. They on that need more because they both like 3 p.m. Eastern.
But you know, bro,
We on
that's divine. That's divine, bro. You can't a lot of stuff is just divine,
Yes.
bro.
slide
I mean, that's why I like really, bro, you got to move in with the Lord. You I mean, just in general, I'm not I'm not a pastor. I'm a sinner. I'm I'm going to tell you I'm a I'm a sinner. You know what I'm saying? I've I've sinned. I've fallen short, but I I believe in God, bro. So, I know a lot of conversations, my network, a lot of stuff is divine. So, it's just meant for us to kind of connect and collaborate and build.
And that's why we here. You know what I'm saying? So, even shout out to you, Sebastian, for putting people together and bridging the gap. And for and for those of you that are here, like it's the same thing. I'm telling you, it be divine. That's why you can't sleep on divinity. You cannot sleep on the divinity of it. You know what I mean? You can't sleep on that. So, I appreciate y'all. But yeah, uh Chad, um I get your
number from Sebastian, bro. Just man, Sebastian, put us in a group chat. Put us all on a group message or something,
All right.
bro.
Appreciate it.
All right,
Yeah.
bro. Appreciate you,
Let's let's work.
Be safe,
bro.
All right,
Rodie.
bro. Y'all be safe.
Much love,
That's a lot.
And and and welcome to everybody that joined,
guys.
the one that's going to join will join. If you're in a strange situation, look, I promise you, we all been there. It's you're not the only one. Even as we get successful, we be in strange situations. Trust me, it like it don't stop. But understand, you just got to have that faith in yourself and just know who you are and know whose you are. When you know who you are and who you are, you ain't it's nothing to worry about.
So, we'll leave y'all with that. Appreciate y'all. I'm out.
All right, brother. I'm going talk to you in a minute.
Thank
Chaz, you already got about here.
No, I was cooling for a
Okay. Yeah.
second,
You got you got any any any choice words you wanna you wanna you want to get in here?
I don't want to cut it off. You know what I'm saying? We had a little schedule the the the b,
man.
but if you guys if you guys a little bit more, man, we could go, you know what I'm saying? With with the with the family's um graces and love,
You mind you you?
can we can we provide a little bit more value?
Of course. Of course. You mind if I share my screen?
Yep.
All right, cool.
Let's cook up.
Let me show y'all something real quick, guys. Share my screen with the
How y'all feeling about the How y'all feeling about the AI autopilot summit now?
crew.
How y'all feeling about Q4 Accelerator now?
All
Yeah.
And see, that's what I'm saying about Jessica, man. You're a particular person cuz you didn't even know what you was getting yourself into. You like, man, I'm going to throw your bag right quick.
I don't know what it's for, but here I come. So, that's what's up, man.
right.
That's That's real.
Maybe you can see the future or something.
All right.
I felt it.
Hey, SP. You can see my screen, Spin.
Yep. It's right there on the phone.
All right. Cool. So, look, guys, just so y'all y'all understand what I'm talking about, I'm going to go through my profile just real quick. The thing that spin is giving us guys is that he algorithm hacking right now. So if you going to your explore page, right, you going to see somebody like spin here. When you run into whatever content you see on your explore page, you more likely to engage. All right? The way that a
lot of people getting this done, they using Instagram guys as a search engine. All right? Whatever your algorithm is showing you going to be in your explore page.
So everything that you into, that's going to be a part of your explore page. All right? This is your algorithm. I'm competing against people guys that's in the music world, right? So, I'm going to show you this music marketing and I'mma break down why why you doing on automation got to make sense. All right, so music marketing guys, these are the top people in the industry. All right, we got a kid named Promo Guard. I
got a kid named Chris Tyson. I got keys the promoter. When I'm talking about sales funnels, just watch how simple this is. Run Instagram music. Chris is creating content. He creating content based in the music marketing. He got a really dope profile. We come here, guys, and we check his automation. His automation is going to take us to a link tree page that got every last one of his promos.
All right. What is he running? He running a master class. All right. The framework of him creating a master class. I got to go ahead and reverse engineer exactly how he creating the content. Y'all understand what I'm saying? So, the idea is now I got to rebuild his exact funnel. And how is he doing it? I'mma use Opus Clip. All right. My automation is going to come from talking head content, guys. So, webinars like we doing
right now, YouTube content, a day-to-day yapping is now becoming a content framework. All right? So, anytime I do a talking head or interview, guys, I'm using a framework like a Opus clip, yo, to take all of my clips, guys, because now I'm in position that I can syndicate everything. So, just sitting in the crib and hanging out, putting the content now has become a part of the content infrastructure.
All right. any of your whiteboard content, any of your day-to-day, any of your presentations, everything is already situated now, guys. So now all I got to do is syndicate the content and now it's scheduled out. All right, for anything that my competitors are doing, now I'm using chat GPT. I'm using Claude to get me the captions, the titles. So now I'm automating guys the social media process. All right. Now I'm going
to my Tik Tok, my YouTube, my Instagrams, my Spotify, and I'm making sure that I'm getting it done on all different platforms. Now I automated it. All right. Now I got a schedule and a calendar for my content. That framework is done. All right. I'm going to show y'all the biggest sauce, guys. Shout card. So y'all want to build up your announcements networks. That mean that any piece of content that you guys are putting
together, it can go viral.
So the most important part is how are you going to distribute your content once you done put together a piece that's gone viral. All right, Spin City creating organic content. You guys creating organic content. Now you got to syndicate it. So there's profiles in your niche. I don't care if you guys doing tech. I don't care if you guys doing fitness. I don't care if you doing motivational speaking. It doesn't matter what
industry in. There are other influencers just like what Terrell was saying that you can pay to get your viral video on their platform. All right. So you can see how many followers they got. You can see the engagement they got, the click-through rate. This is how you now stack your actual campaign. All right. So I know who my competition is, guys. I know what kind of content I had to create. Now I just got to do the work.
What Chris can't beat me with, guys, is that I actually got my own viral content. All right? So this same piece of content that I've done really well with is how I make all of my money. All right? My insight's not available right now, but this framework and this video, you can take it and now you can syndicate it on a shout card. All right, so getting famous is basically a budget. I'mma tie all this in. I've done the work,
guys. I got the organic edit cost me less than $50. That video has done well organically. I built the salesunnel, which is basically a calendar where people can come and they can get a booking and talk to the kid. Now, I'mma syndicate that content. I got $3,000. I'm going to go pie 20 pages, guys, and reynicate that content on those pages because now we're going to try to arbitrage their following. All right?
If they got 20 million followers, 10 million followers, they only get an engagement rate of 2% 10%. We know what to expect now from a campaign. All right? That's how you go and get famous, guys. You're using your content and using leverage. The last one I'm going to give you guys is fame swap. All right? You got shout cart using other people's platforms. Fame swap is about using all the AI skills you got using content
and now building your own ecosystem. So I'll go on Fame Swap and as a broker guys I'll buy other profiles that are already what generating content traffic in a certain industry. So based off of your capital you can be famous tomorrow. If we don't have the money then we go deal with Mr. Terrell. That's where you put your 50,000 $75,000 $100,000 at. You create your own content ecosystem where you now syndicating your content
on these profiles that is not based off of one theme or one niche guys.
Now it looks more organic. So if Sebastian got a video out where he is he's beating up a a alligator everybody in the world would share that. Right? That's evergreen type content. Now if he want to go viral you can share that content on all types of pages that's already got traffic. All right? Think about politicians. Think about your new artists. Think about new brands. They are using this type of leverage guys to go
ahead and hack the algorithm. If you got a hundred different pages that's reposting your content that got some type of authority, it don't matter what niche you in, you are famous tomorrow. So now guys, this how you conceptualize why Terrell is so important. Mr. Brown give you access to some capital. You can go ahead and buy your leverage, guys, to syndicate what you doing. I do this for athletes, guys. I do this for entertainers.
We do this for any and everybody based off a budget. If you don't have one, you go and create these accounts for free guys. It take nothing to get an email and go create these free accounts and then to continue to arbitrage your how you syndicate your own distribution. All right, so I just want to break you down on why that's important and and how you know fame works for a lot of different folks guys is based off a budget.
All right, what resources they using, what platforms we doing, how they automating those platforms. Just think of it now as arbitrage. All right. If we can buy access to your platform and we got a message, we going to send it out. That's why Terrell told you about the one page that he's spending $75. He's basically letting you know that he might spend $75 every day towards his advertising. But imagine how many other pages
that he's using, guys. What if he got a 100 pages that he's spending $75?
That's a $7,500 campaign. So now becoming famous and successful is a budget. You just got to kind of break it down a little bit. Spin, you follow with me?
Yo yeah, bro. I know where it's at. I know what's going on. Are y'all following CAD though?
Yep. Yep.
Can we get some ones? Can we get some? Do we understand what we just seen? Does that give us more confidence in it being six,
Yep.
seven figure earners? If we have the proper bill, we got the proper piece uh the the proper people around us that'll help us leverage the bank, help us leverage the systems, help help us leverage social media. And then we take that to our VCs and say, well, I've amassed over 2.3 million views over the last two three months and my personal brand should be worked as it is. Do you is is not uh the system from space in them
in the VC capital seats not about to invest in that?
Do we not just take our influence and our leverage from the bank and our own credit and then turn that over to our VCs and turn our five figures into seven and then our seven and a nine with with multiple brands and multiple deals, a S corp, CC Corp, multiple LLC's under umbrella. Are we not rich before 2030? And are we not in the first place of artificial intelligence, robotics, tech, software, hardware, and now rockets?
Who are
Come on. Hey, Finn. Spin, you got a summit today, right?
we,
So from y'all summit, all of y'all could have an opportunity to leverage this summit. So Spin can say,"Look, the 12 people that's on this call right now, the 20 people that's on this call, I need everybody to reshare this message that we got." That's how you guys arbitrage.
man? Chad,
If you you part of a community now,
I've been telling they ass this stuff all weekend.
hey, look, Spin, they could syndicate their content through your network.
And then guys, if y'all build a network plus spin network, just think about how much leverage you got now. If everybody come with 10 and we got 10 folks here, guys, now you got 100 people. Now the community sharing a message and we moving movements. It's way different now. Feel me? So that's all I want to give y'all with love and impact is how do you care?
Yeah.
Do you care enough about your movement? Do you actually care enough about your movement? My movement guys is focused, man. Like I told you, for me it's divine. Spin just brought y'all a conversation where it's a young guy. We grew up on the same street. He went to the high school that lives behind my crib. We never met before. We done a lot of numbers. Where we from? We've been both trying to make it out the wire.
We missed each other trying to make it out the wire. It took for Spin City to bring us on the summit,
That's
guys, on a Monday in 2026. I just look at my inbox. I've been talking to Brown and we've been hitting and missing,
crazy.
guys, for the last three and a half, four years. We live on the same street, ladies and gentlemen. That's what AI technology, but more importantly, that's what spin and divine life bring together, guys. So, that's why I say it's blessed. The network is more of a blessing than a skill
Facts. That s* was hard.
set.
It was hard. And I'm telling y'all hit me at the same time. I'm like,"Bro, hold on." And I then I know I do know where both of y'all from. So the whole time I'm thinking, I'm like,"Okay, well when Chief see Chad, they gonna say it's good." And you like,"Bro, you for me?" I'm like,
"Hold on, man. Them didn't even know each other."
Hey Finn,
Wait,
when I left, look this how crazy it is. I I went on a whole another side of Baltimore. So what he talking about is when he left, I went out to the county. So we might have just grew up and missed each other.
right. Yeah.
That's why I say God different, guys. We on a whole different path. He on the same street. He might have went left and I went right and we still ended up on Spin City Summit. It can't be no different than God,
Yeah,
guys. You understand what I'm saying? I missed this brother my whole life. We 40 years old.
that's what's up, bro. Appreciate you, Chad. Appreciate everybody.
Yeah.
How was the
Love and blessings to all of y'all.
song?
Spin, I check in, man.
Proud of y'all, man. Always love. Trust me. Ain't nothing but this what we got to do more as young folks, minorities. Me and Spinn don't got nothing but just love for each other. That right there alone in itself going to get the job done. So guys, please, please, man, appreciate y'all. Yo, man,
Yeah,
I check in soon.
we all good. I text you, bro. Appreciate you, bro. We going, y'all. How y'all feel about this now? Hey, are we out of words? Was it too much though?
out of words for real. Definitely wasn't too much, but I got to digest. Like, that's crazy.
Yeah, that was hard, John.
You just gave us so much.
That was hard. That was hard.
No other summit is all I have to say.
Yeah. No, the summit, man. It was overwhelming, fam. That was a good one, y'all.
That was healthy.
Like I haven't even been able to sit down. Like this is crazy. Much gratitude spent.
show y'all. Anybody that know me, I told y'all I had something different this time. And I know y'all watch me on social media. Oh, he giving away all the game. All right. He giving away all the game on social media. Okay. Well, look at the game. Did I get inside master? Oh, well. Okay. He kind of give away 50% of the game based on master. Okay. Well, let me lay it all out there. Let me give away 85% of the game on the
summit and well there it is and I guarantee you I just make again I make a personal guarantee a four figure five figure guarantee. Y'all run with me build with me in September and run with me and my new Spin City HQ team to next year. Your 10, your 20, your 30. I'll put it in your purse. I'll put it in your pocket. Run with me, y'all.
That's all I'm really saying. Y'all enjoy the rest of this good Monday, get some sun, walk around, exercise if you have it, get that good water, leave it all on your mind. Tomorrow afternoon, all of your assets come through. Y'all that have made it this far, come this far, pay for this far, all your assets come through tomorrow. Um, and I will have a slight class. I will have a slight class. It will be only 30 minutes.
So when you see the link and you get the link for um you for accelerator when you get that link just sit down with me for 30 minutes I'm just going to say something about how we're going to navigate everything. I won't cuz again the summit was so powerful I won't just let's get into the Q4 but it will be it will be a daily thing to get done and it'll be real real small because again I don't want it to be overwhelming.
I want you guys to be able to go back through the um the entire summit on replay with the notes, with the skills, with the connectors, with your resources for the next for September.
You know, the summit, it's summit September because we're going to break down these hours and extend it for the next 30 days and really tangibly building in those systems, putting those systems. And again, you know, because Shay asked me, it's like, hey, look, we're all a lot of you are saying, look, we're at different levels between building and marketing and scaling and social media. I'll meet you there. You know, it's
September to remember summit September. We're all going to go back through the summit in longer form because what do we what have we done now? It's like 24 hours worth of us sitting down talking, sitting around presenting. My math ain't no good right now. We got on 11. That's another five. Two hours on the VIPs. That's already nine. With a 8 hour first day and a 6 hour second day. Hell no. I'm not just going to Yeah, y'all.
Let's jump into Q4. That is why I made it four months. You see, hey, I'm a damn good planner. Yes, it has to be four months so we can all go back through this.
I can reexplain. I can re-establish. we can get back with those coaches that are going to come back for longer form classes. So now y that's what I'm saying. Walk with me because we're going to have How about a whole class from Chief FBS? How about a whole class from D Hud? How about a whole class from Lady Rocket? How about a whole class from Coach Tony? and they're lining up the business and getting ready you getting
ready to take your automated company to the moon. That's what they going to call it. A whole class with Chad and spreading and spreading the word far and wide through social media. Let's take that time. Let's build up. Let's have fun. Y'all know how I like to get, man. Can't make no functions without a little fun first. Uh I'm grateful for all y'all. Everybody that tapped in early, everybody that tapped in late. It's been
good classes. These resources will be AIized, strategized, and planned. Let's have a good September. Let's have a Let's have the greatest Q4 of our lives.
Of our lives on my guarantee. All right. Peace to the family. Uh, peace to you and yours. has been your family from the inside of AI, marketing, sales, credit, VC, inside of the game, inside of Silicon Valley, inside of tech, inside of mergers, inside the bank. I didn't want to be an AI influencer. I don't want to be an AI guru. This is automated AI business. That's why I brought the credit, homies. That's why I brought
the social media, homies. That's why I wanted you to hear from somebody that has worked in the music industry. Couple folks worked in the uh music industry already. Uncle Hero been in the music industry since I was born. Chad works with Drake. Chad works with people in the NFL. They work with them. Let them work with you. Peace to the family, the people you and yours and your brother from the inside of AI in the AI autopilot
summits being city. All right y'all stay healthy. Take care. I will see y'all where I see y'all at.
Thank you,
Peace.
brother. Take care, everyone.
Take care of
Thank you.
Peace. Peace. Peace.